GOOD
AFTERNOON AT FIRST AND FOREMOST
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE ABOUT AT
STARTING THIS MEETING A BIT
DELAYED BY AN HOUR. WE ARE
LIVING IN INTERESTING TIMES AS
YOU ALL KNOW AND- THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUES TO FOCUS
ON AT BEST PRACTICES FOLLOWING
HAPPENED APARTMENT A PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES IN VERY FOCUS
ON THAT- THROUGHOUT THE
MORNING. HERE WITH OPERATIONS
IN THE LEGISLATURE SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE- IN
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
UNDERSTANDING AND AS SINCERELY
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE DELAY- ON
BEHALF OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE WE
WELCOME YOU. TO THIS LONG
STANDING TRADITION OF THE FORTY
SEVENTH ANNUAL ZEKE GRADER
FISHERIES FORM HI MY NAME IS AT
MIKE WEIR OF HONOR TO BE ABLE
TO CHAIR- THIS- ESTEEM COULD BE
ALONG WITH OUR VICE CHAIR SOME
NUMBER STONE WHO HAS BEEN JUST
SO SOLID ISSUES OF FISHERIES
AND REALLY BEFORE. PART WE
WORKING WITH. WHEN WE Q. I TO
ALL OF ON TO IS FROM NIGHT.
MANY OF YOU ARE HERE. AND WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR WORKING IN IT
THE WHAT MASON. BOUNTY FROM. I
TOOK AN AMAZING AMOUNT OF WORK
WE DO WANT TO SAY HOW
APPRECIATIVE WE ARE OF YOUR
HARD WORK- IN YOUR GENEROSITY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS-
YESTERDAY EVENING IS A GREAT
EVENT. THIS AFTERNOON WE WANT
TO WELCOME ALL FISHERMEN WHO
TRAVELED FROM ALL CORNERS OF
THE STATE THAT TO BE A TO BE
WITH US IN THIS TIME HONORED
TRADITION IN IN THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. FOR NEARLY
ABSENT EAT. CALIFORNIA IS FISH
SPECIFIC A ORGANIZATION AND SO.
COUNCIL AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
FISHERMEN COME TOGETHER. TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IN ANNUAL
REPORT. AND THAT REPORT IS
VOCAL FOCUS ON THE GOALS IN
ANNUAL ACTIVITIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS- IN IT HAS BEEN
A BUSY YEAR SINCE THE LAST TIME
WE ALL MET. IN IT'S BEEN A BUSY
YEAR FOR THE FLEET. WE HEARD
FROM EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
IN THIS AUDIENCE TODAY ABOUT
THE NEED FOR DISASTER RELIEF
AND- FINDING IN SOME GOOD NEWS
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
DIRECTOR BONTA FOR HIS ADVOCACY
AND- ALL THE ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ARE HERE TODAY. WE FINALLY SAW
DISBURSEMENT THE FUNDING FOR
THE CRAB FISHERY- AND AT FUNDS
WERE SECURED FOR SALMON
SARDINES INTERACTIONS- WE ARE
NOT DONE WITH THOSE FEDERAL
DOLLARS. I EIGHT IN NO THAT IT
WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU WHO
ARE HERE WITH US WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR ADVOCACY. IT HAS
BEEN 1% ALSO BEEN. STATION IN
THE LAST YEAR WE'VE ENACTED
LEGISLATION FOR THE FISHERY A
REACHED SALMON STEELHEAD HOW I
HAVE HOW THE WHALES CUCUMBERS
IS A NUMBERS FAVOR MARICULTURE
AQUACULTURE AS WELL AS
PROTECTING THE INDUSTRY FROM
EXCESSIVE LANDING FEES AND MORE
I IN THE DIRECTOR AND I ARE
GLAD THAT THAT IS OVER AT MY
RIGHT MISTER DIRECTOR THAT OUR
RIGHT THERE AGAIN. GOOD TIMES-
BUT LOOK HERE'S THE BOTTOM
LINE. WE STILL HAVE CHALLENGES
AHEAD. I THIS SEASON WERE
SUFFERING FROM TO DROUGHTS. ONE
IMPOSED BY THE WEATHER. IN ONE
OF THE HANDS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
POUR WATER MANAGEMENT. CAN KILL
MORE THAN 95% OF OUR BABY
SANDING. AND ALONG WITH LOW
RAINFALL THESE CONDITIONS CAN
CREATE A PERFECT STORM. OF
SALMON KILLING EVENTS. AND
WE'RE JUST ABOUT THERE WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION RULES THAT
HAVE JUST BEEN RELEASED. THESE
LIMITATIONS ON WATER
DRAMATICALLY IMPACT- THE SALMON
FISHERY IN ITS CAN IMPACT OUR
ECONOMY. FROM CALIFORNIA ALL
THE WAY TO THE GREAT COUNTRY OF
CANADA. AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
LAST SEASON WAS ONE OF OUR BASS
SALMON SEASONS IN DECADS AND
THIS DECISION BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE THESE DANGERS NEW RULES
WILL HAVE DEVASTATING IMACTS
ABOUT THE SAN JOAQUIN AS WELL
AS THE SACRAMENTO. WATERSHEDS
OUR NUMBER ONE GOAL OF TODAY'S
HEARING IS TO HEAR FROM ALL OF
YOU. HERE ABOUT THE ISSUES AND
TO BE TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
PRECARIOUS STATE OF OUR
FISHERIES AND EDUCATE THE
LEGISLATURE RESIDENTS ABOUT
YOUR STATUS- AND AGAIN WE ARE
SO GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU
TAKE THE TIME. I DO WE HAVE TO
BE HERE TODAY BUT BEFORE WE GET
INTO OUR ALL STAR LINE UP A
PANELIST LIKE TO BETTER TURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO VICE CHAIRMAN
STONE WE'RE GONNA WELCOME. BOTH
THE SECTARIAN AFTER RESOURCES
BECOME FORTIES WELL AS A
DIRECTOR OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GOING TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP CIRCUITS
YOU. THANK YOU VERY HAPPY HERE
UPON APPRECIATE THE JUST FOR.
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND CALM.
AND THEN THIS FIX THE MIDWEST
THE PACK. THAT YOU HAVE SUPPORT
DURING A- THOROUGH CLEANING IS
THAT WE- THE THINGS THAT ARE
FOR. BUT I WANT TO THE
FISHERMEN WHO SHE- LAST NIGHT.
ABOUT OF THAT WAS A FAB. DINNER
AND AS PROMISE THEN. IN TRADE
FOR THAT WE MAKE YOU COME AND
SIT THROUGH A LONG HERE
AFTERNOON. THIS IS WHAT THAT'S
WHAT YOU DO THIS IS WHAT WE DO
IS SIT THROUGH LONG HEARINGS.
BUT ALSO IN THAT. HAVEN'T GONE
TO A NUMBER OF THOSE FEES WE
DID NOTICE THAT THERE WAS FAR
LESS CRAP THAT WE'D SEEN BEFORE
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE GREAT NEW
SHOOTERS. AND THAT'S
APPROPRIATE WE WERE REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH THESE FISHERIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CRABS. THE SEA URCHINS SEEN THE
LOSS OF CAL SEEN THE DRAMATIC
CHANGES HAPPENING IN OUR
OCEANS. SO WE SEE REFLECTED ON
THE DINNER TABLE LAST NIGHT.
ALWAYS REMINDERS OF WHAT IT IS
THAT WE'RE WORKING FOR AND
TRYING TO SOLVE HERE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR YEARS ON THE NET TO
THE CELL MONADS. AND THE
HABITAT ISSUES THAT THEY
REPRESENTS. AND IF WE'RE NOT
CAREFUL WAY INSIDE WE
ABSOLUTELY CAN CRASH THAT
FISHERY ON THE OCEAN SIDE AND
IS A- MEMBER OF THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THAT OUR
SECRETARY. IS THE- IS THE
CHAIRPERSON OF WE PUT OUT A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT OCEANS
POLICY THAT. A FOR THE FOR THE
FIRST TIME REALLY IN A LONG
TIME COMBINES A NOTION OF WHAT
HAPPENS ON SHORE AND ITS
EFFECTS OFF SHORE AND THESE ARE
FIGHTS I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
FIGHTING OF FOR A LONG TIME
BECAUSE FISHERIES RELY ON WATER
QUALITY HABITATS AND OTHER
THINGS. DEEP INTO CALIFORNIA.
IN ORDER TO PRODUCE A
SUSTAINABLE AND LARGE FISHERY
OFF OF THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA
WE CAN NEVER FORGET THOSE
CONNECTIONS THAT'S- WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. WITH
FEDERAL WATER POLICIES BUT WE
ALL APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THAT
YOU HAVE ALL GONE THROUGH THE
FOR THE FISHING INDUSTRY THE
FLEET HAS GONE THROUGH. TRIED
ADVOCATE FOR AND BE A PART OF
BUILDING SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS OUR
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY AND
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE PANELS AND
LAYING OUT. THE PATH AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIR IN AGAIN WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
ISN'T GENERALLY NOW LIKELY TO
ADVANCE THEIR FIRST PANEL THIS
IS GOING TO BE FOCUS ON REMARKS
FROM BOTH. A THE SECRETARY
AFTER RESOURCES CITY CALIFORNIA
WAY CROWFOOT ALONG WITH THE
FULL BRIEFING FROM TRUCK BONHAM
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL LIFE. I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE DIRECTOR HE'S
THE LONGEST SERVING DIRECTOR IN
THE DEPARTMENT'S HISTORY- AND-
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE- IN. REGULATION SIR IN
THAT IT'S TRUE THE A MILESTONE
IN E LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU
HERE IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO
COME. BUT MR CROWFOOT IS GOING
TO BE KICKING US OFF AND THIS
GROWTH IT IS A SECTION NOW TO
RESOURCES IN HE'S ONTINUE WITH
THIS LONG STANDING TRADITION OF
KICKING OFF THIS. FORUM AND
HE'S GONNA BE PROVIDING THE
PRIORITIES- FOR TWENTY TWENTY
FOR FISHERIES INCLUDING THE
MINISTRATIONS PLAN FOR FLOWS
FOR SALMON IN LIGHT OF THE-
BIOLOGICAL OPINION THAT HAVE
BEEN ADVANCED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHICH WE NOW.
MINISTRATION AS DEEP CONCERN
OVER IN ONE TAKE A MOMENT. TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR FIGHTING FOR
OUR AND DANGEROUS SHE I AM BOTH
DOCUMENTS AND- IT'S GONNA BE
FOCUSING. THREE SEPARATE.
SALMON AND THEN LASTLY HOW WE
CAN EXPEDITE THE FEATHER RIVER
TO REALLY DOES SEEM AN
RESTORATION PROJECTS THE FLOOR
IS YOURS HIS SECRETARY AGAIN I
WANT TO SINCERELY APOLOGIZE
ABOUT DELAYING BOTH YOU AND I
ARE ALL OF OUR PANELISTS IN
THOSE WERE HERE TODAY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE SIR I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A- TIME
CERTAIN THAT YOU NEED TO GET TO
IS WELL- ON A CORONAVIRUS.
CALLS ALL TURN THE FLOOR OVER
YOU SIR AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT FOR YOUR TENANTS THANKS SO
MUCH GERMAN WIRE AND AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE IT'S A
TESTAMENT TO YOUR PRIOR-
PRIORITIES THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
HOLDING THIS GIVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
BIG THANKS TO TOM ALSO FOR
ORGANIZING THIS I HAVE TO SAY
THIS IS MY SECOND THIS WILL BE
MY SECOND HEARING ANNUAL
HEARING IT WAS MY SECOND TOO
MANY TO JOIN. ON THE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT ARE THAT ARE FISHING
IN OUR STATE- LAST NIGHT AND I
HAVE TO SAY IT IS. REALLY RIP
VALUABLE THAT WE HAVE THEM COME
DOWN SACRAMENTO IN CASES YOU
KNOW TRAVELING FROM PLACES LIKE
CRESCENT CITY OVER SIX OURS TO
BE HERE I ALWAYS ENJOY HIT THE
I BARNETT PERSPECTIVE OF THE
MEN THAT ARE ACTUALLY THERE ON
THE WALL OUR- THING FROM WHAT
THEY THINK UP INNOVATE. IS FOR
THE- FISH A- TWO. BE I THAT.
THE INTAKE WORKING. ON CRAP
WHALE IT CETERA SO. IT'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY AND ME THAT
IT NEW LEADERS TO I WAS EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO MEET MISTER BRAD
SHAW WHO WHO TAKES OVER
LEADERSHIP OF A PC FFA AND THEN
OF COURSE ROTH SINGLE BY THE NO
OPPENHEIM WHO'S BEEN- KEY STAFF
LEADER THERE. SO IT'S A IT'S A
REALLY VALUABLE OPPORTUNITY
HUGE THANKS TO YOU OFFER
SPEARHEADING IT EVERY YEAR- YOU
ASKED A LOT OF VERY GOOD DIRECT
QUESTIONS OF ME AND YOU WANT ME
TO COVER IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME SO I PREPARED A POWER
POINT PRESENTATION- MY GOAL IS
TO BE AS DIRECT AS POSSIBLE
ANSWERING ALL THOSE QUESTIONS
AND OF COURSE I WELCOME. HI THE
ANY FOLLOW UP AND YOU HAVE. SO
FIRST UP WAS ASKING ABOUT OUR
PRIORITIES OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND I TALK A
LOT ABOUT- FOUR PILLARS THAT.
THAT WAKE ME UP EVERY MORNING.
AND FROM TOP LEFT- THE FIRST
PRIORITY IS CLIMATE RESILIENCE.
AND I CALL THAT PROTECTING
PEOPLE IN NATURE FROM THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. NOW
WE KNOW WE CAN'T STOP THOSE
IMPACTS OF BUT WE CAN HELP OUR
NATURAL PLACES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES- WHETHER THESE
CHANGES AND ADAPT TO THESE
CHANGES. SO IN THE CONTEXT OF
THIS HEARING IT'S ALL ABOUT
BUILDING THE RESILIENCE OF OUR
FISHERIES TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE- FOR. DECADES TO COME.
THAT PICTURE I IN TOP LEFT
CORNER IS ACTUALLY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
PUTTING. THROUGH THE SALMON
RESTORATION PROGRAM WHICH IS A
FORTY YEAR PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THAT CONSERVATION CORPS AND-
THE- NOT PART OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. THE SECOND PRIORITY
IS PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY WILL
TALK A LOT TODAY ABOUT
ENDANGERED SPECIES OF FISH.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON. KEEPING
SPECIES ALIVE THAT ARE ON THE
BRINK OF EXTINCTION. AT THE
SAME TIME I THINK WE AT THE
STATE CAN DO MUCH MORE
UPSTREAM. TO KEEP PLANTS AND
ANIMALS ARE HEALTHY SO THAT
THEY AREN'T. ON THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION- MANY DON'T KNOW
THAT WE HAVE MORE VARIETY. MORE
DIVERSITY OF PLANTS AND ANIMALS
AND ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY CONSIDERED
ONE OF THE- WORLD'S
BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOTS. AND SO I
AM FOCUSED ON TRYING TO.
RESHAPE A LOT OF OUR
INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS WITH A
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON HOW DO WE
MAINTAIN. THIS WE NOW I WOULD
EVER BE. THE PROPERTY IS. FOR
ALL. AND YOU HEAR THE GOVERNOR
TALK ABOUT IT. WHEN YOU'RE- ALL
STAR FOR. IN RESIDENTS CAN CAN
ACTUALLY SHARE IN. THE SERVER.
I THINK THAT MANIFESTS OUR
AGENCY. IN THEM CALIFORNIANS
CAN ACTUALLY GET OUT I NEED.
OUR STATE PARKS ARE NATURAL
RESERVES SO WE'RE FOCUSED. ON
THAT AND YOU'LL SEE MORE ABOUT.
THAT IN COMING YEARS. AND THEN.
SLEEP ON AND NEVER WERE CALLING
CUTTING THE GREEN. WHICH IS HOW
DO WE GET ENVIRONMENTAL HISTORY.
PROJECT IN OUR MENTOR. PROJECT
IMPROVE. HAPPEN AT. OF THESE.
I'M ON MORE QUICKLY THE FACT.
THAT I LEARNED FIRST YEAR BEING
TERRY IS WE- ON FOR ENVIRONMENT
ADDRESS. IN SOMETIMES THIRD OF
THE PROJECT BUDGET IS ON PLAY
AND PER. AND IT TAKES YOU. TO
DO A SORT OF A TEMPLATE ED-
STREAM RESTORATION PROJECT OR
OR A WETLAND RESTORATION
PROJECTS SO WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON. HOW CAN WE HELP
GOOD ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS
HAPPEN MORE QUICKLY. SO WE'RE
YOU KNOW YOU ASKED ME TO FOCUS
ON OUR WORK ON SALMON ARE AS A
SPECIFIC FOCUS WITHIN OUR
FISHERIES WORK AND I WANTED TO
JUST SHARE WITH YOU A GRAPH
THAT THE- MEN AND WOMEN. BEHIND
ME NO TO WELL WHICH IS. WE HAVE
OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US THIS IS
THE LONG TERM DECLINE IN OUR
SALMON POPULATIONS SO ON THE
LEFT- IS- THE BASELINE AVERAGE
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND ON THE
pFROM NINETEEN NINETY TWO TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND EACH OF
THOSE LINES ARE REPRESENTS A
DIFFERENT SPECIES OF SALMON.
AND WHAT WE SEE IS ANYWHERE
FROM- 43% DECLINE I OVER THAT
FIFTY YEARS TO UPWARDS OF 90% I
AND SO I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT- THE HEALTH OF OUR SALMON
FISHERIES IS MOVING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION. I THINK OUR
GOAL HAS TO BE- TO PIVOT. I AND
TO RESTORETHE FISHERY. YOU
ASKED ABOUT A- UPDATE TO THE
SALMON DOUBLING GOAL THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING- WITHIN THIS
DISCUSSION OF ALLEN TERRY
AGREEMENTS- AND IT IS
SPECIFICALLY TO DOUBLE- THE
AMOUNT OF SALMON FROM THAT BASS
LINE- BY TWENTY FIFTY- YOU ALL
PROBABLY KNOW THAT- THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT IMPROVEMENT ACT.
ARE REQUIRED THAT THE SECRETARY
OF INTERIOR DEVELOP A PROGRAM
TO MAKE ALL EASONABLE EFFORTS
TO DOUBLE THE POPULATION. THAT
BASELINE POPULATION BY TWO
THOUSAND TWO. BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
STATE. MOVED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION SO FOR THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS THERE'S BEEN A
SALMON DOUBLING GOAL THAT SORT
OF FLOATING OUT THERE IN THE
ETHER WITHOUT A DATE TO TARGET
TO HOLD OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE
TO. IMAGINE A GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION GOAL THAT SAID 50%
OF- REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS PERIOD. WELL THE
QUESTION IS BY WHEN AND HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY ESTABLISH A PLAN
WITHOUT OR TARGET WITHOUT A
DATE. SO WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT
THE TWENTY FIFTY IS AMBITIOUS
GIVEN THAT- SHARP INCLINE IN
THE FACT THAT WE AFTER INVERT-
THE TRAJECTORY. BUT WE ACTUALLY
THINK THAT IT'S DOABLE AND IT
GIVES US A THIRTY YEAR WINDOW-
ON WHICH TO DEVELOP A PLAN I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY
WERE BULLISH ON VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS AND WE THINK THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS WHICH- AS
DISCUSSED ARE FIFTEEN YEARS AND
LÏNG. ARE ACTUALLY WOULD
WOULD MOVE US- BACK UP THE
TRAJECTORY TOWARD THAT THAT
DOUBLING GOAL I CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT IF
YOU WANT TO GO INTO DEPTH. ON
THAT. SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT WE NEED TO RECOVER OUR
SALMON POPULATIONS GOES WITHOUT
SAYING WE HAVE TO RESTORE FLOWS
IN RIVERS IN THE BAY DELTA I
THINK EVERYBODY FROM WHEREVER
YOU ARE I IN THE ON THE
SPECTRUM OF WATER STAKEHOLDERS
AGREES ON THAT WE HAVE TO ALSO
DO A LOT OF OTHER THINGS I
IMPROVING AND EXPANDING HABITAT
WE'VE LOST- MUCH OF OUR- SALMON
SPAWNING IN REARING HABITAT-
OVER THE YEARS WERE
INCREASINGLY MOVING WATER
THROUGH THESE THESE CHANNELIZED
RIVERS THAT HAVE LOST THAT
THEIR NATURAL FLOWS- WE NEED
TO- PRIORITIZE APPROPRIATE DAM
REMOVALS INCLUDING THE KLAMATH
RIVER DAMS. AND BARRIERS TO
FISH PASSAGE WHICH STRUCK COULD
TALK MORE ABOUT WE NEED TO
CONTROL INVASIVE SPECIES
OBVIOUSLY CONTROVERSIAL THIS
QUESTION ABOUT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH INVASIVE SPECIES LIKE
STRIPED BASS ARE ACTUALLY-
IMPACTING SALMON POPULATIONS
BUT I THINK WE RIGHT I
RECOGNIZE THAT CONTROLLING
THOSE POPULATIONS IS ONE THING
THAT WE HAVE TO DO. WE ALSO
HAVE TO IMPROVE OCEAN
CONDITIONS WE'LL TALK A LOT
TODAY ABOUT THE HEALTH OF OUR
RIVERS BUT WE KNOW ON THE SAM
AND I REALIZE ON THEHEALTH OF
OUR FRESH WATER ECOSYSTEMS AND
ARE OCEAN BASED ECOSYSTEMS. I'M
REALLY EXCITED WITH THE-
STRATEGY FOR OCEANS AND COAST
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND-
MYSELF AND THE OCEAN
PROTECTION- COUNCIL JUST
APPROVED WHICH ACTUALLY HAS. A
BUNCH OF INVESTMENTS IN
PRIORITIES TO IMPROVE OCEAN
BIG. BASS WE ALSO NEED TO.
UTILIZE BETTER NEW ACTIONABLE
SCIENCE WE SPENT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON SCIENCE-
OF THE HEALTH OF OUR WATERWAYS
INCLUDING FISHERIES BUT TOO
OFTEN IT'S WHAT I CALL COME
COMPLIANCE SCIENCE OR WORSE YET
COMBAT SCIENCE WHAT WE NEED IS-
SCIENTIFIC MONITORING AND
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH THAT IS
TRANSPARENT AND THEN INFORMS
ARE MANAGEMENT WHICH HAS TO BE
ADAPTIVE WE CAN'T LOCK
OURSELVES IN THE THESE DECADE
OLD MANAGEMENT DECISIONS AND
MANAGED THROUGH. REGULATORY
DECISIONS THAT GET CHANGED ONCE
A DECADE OR LITIGATION THAT
TAKES FIFTEEN YEARS TO GET DONE
WE HAVE TO WORK TO UTILIZE THE
BEST CIENCE AN ADAPTIVELY
MANAGE TOWARDS RECOVER OF THESE
THESE SPECIES. AND THEN LASTLY
I'LL SAY YOU KNOW WE ARE REALLY
PRIORITIZING THAT THE PROMISE
OF COLLABORATION- I THINK WE'LL
HEAR A LOT OF PERSPECTIVE TODAY
ABOUT THEY WERE THE ROLE OF
LITIGATION AND OBVIOUSLY
LITIGATION HOUSE A ROLE IN
PROTECTING OUR FISHERIES. BUT
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IF WE CAN
ULTIMATELY TRANSCEND LITIGATION
AND CREATE SOME TYPE OF
DURABLE- A SET OF RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
THAT RESTORES FISHERIES AND
MEETS OTHER NEEDS I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE BETTER FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT. SO WE'LL TALK
TODAY ABOUT WHEN I CALL TWO
DISTINCT BUT OVER OVERLAPPING
PROCESS SEES THAT ARE IMPACTING
THE SALMON FISHERY. ON THE LEFT
YOU HAVE- WHAT I CALL THE BAY
DELTA PUMPING RULES OR THEY
DON'T TO INFRASTRUCTURE RULES-
THAT EXISTS TO PROTECT
ENDANGERED SPECIES. SO A LOT OF
PEOPLE HEAR ABOUT THE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS BUT I
ALWAYS LIKE TO TRY TO BREAK IT
DOWN BECAUSE THAT'S CONFUSES
PEOPLE SO THIS IS REALLY FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. THE RULES THAT
GET PUT IN PLACE TO PROTECT
ENDANGERED SPECIES- AND THOSE
ARE RULES THAT ARE REQUIRED
BOTH BY OUR FEDERAL ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT AND OUR STATE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT WHICH WE
KNOW OF AS SEASIDE. AND OUT OF
US HAS OF COURSE RESULTED IN AN
UPDATED BIOLOGICAL OPINION.
THAT UPDATE WAS DIRECTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP- IN LATE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND REYES. TURNS
WITHIN OUR ADMINISTRATION
CERTAINLY THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL- BASED
ON THE WAY THAT THE PRESIDENT-
DIRECTED THAT UPDATE. I E. ON
IT LET US NOT TO TAKE AN
EXTRAORDINARY ACTION WHICH IS
TO DECIDE THAT WE CAN NO LONGER
RELY ON THE FEDERAL. RULES THAT
FEDERAL BIOLOGICAL OPINION. TO
COVER OUR STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
UNDER OUR STATE IN YOUR
SPEECHES ACT. SO WE IN ESSENCE-
BEGAN DOWN A PARALLEL PATH-
SCIENCE BASED INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT RIPPLES NEED
IT OUR E. W. R. INFRASTRUCTURE.
ABIDE OR COMPLY WITH OUR EIGHT
INJURES BECAUSE ACT SEASIDE. SO
MY OF THE DISCUSS. THAT YOU
HEARD ON THE FEDERAL. OPINION
IT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
HAS BEEN OUR CONTENTION THAT
THEY ARE NOT PROTECTIVE ENOUGH.
AND OF THAT- WE ARE. WE ARE
CREATING A SET OF RULES THAT
ARE DIFFERENT. AND WE IN THE
FALL EXPLAINED THAT OUR
PROBLEMS WERE. CLEAR ENOUGH
WITH THAT THE- PROPOSED
BIOLOGICAL OPINION THAT IF
NEEDED WE WOULD FILE
LITIGATION. WE HAD CONSTRUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR FEDERAL
AGENCY PARTNERS IN RECENT
MONTHS BUT DIDN'T REACH
RESOLUTION AND SO OBVIOUSLY BE
FILED THAT- LITIGATION. THE
SAME TIME CHALK IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
ARE FINALIZING A STATE PERMIT
THIS INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT-
THAT WILL. ENABLE ACCOMPLI
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
INFRASTRUCTURES OPERATIONS
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SUN SO
THAT'S ONE. THE OTHER IS- OF
COURSE PROTECTING THE
BENEFICIAL USES OF. OUR OF THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER SYSTEM IN ALL
OF ITS TRIBUTARY IS THE SAN
JOAQUIN AND THE BAY DELTA OF
COURSE WHICH THOSE TO RIVER
SYSTEMS FLOW INTO. AND FRANKLY
THE STATE IS- DECADE VERDUGO UP
TODAY IT PLAN TO ACTUALLY
OPPORTUNITY BENEFICIAL USES IN
THOSE RIVERS WHICH INCLUDES. ON
THE AND HEALTH OF THE RIVER BUT
I WE CAN. ACTIVITY RAY. WATER
CA AT STORE. APPS UNDER THE
PORTER ACT NOW AS YOU KNOW I'VE
CHAIR IN THIS MEMBER THERE HAS.
A RACE. PROCESS WAS A NEW. A
COUPLE FEW YEARS AGO- THAT
WOULD REQUIRE ON IMPAIR FLOW IN
THOSE THIS. ARE TO DO TELL. AND
WE HAVE FOCUSING OF ART GEN ON.
I WANT TO BE AGREE. YEAH THE
BOMBING I'M SURE THERE STAND
THEY WERE BE A LEGALLY ENFORCED
SET OF. ARE TO IN THE HEALTH OF
THOSE WATER WAYS AS A PLAN OF
IMPLEMENTATION- FOR THAT
REGULATORY ACTION. AND I WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT THOSE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
ARE. SO SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
FROM CALLIE PA AND I GUESS LAST
MONTH- LAID OUT WHAT WE THINK
IS A LEGALLY AND SCIENTIFICALLY
ADEQUATE FRAMEWORK FOR A
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT. AGAIN YOU
GO BACK TO THAT A WAY TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THAT THAT
STATE. LAW REQUIRED UPDATE OF-
THE BAY DELTA PLAN. AND JUST
THE BROAD BRUSH- ELEMENTS OF IT
IS- EIGHT TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF NEW WATER
AND I SHOULD SAY THAT THAT IS
NEW WATER THAT CANNOT BE ERODED
BY LET'S SAY REDUCED WATER
EXPORTS FROM THE BIOLOGICAL
OPINION SO REALLY FOCUSED ON.
AT ALMOST A MILLION ACRE FEET
OF NEW FLOWS COMPARED TO
EXISTING CONDITIONS. ARE
CALLING FOR THE RESTORATION OF
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
HABITAT- THAT'S AS I UNDERSTAND
IT ALMOST- TAKING THE YOLO
BYPASS AND MULTIPLYING IT BY
ABOUT- A ONE POINT TWO FIVE
THAT'S THE AMOUNT A HABITAT
THAT WE'RE- TALKING ABOUT WOULD
BE PART OF THIS- THAT WOULD AND
THAT. THIS AGREEMENT WOULD
GENERATE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OF NEW INVESTMENT SHARED BY
WATER USERS WHO FOR THE FIRST
TIME WITH A SOUTH THEMSELVES
FOR THESE IMPROVEMENTS STATE
GOVERNMENT AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THEN IMPORTANT
AS I MENTIONED ACTUALLY A
PORTION OF THAT GOING TO NEW
COLLABORATIVE SCIENCE THAT
WOULD BE GOVERNED BY- A
TRANSPARENT COLLECTION OF
ENTITIES MY VISION IS IT WOULD
INCLUDE WATER USERS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION
GROUPS AND FEDERAL AND STATE
AGENCIES. TO ACTUALLY-
DETERMINE WHAT SCIENCE IS
NEEDED AND USE THAT ALONG WITH
MONITORING TO ADAPTIVELY MANAGE
THOSE NEW FLOWS AND THAT ADDED
HABITAT HABITAT. WE THINK THAT
THIS ACTUALLY EXPANDS THE TOOLS
THAT WE CAN USE TO BRING BACK
SALMON AND OTHER FISH
POPULATIONS SO YOU YOU SAW MY
LIST OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND
IN THE INCLUDED NOT JUST FLOW
BUT HAVE TACK AND ADAPTIVE. AND
SO THIS COMMENTARY AGREEMENT
FRAMEWORK WE THINK ACTUALLY CAN
BRING THOSE TOOLS IN A WAY THAT
THE SIMPLE WATER BOARD
REGULATION BUT SIMPLY CONTROL
THE LEVER ON FLOWS CANNOT.
IMPORT WE BELIEVE THE BALLING
AGREEMENT HAS PROMISED TO
ACTUALLY COME INTO A FACT IN
SHORT ORDER REALLY IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS. I THINK ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OF THE
REGULATORY PROCESS IS IT
REQUIRES- ONE THAT THAT THAT
REGULATORY PROCESS THE WATER
BOARD- WILL. WILL WOULD HAVE TO
COMPLETE SECONDLY- ESSENTIALLY
THE- AMENDMENT OF WATER RIGHTS
IN THE ADJUDICATION OF WATER
RIGHTS AND I AS I UNDERSTAND IT
SEVERAL HUNDRED WATER RIGHTS.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY LITIGATION
IN EVERY DIRECTION SO. WHAT
I'VE HEARD IS THAT YOU KNOW THE
MOST AMBITIOUS OP I ESTIMATE AS
TO WHEN NEW WATER COULD COME
IN- THE RIVER FROM THAT
REGULATORY PROCESS WOULD BE. A
SEVEN YEARS BUT I'VE ALSO HEARD
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE ONE KEY ADVANTAGE
OF THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT
FRAMEWORK BE ACTUALLY GETTING
THESE IMPROVEMENTS- IN BACK
INTO OUR RIVERS QUICKLY. IF WE
LOOK AT THAT TRAJECTORY WHAT WE
THAT DOUBLES THAT SALMON
DOUBLING GO BY TWENTY FIFTY. WE
CAN'T FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE
CAN'T WAIT FIFTEEN YEARS TO
MAKE AND VOEPEL IMPROVEMENTS
BECAUSE WE I THINK WE ALL
ASSUME WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IF WE MAKE THOSE BARMA. THAT
YEAH OKAY COME FLY. THE NOTE ON
THIS IS THE A BREAKDOWN OF HOW
THAT FIVE BILLION WOULD GET
SPENT ALMOST ONE SEVEN ON HOW I
SHOULD MENTION THAT WERE THAT
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO SHARE THIS
PRESENTATION OF THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE. AND THEN LASTLY- DO I
WANT TO MORE SLIDES- ONE IS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WHAT WE PUT OUT THERE IS A
FRAMEWORK A PROPOSED FRAMEWORK-
NEXT STEPS- IF WE GET THERE
WOULD BE DEVELOPING THAT
FRAMEWORK INTO A PROPOSED
ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENT. SO
ACTUALLY THE FINE PRINT- THAT
WOULD THEN GETS SUBMITTED FOR
SCIENTIFIC PEER REVIEW
INDEPENDENT SCIENTIFIC PEER
REVIEW OFFER COMMENT AND THEN
UNDERTAKEN ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS UNDERSEA C<c.cyan>. AND</c>
THEN HAVE THE WATER BOARD
ACTUALLY CONSIDER IT AS A
PROPOSAL OF IMPLEMENTATION AND
THEY'D HAVE TO DEVELOP A
SCIENTIFIC BASIS REPORT SO THE
POINT IS FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
IT IT WOULD IT WOULD UNDERGO
QUITE A LOT OF SCRUTINY. LASTLY
YOU ASKED ABOUT THEIR MOLINO
AFTER BAY. I'M IN A LOT OF THE-
SALMON GROUPS HAVE MADE REALLY
GOOD POINTS ABOUT LOOK LET'S
LET'S LET'S PICK THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT WHILE WE'RE
NAVIGATING IS MORE COMPLICATED
SUBJECTS AND THE FACT IS WATER
THAT GETS THE THERMAL LIDO
INSTANCE THERE- ONE OF THE
FEATHER RIVER- I'M TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT REALLY REDUCES
SUITABLE HABITAT. FOR SALMON A
LOT OF THE RIVER JUST 1% TO
THRIVE AND- YOU OUT QUESTION
BOTH OF YOU ABOUT. WHY CAN'T WE
ACTUAL MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS- I
THINK THE BILL THE EXPLANATION
HAD BEEN THAT WERE WAITING ON A
FOR LICENSE WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
TODAY IS WE AGREE WITH YOU. ON
THE NEED TO ACTUALLY MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS EFFORT AND-
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IS DONE ABROAD FEASIBILITY
ASSESSMENT WHICH IS REALLY
INITIAL WE THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO BEGIN THIS YEAR
A MUCH MORE DETAILED-
FEASIBILITY ASSESSMENT OF THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS WHICH IS A
NECESSARY STEP ON THE CRITICAL
PATH TO ACTUALLY GETTING THIS
DONE. I THINK MANY OF US AGREE
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS UNTIL THE FOR CREE
LICENSING HAPPENS WHICH FRANKLY
IT'S BEEN. YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
BEEN WAITING ON FOURTEEN YEARS
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF THESE
ABILITY- WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE A LOT OF PLANNING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE- THAT SHOULD
BE DONE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING SAM AND-
GROUPS. AND SO I THINK WHAT I
CAN SAY THAT WHICH IS NEW HERE
TODAY IS THAT- THAT I CAN GIVE
YOU MY COMMITMENT TODAY THAT TO
ACTUALLY START THAT WORK- WHICH
IS THAT NEXT STEP IN THE
CRITICAL PATH. AND WITH THAT
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR TURN IT OVER TO
CHUCK. BUT WE DO QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I KNOW MISS SECTOR YOU
YOU MAY HAVE TO DART OUT HERE.
WITH PRIOR ENGAGEMENT SINCE
WE'RE LATE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY DEIGN TO
APOLOGIZE ONCE AGAIN. I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF THE VICE CHAIR
HAS SOME QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND I KNOW I DO BUT PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR MOISTURE. WITH JUST
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WHEN IN
LOOKING AT THAT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IT YOU CAN EXPAND YOU
HAD ONE CATEGORY OF WATER TYPE.
NEW WATER PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS
WHAT ARE YOU ENVISIONING. IN
THAT CATEGORY SO THERE ARE THE
NOT THE BLUE- SEGMENT SO THERE
ARE PROJECTS THAT WERE
APPROVED- FOR- DEVELOPMENT
UNDER PROPOSITION ONE WHICH WAS
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN WATER BOND
BOND SO WHAT'S CALLED CHINO
HILLS KERN FAN- LOS THE
CHARACTER EXPANSION- AND SO
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY BE-
REALIZING THOSE PROJECTS. ARE
FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH- ADDITION
TO OP SOME GROUND WITH
GROUNDWATER BANKING PROJECTS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE. I'M WE
ARE NOT IN THAT CATEGORY
PROPOSING A NEW- AS I DON'T
THINK ANY NEW PRODUCTS THAT
HAVE. ALREADY BEEN- CONSIDERED
THE PROP ONE THING PROCESS.
THIS IS GOOD THAT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE A RECORD. AS ASSEMBLY.
STONE I WOULD ALSO ADD IN THIS.
GRAPHIC TWO IMPORTANT POINTS
FOLLOWING YEAH SO THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY IS.
PUTTING A COMMITMENT ON THE
TABLE HERE ABOUT DEMAND
REDUCTION THAT'S SIGNIFICANT
SECOND A LOT OF THE FINANCING
UNDERNEATH THE CIRCLE IS A
PROPOSED SELF TAX IT'S WATER
AGENCIES IN DISTRICTS
INCREASING THEIR OWN RATES FOR
PURPOSES OF GENERATING THE
REVENUE TO DO THIS WHOLE SALE
COMPREHENSIVE ENDEAVOR THAT TOO
IS ALSO PRECEDENT SETTING. AS I
RECALL ABOUT 45% OF THAT BY
BILLION AT LEAST IN THE
FRAMEWORK THAT THE SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD I SUGGESTED- WOULD
BE BORNE BY THAT THAT SELF
ASSESSMENT. GOOD FOR THE TEXT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WITH
SECURITY I DESERVE A FEW ITEMS
I WANNA FOCUS IN ON THE RELIEF
I DIDN'T LIKE TO TRANSITION TO
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND THEN
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
BIOLOGICAL PINION SO LOOK AT I
KNOW YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT YOU
TO BE OUR IS- I'M PARAPHRASING
HERE OF THESE THESE ARE YOUR
WORDS. BUT IF THEY'RE STANDS
HAS BEEN. THEY WANTED TO WAIT
UNTIL FOR CAT ISSUED A LICENSE.
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
EVEN THAT MAJOR PLANNING
COMPONENT YEAH SO- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT YOU W. R. THIS IS BEEN.
ALI THAT THE FIRST WORD BIT OF
A SHOW- FOR MANY YEARS IN THIS
SPECIFIC AREA OF THE RIVER IN
ITS KILLING TEN MINUTES WE KNOW
IT I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO YOU SO I
THINK ONE OF THE PIECES THAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE A FOCUS IN ON
IS THAT WHAT IS THAT TIMELINE
RIGHT- FOR FEASIBILITY IN WHAT
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE. IS
BEING ABLE TO HAVE A MEETING
WITH YOU INDEED HAVE YOU ARE A
SINNER NIELSEN SINCE IT'S AN IN
HIS DISTRICT AND WALK THROUGH
THAT JUST BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN
A LONG TIME COMING RIGHT AND-
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE
TO GET THIS THING MOVING WITH
THAT TIME LINE LOOKS LIKE AN OF
HIM ANY COMMENTS ON IT YEAH I
AFTER SPECIFIC QUESTION AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT
FOUR TO SIX MONTHS TO HAVE THE
CONTRACT BE PUT IN PLACE BY THE
W. R. TO ACTUALLY- FACILITATE
THE STUDY. BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
HAVE A MORE DETAILED FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU AND DIRECTOR NAME IT
HAS BEEN REALLY PROACTIVE MY
QUESTIONS ON THIS. I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE IT JUST
BECAUSE AGAIN. LONG TIME COMING
IN. IF WE TACKLE TALK ABOUT A
LOW HANGING FRUIT PROJECT RIGHT
I THAT IS GOING TO HAVE A
DIRECT POSITIVE IMPACT TWO
SPECIES IS IN PERIL I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THEM YEAH AND
I'LL JUST MENTION THE YOU KNOW
THE SOONER WE CAN GET THE FOR
OUR LICENSE THE BETTER AND I
THINK THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS BUT ALSO
MAJOR RECREATIONAL BENEFITS.
FOR THE OROVILLE COMMUNITY
THAT'S REALLY BEEN THROUGH THE
RINGER OBVIOUSLY IN RECENT
YEARS SO ANY ANY- YOU KNOW- ANY
COLLABORATION WE CAN HAVE ON ON
MAKING THE CASE TO FOR TERROR
ATTACKS BUT I THOUGHT WE
HELPFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. WANT TO
GO TO VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND-
LOOK. AT I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU. IN THE
MINISTRATION OF A WORKING ON-
AND- IT IS NEVER EASY. RIGHT
BUT THERE'S CONCERN ESPECIALLY
WITHIN- ENVIRONMENTAL AND SEVEN
COMMUNITY ABOUT THEIR
VOLUNTARY. AND WHAT IS THE
STICK TO BE OF THAT MOVE
FORWARD WITH COMPLAINTS. AND IF
WE DON'T SEE COMPLAINTS WHAT
HAPPENS. CAN YOU GO THROUGH
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERN IN REGARDS THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE YEAH SO LIKE I
SAID I THINK THAT THE TITLE
THAT'S NOW SORT OF TAKEN HOLD
OF THESE SO CALLED VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS IS A BIT OF A
MISNOMER. BECAUSE THE THESE
WOULD BE LEGALLY ENFORCEABLE
AGREEMENTS AS I UNDERSTAND IT
FOR THE WATER BOARD TO EVEN
CONSIDER THIS A PATH OF
IMPLEMENTATION THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE ENFORCEABLE
SO THIS WOULD NOT BE. YOU KNOW
ASPIRATIONAL TARGETS THESE
WOULD BE LEGALLY ENFORCEABLE
THERE'S AN OPEN QUESTIONS
ABOUT. I AND THIS IS WHERE WE
REALLY THAT THIS THESE
QUESTIONS COME IN IN IN
FINALIZING WHAT AT WHAT AN
AGREEMENT WOULD LOOK LIKE- ARE
THERE OFF RAMPS FOR EXAMPLE IF-
THERE AT THE BY A LARGE
BIOLOGICAL TARGETS THAT ARE
DEVELOPED IN THE SPECIFIC
AGREEMENT ARE NOT MET- I THINK
THE WATER BOARD WOULD NOT HAVE
MUCH IN. AT ALL IN VOLUNTARY
THE PATHWAYS IMPLEMENTATION
THERE WASN'T ACTUALLY- A TRUE-
BINDING- SET OF COMMITMENTS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION- SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE'D LIKE IS
ON ANOTHER SPACE AND TIME TO
ACTUALLY WORK ON AN ENFORCEABLE
AGREEMENT THAT REALLY DETAILS.
ON THE LEGAL ENFORCEABILITY
TURN TO MAKE A CASE TO OUR
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THOSE
CONSERVATION GROUPS THAT THIS
IS FAR FROM VOLUNTARY THIS IS
ACTUALLY A- MANDATED. SO JUST
JUST WALKING THROUGH THIS APP
YEAH YOUR PATIENCE SO WORK WITH.
AND OF CONTRACTS ALONG RIGHT
WITHIN DELTA YEP OR WHO ME
VALUES. ON THAT WATER FLOW
THROUGH THE DOW. YOU NEED ACTON.
VERISIGN THAT WE DEDICATE A
NUMBER OF ACRE FEET. IT GOAL I
I'M I'M I'M OVERSIMPLIFYING I.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN- YOU DON'T
HAVE THOSE FOLKS STEP UP. AGAIN
WORST CASE SCENARIO RIGHT YEAH
THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY STEP UP
TO BE ABLE TO. SIGN UP THE
UNDER THIS PROGRAM IN SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT BUT SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR WE DID WITH THE- DRY
CREEK BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS FROM
MCCAIN RUSSIAN RIVER. BUT
CANDIDLY WE HAD CHALLENGES WITH
LANDOWNERS STEPPING UP SO. WHAT
HAPPENS THEN. YEAH I MEAN THERE
WERE THERE THERE NEED TO BE
CLEAR SANCTIONS THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE POTENTIALLY THE
RIVERS AND- TO AN UNIMPAIRED
FLOW SCENARIO. SO IT YOU KNOW
JUST TO BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT ONLY
TALKING ABOUT WATER CONTRACTORS
THEY GET THEIR WATER FROM YOU
KNOW FROM THOSE RIVERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WATER CONTRACTORS
THEY GET THEIR WATER FROM THE
TRIBUTARIES OF THOSE RIVERS
RIGHT FROM AS FAR NORTH AS AS
THE SACRAMENTO MEANS DAM IN THE
U. BAR. ALL THE WAY DOWN YOU
KNOW NTO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY- BUT IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT IS NOT GOING TO WORK IF
THEY'RE ACTUALLY THAT THERE
AREN'T CLEAR SANCTIONS AND SO
CHUCK I'M HAPPY IF YOU JUMP IN
BUT- THE NOTION WOULD BE. THAT
IF YOU BUY YOUR LEGALLY
ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENT THEN YOU
ARE BROUGHT INTO THE REGULATORY
REGIME SO YOU YOU STILL NEED
INDIVIDUALS WE HAD A STEP UP
THOUGH DO BETTER PARTICIPATE.
SO I THINK THERE THREE FILTERS
TO YOUR QUESTION FIRST IS.
UNLESS SUFFICIENT PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER AND EXECUTE. A LEGALLY
ENFORCEABLE CONTRACT. WE WON'T
GET THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS SO
THE SECRETARY HAS DESCRIBED THE
FRAMEWORK WE HAVE SOME HEAVY
WORK AHEAD OF US TO TURN THAT
INTO AN ENFORCEABLE CONTRACT
THAT'S THE SECOND POINT.
ENFORCEABLE CONTRACT IN MY MIND
SHOULD HAVE REMEDIES AND
CONSEQUENCES IF PEOPLE DON'T DO
WHAT THEY PROMISED TO DO. AND
THEN THE THIRD FILTER WOULD BE.
IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO
COLLABORATE AND DO SOMETHING
COMPREHENSIVE AND PRECEDENT
SETTING. THEN THE REGULATORY
PROCESS ARGUABLY SHOULD APPLY
TO YOU WHICH IS THE UNIMPAIRED
FLOW CALCULATION THE SECRETARY
REFERENCED IN TIMELINE IS WHAT
ON THAT. WELL THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THIS
LITIGATION THE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS COMPLICATE THINGS
YEAH- AND SO YOU KNOW BUT OUR
FOCUS- LET'S SAY SETTING THAT
ASIDE FOR DISCUSSION PURPOSES
WAS TO REALLY MOVE TOWARDS- AND
ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENT. TO BE
PROPOSED TO GO THROUGH ALL THAT
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW REALLY IN THE
NEXT FOUR TO SIX MONTHS. OKAY
ALL RIGHT. I AND I THINK THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY NOT BELABOR
THE POINT HERE IN BECAUSE I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
BIOLOGICAL PENNY AS WELL. IS
UNLESS. BEING CANDID RIGHT AND
AGAIN I'M JUST USING MY
EXPERIENCE MUCH SMALLER PROJECT
COMPLICATED MUCH SMALLER
PROJECT ON THE RUSSIAN SOME
DIFFERENT DYNAMICS. UNLESS
THERE'S DEADLINES GIVEN VERY
GOOD INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
SIGN UP- AND IF YOU DON'T SIGN
UP THEN THERE IS GOING TO BE A
STICK THAT'S COMING DOWN. FOLKS
DON'T TYPICALLY MOVE WITHOUT A
DEADLINE AND THAT'S WHY
DISTRICT FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE AND THEN HOW YOU
BACK INTO THAT TOTAL GOAL OF
WHAT YOU WERE JUST MENTIONING-
IN REGARDS TO RESTORING SEE-
SIX SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES
HABITAT- EIGHT TO NINE OR TO
THOUSAND. ACRE FEET INTO FLOWS
BACK IN INTO THAT RIGHT SO
THAT'S THAT'S I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET MY HANDS ARE I MEAN I
WILL SAY THAT. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WATER USER COMING
TO THE TABLE IN A VERY SERIOUS
WAY AS CHUCK MENTIONED YOU KNOW
THERE. THERE ARE- YOU KNOW.
TALKING ABOUT- CREATING THEIR
FIRST SELF ASSESSMENT OF OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THESE
IMPROVEMENTS. AND OBVIOUSLY NO
ONE SIDE ON THE DOTTED LINE OF
THAT BUT THERE ARE A LOT THAT
ARE. HAVING BRACE THE FRAMEWORK
FOR THAT. SO I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THEY DO THEY ARE AT THE
TABLE IN PART BECAUSE OF
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A REGULATORY
PROCESS IF THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN.
LAST THEY'LL SAY I DON'T WANT
TO HIDE THE BALL THOUGH THERE'S
YOU KNOW REASONABLE PEOPLE
DISAGREE WITH US AS IT RELATES
TO HOW MY WHAT THE FLOW NEEDED.
VERSUS THOSE OTHER-
IMPROVEMENTS WHICH GETS ITS
REALLY GOOD SEGUE BECAUSE IT
LOOKED THIS BIOLOGICAL PAIN IS
MOVING FORWARD IT COMPLETELY
SCREWS OVER TEMPERATURE
PROTECTIONS EIGHT SCREWS OVER-
ELIMINATES FLOW PROTECTIONS
RIGHT- AND IS GONNA KILL
SALMON. SO HOW IN AGAIN THIS IS
NOT YOU RIGHT THIS OUT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- I MEAN THIS MESSES
IT ALL UP. YEAH IT LIKE I SAID
LIKE I SHOWED YOU THAT MEAN
IT'S SEPARATE BUT OVERLAPPING
AND SO YOU KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE'VE BEEN SO
FOCUSED ON THIS- ON THIS
FIFTEEN YEAR AGREEMENT BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS- GRAPH
AND WE'RE THINKING HOW THE HECK
ARE WE GONNA CHANGE THINGS THAT
WE CAN IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS
THE NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS. WE'RE
GONNA BEAT WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT THAT LINE GOING
LOWER AND FRANKLY CAN'T GO MUCH
LOWER FOR SOME OF THOSE SPECIES.
SO THAT'S WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
BUT- BUT- BUT SENATOR YOU'RE-
YOU'RE RIGHT THIS DOES THIS
DOES MUCK UP THE WORKS. YEAH
IN- SO CAN YOU JUST WALK US
THROUGH AND I KNOW YOU CAN'T GO
INTO GREAT DETAIL ON THIS BUT-
WALK US THROUGH THE NEXT STEPS
SO OBVIOUSLY SHOT ACROSS THE
BOW- CALIFORNIA THROUGH
ATTORNEY GENERAL WORKING
CORNISH WITH YOUR OFFICE IN THE
GOVERNOR. HAS MOVED FORWARD ON
LITIGATION AND WHAT YOU WOULD
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO SEE WITH THE
GRAND VISION- OF THE PLAN THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO SEE
IMPLEMENTED. YEAH SO I WOULD
SAY. YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
CLEAR THAT. THAT THESE CONCERNS
WE HAVE ABOUT THE FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL OPINION NEED TO BE
RESOLVED AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN
CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT OUR INTENT
TO SIMPLY LITIGATE TO LITIGATE-
THAT IF WE CAN ACTUALLY RESOLVE
OR SETTLE OUR CONCERNS THAT WE
WOULD WELCOME THAT YEAH- AND
THAT WOULD AT LEAST CLEAR- SOME
SPACE FOR A COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS. I THINK THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- THAT IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW THE I'D SAY THAT'S
THAT'S AN OPEN QUESTION AT THIS
TIME WHETHER THOSE CONCERNS CAN
BE RESOLVED. IN THE LAST PIECE
HERE IN AGAIN I APPRECIATE THAT
THE SECRETARY DOING THE TO
QUESTION PIECE IN THIS WILL DO
BE A COMMA LOOK. AND I TO THE
DIRECTOR LOOK FOR THE
DIRECTOR'S REPORT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SCIENCE BASED
DECISIONS AND WHAT YOU LIKE ME
TO IMPLEMENT. I'M THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH SIGNS IT
HAPPENS AGREEMENTS. AND IT
STINKS AS- THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES- ON THE
FEDERAL- INSIDE. THAT
REPRESENTED MEANING THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO WORK WITH- I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT. I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GO. ON
THESE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO GET
MANDATED. ACTION A- A NEW
OUTLOOK AND NEW SCOPE. BUT THIS
COMPLETELY SCREWS UP ANYTHING
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON. SENATOR
HERE HERE'S WHAT I'D SAY. I
THINK YOU KNOW THE SUB I PUT
MYSELF THROUGH LAW SCHOOL AND
TO DO FISHERIES RIVER ECOSYSTEM
WORK. IN MY CAREER IN
CALIFORNIA SO FAR I HAVE NOT
SEEN SUCH A COMPLICATED MOMENT.
OF SUCH IMPORTANT PIECES WHICH
POTENTIALLY. ONE COULD
HARMONIZE FOR A GRAND OUTCOME
THAT DOES RECOVERING CHANGE
THAT DOUBLING TRAJECTORY. BUT
RACES SUCH UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE
OF THE STAKES IN THE DYNAMICS
INVOLVED. THAT SAID. THIS IS
NOT NEW NEWS SECRETARY CRAWFORD
A MINUTE AGO TOLD YOU AND THE
AUDIENCE THAT. HOW MANY MONTHS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION NOW. FOR
A NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
FIFTEEN. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON A SEPARATE STATE PERMIT-
BECAUSE FIFTEEN MONTHS AGO WE
PROJECTED THIS VERY LIKELY
CONFLICT WHERE THE STATE WOULD
BE UNWILLING TO RELY UPON THE
FEDERAL WORK PRODUCT. AND
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE. ALL RIGHT.
SO I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IN
THIS IS NOT THE THESE AREN'T
THE DIRECTOR'S WORDS IN THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH SCIENCE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
DATA- IT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH- A GIVE ME- TO FORMER
CLIENT. AWKWARD SILENCE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT- MISTER
SECTOR IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE A
COVER- IN AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY INTO
THE PUSH YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU
HAD SEVERAL QUESTIONS- BUT YOU
WANT TO TALK TO COVER SO I'D
SAY. IF YOU WANT TO TRANSITION
TO HIM SUPPORT THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
DALE. TO GIVE YOU LIKE THE ROAD
RUNNER- DUST STRAIGHT OUT. WE
GO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER DIRECTOR AT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR GIVE TEN
MINUTES THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE SO IT'S TRUE MY NAME IS
CHUCK BOTTOM I'D BE GLAD TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE KIND OF
SHIFTING GEARS AND FOLLOWING
YOUR REQUEST FOR MY TEN MINUTES
I WOULD TAKE US ON A QUICK TOUR
THROUGH CRAB. SALMON OPEN
ACCESS KELP. MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
AQUACULTURE SOME COATED WIRE
TAGS. IN TEN MINUTES AND TEN
MINUTES TO COME IN WITH THIS
IDEA OF HOPE WHICH IS. PERHAPS
CLICHE BUT IMPORTANT TROPE AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME. YOU SAID
THOUGH TELL YOU A PRIORITY MY
PRIORITY IS ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
AND I WANT TO TAKE THE MOMENT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK EVERYONE
IN THE ROOM I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS REALIZES. MONEY
MATTERS IN THE BUDGET IS AN
EXPRESSION OF YOUR PRIORITIES
SO I WANT TALK A LITTLE BIT.
ABOUT OUR BUDGET OUR DEPARTMENT
IS CHARGED WITH. PRESERVING
NATURE IN CALIFORNIA. ALL THAT
WILDLIFE AND PLANT DIVERSITY.
WE'RE CELEBRATING OUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS
YEAR WE TRACE OUR ROOTS TO THE
BOARD OF FISH COMMISSIONERS.
WHICH WAS STRTED TO STOP THE
MARKET HARVEST OF WILDLIFE
COMMENSURATE WITH THE GOLD RUSH.
SO GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS
PROPOSING SOMETHING I HAVEN'T
REALLY SEEN IN MY TENURE AS
DIRECTOR A DIRECT INVESTMENT
INTO OUR DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THE
SECRETARY CRAWFORD'S LEADERSHIP
ABOUT BIODIVERSITY. AND I WOULD
ACTUALLY ARGUE IT'S A SALMON
BUDGET PROPOSAL HERE'S WHY. AS
YOU KNOW- THE PROPOSAL IS TO
AUGMENT OUR DEPARTMENT WITH
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
AND FIFTY ONE NEW POSITIONS.
SIX AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT PROPOSED INVESTMENT IS
TO MODERNIZE OUR HATCHERIES THE
PEOPLE SITTING BEHIND ME CARE
ABOUT THAT A LOT HERE'S WHAT WE
DO THAT SIX AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS WE BY EIGHTEEN
EXHORTING MACHINES. INSTEAD OF
SQUEEZING THE FISH IN THE
HATCHERY WE CAN AUTOMATE THIS
IT DOESN'T CHANGE OUR LABOR
LEVEL BUT IT INCREASES OUR
EFFICIENCIES. AND WOOD BY FORTY
THREE TRUCKS SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASE THE SURVIVAL RATE OF
THE SMALL FISH WERE WE TAKE
FROM THE HATCHERY TO THE RIVER
OR THE OCEAN. THAT'S A SMART
ONE TIME INVESTMENT. WE TAKE
SIX MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT AND
WE'D BY OURSELVES A NEW FIXED
WING AIRCRAFT WE HAVE SEVEN
PLANS SIX WERE BOUGHT IN THE
EIGHTIES YOU HAVE TO QUESTION
YOUR HEALTH AND SAFETY BEFORE
YOU GET ON TO SOME OF THEM. WE
NEED A PLANE FOR ONE REASON AS
A GREAT EXAPLE. OUR FUTURE OF
MANAGING MAJESTIC MARINE
MAMMALS IN THE OCEAN. DURING
THE CRAB SEASON IS PROBABLY
FLYING OVER THE WHALES AND
COMMUNICATING THE HARD WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN BEHIND ME. TO
HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THE RISK
ASSESSMENT AND AVOID
ENTANGLEMENTS AN ASSET LIKE A
PLANE. IS RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
IT'S PART OF THE FISHERIES AND
SAM AN ASPECT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. WELL DONE STOP THERE.
YOU HEARD THE SECRETARY'S
PRIORITY ABOUT CUTTING THE
GREEN TAPE. FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
WE TAKE A PORTION OF THIS
PROPOSED INVESTMENT WE'D ADD
FIFTEEN NEW PEOPLE AND WE SPENT
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS BASICALLY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NORTH FOR ALL THE
COASTAL STREAMS BECAUSE WE'RE
CONVINCED YOU CAN BRING COASTAL
SALMON BACK IN CALIFORNIA
HERE'S HOW YOU DO IT. YOU PUT A
LAWYER WITH THE GRANT MAKER
WITH THE RESTORATION PLAN WITH
THE PERMIT- WITHOUT A WATERSHED
COORDINATOR. AND WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT WITH THIS GROUP OF
FIFTEEN MULTI DISCIPLINARY UNIT
ONE STOP SHOP CLEARING HOUSE
FOR ALL THE RESTORATION TRIBAL
COMMERCIAL FISHING
ENVIRONMENTAL ENERGY
PROGRESSIVE LEADERSHIP AT THE
CINEMA COUNTY WATER AGENCY
PROGRESSIVE TIMBER COMPANIES.
AND INVEST IN GETTING TO SCALE
AND PACE ON THE RESTORATION OF
THAT SAME A LANDSCAPE CUTTING
THE GREEN TAPE. BUT IT DOESN'T
STOP THERE. YOU MAY KNOW THAT.
WE MANAGE THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
SPECIES ACT PROGRAM WE HAVE
ABOUT THREE OR FOUR PEOPLE
MANAGING THAT WHOLE PROGRAM FOR
THE WHOLE STATE. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD GIVE
US THIRTY ONE NEW PETITION
POSITIONS FOR THIS IS A
PROGRAM. AND ADD TEN POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THAT WORK JUST IN THE LAST YEAR
WE HAVE PETITIONS TO ADD. YOUR
THE CALIFORNIA SUMMER STILL HAD
TO THE PROTECTED LIST AND THE
UPPER KLAMATH TRINITY- RIVER
CHINOOK SALMON TO THE LIST
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE WORK
LOAD THE BUDGET WOULD BE
RESPONDING TO. BUT DON'T STOP
THERE. AT THE END OF THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION WE GOT A BUDGET
AUGMENTATION WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THIRTY MILLION MORE DOLLARS
AND THIRTY POSITIONS THAT
SUNSETS NEXT YEAR. GOVERNOR
NEWSOME IN A PRUDENT WAY IS
PROPOSING TO JUST MAKE THAT
CONTINUE IN PERPETUITY. HERE'S
WHAT WE DID WAS SOME OF THAT
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. WE PUT
ALMOST THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AND ELEVEN PEOPLE ONTO OUR
MARINE WORK. WE BOUGHT OUR
FIRST EVER PATROL BOAT FOR
NORTH OF SAN FRANCISCO WE STOOD
UP OUR FIRST AND I WOULD SAY
NATION ONLY WHALE SAFE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. WE'VE CLUED
AND ISSUED EXPERIMENTAL PERMITS
FOR LIKE THE BOX CRAB FISHERY
WHICH ARE RESPONDING TO
CHANGING FISHERY NEEDS IN A
WARMING OCEAN WE'VE- DONE FIVE
ELECTRONIC UPDATES ACROSS OUR
MARINE VESSELS WE USE FOR
MONITORING. WE TOOK A DATA SAID
THAT IS EXISTENCE SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND HAS
BEEN PAPER. AND WE MODERNIZED
AND DIGITIZED THOSE ARE
EXAMPLES OF THE INVESTMENTS
THAT'S WHY I STARTED WITH
BUDGET LET ME TURN TO THAT
OTHER QUICK TOUR CRAP. CRABBE
HAS PROVOKED THIS DYNAMIC WITH
MARINE MAMMALS. AS YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR WE SPOKE ABOUT A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT THAT HAVE
BEEN REACHED BETWEEN THREE
PARTIES WE ARE ONE OF THOSE
PARTIES SINCE THEN WE'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING COMMITMENTS AND
COMPLETING OBLIGATIONS WE ARE
MID COURSE IN FINALIZING A
STATE RULE WHICH WILL
MEMORIALIZE A RISK US. AND
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. CALL THE
RAMP. WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH MANY LED BY THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE SENATOR HERE'S WHERE WE
ARE IN THAT RULE MAKING. WE'VE
PUT OUT TWO DRAFTS. TO SEE
INFORMAL FEEDBACK. BEFORE A
MEETING WHICH WAS SCHEDULED IN
PERSON IN SAUSALITO NEXT WEEK
WHICH IS NOW BEEN CONVERTED TO
A TELECONFERENCE. WE WILL PUT
OUT A THIRD INFORMAL DRAFT OF
THE PROPOSED RULE. THE RULE
DESCRIBES THE STRUCTURE FOR
DECISION MAKING THE INVOLVEMENT
OF THE WORKING GROUP WHICH IS
MULTI DISCIPLINARY
STAKEHOLDERS. AND TELLS YOU THE
CRITERIA USED TO MANAGE THIS
INTERFACE BETWEEN MARINE
MAMMALS AND THE CRAB FISHERY.
THAT'S ALL CONSULTATION BEFORE
WE MOVE TO AN ACTUAL FORMAL
SUBMISSION TO THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. TO COMPLETE
THE RULE MAKING WHICH WILL
PROMPT YET ANOTHER ROUND OF
PUBLIC FEEDBACK RESPONSE TO
COMMENTS WE ARE HECK BENT ON
COMPLETING THIS RULE MAKING BY
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY. TO
SETTLEMENT WE MADE AND IT'S
ALSO THE PLATFORM IN WHICH WE
WILL GO TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND I WOULD ARGUE
GET THE FIRST EVER. FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT PERMITS
FOR A FISHERY THAT'S FIXED GEAR
LIKE DUNGENESS CRAB RELATIVE TO
THE WRIST TO MARINE MAMMALS IN
OCEAN SPACE THAT IS TO ALONE IS
PRECEDENT SETTING. WE WON'T GET
THERE. WITHOUT REALLY SOLID
OPEN TRANSPARENT COORDINATION
COMMUNICATION WITH THE TRAFFIC
CRAB FISHERY SO WHAT I BELIEVE
THE CRAB FISHERY WILL SEE
BEFORE THEY GET TO THE MEETING
NEXT WEEK IS A REVISED RULE
KIND OF A STRAW PERSON THIRD
VERSION. THAT REFLECTS A LOT OF
THE INPUT. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
A IN HIS ROLE FOR THE WORKING
GROUP TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A
GREATER EMPHASIS ON BASS
SCIENCE AND ADDITIONAL ASPECTS
SO THAT'S COMING. ON A RISK
ASSESSMENT FRONT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IT IS SETTLEMENT
ARRANGEMENT WE NOW HAVE
CALENDAR MOMENTS. WHERE WE
CONVENE THIS ADVISORY GROUP
WHICH IS COMPLETELY COMPRISED
OF MEMBERS OF THE FLEET THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
ACADEMICS. AND WE ASSESS THE
SITUATION AT CERTAIN MOMENTS.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THERE'S A
HIGH MEDIUM OR LOW RISK.
BETWEEN THE FISHERY AND
ENTANGLEMENT AND THEN MAKE A
MANAGEMENT RECOMMENDATION. OR
POTENTIALLY A DIRECTOR ACTION
THAT GROUP MATT IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS. THAT GROUPS
ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN SUBMITTED
TO ME THAT THE STATISTICS KIND
OF THE INFORMATION THAT'S
HAPPENING IN REAL TIME IS THIS
WORKING GROUP CONCLUDES THE
RISK OF ENTANGLEMENT IS LOW
THAT MARINE LIFE CONCENTRATIONS
RIGHT NOW IS LOW THAT ARE OCEAN
ENFORCED CONDITIONS THE RISK OF
THAT PRODUCING THE PROBLEM IS
LOW AND THAT THE FISHING
DYNAMICS RISK. IS LOW. SO THE
WORKING GROUP ALSO DID NOT
RECOMMEND ANY MANAGEMENT ACTION.
AND THEY RECOMMEND WE KEEP THE
SEASON GOING PAST APRIL ONE.
I'M REQUIRED UNDER THE
SETTLEMENT TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
BY MARCH FIFTEENTH WHICH
HAPPENS TO BE A SUNDAY. TO
AVOID DOING THAT ON A SUNDAY
WE'RE GONNA. MAKE OUR
PRONOUNCEMENT TOMORROW THE
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THAT
RECOMMENDATION AND WHETHER WE
HAVE A MANAGEMENT ACTION WE
WANT TO DO IT TOMORROW JUST
CRIED GIVE CERTAINTY AND
PLANNING STABILITY. THAT'S THAT
pTHE FORECAST IS YOU KNOW WE RUN
COMPLICATED MODELS THERE'S A
FEDERAL COUNCIL THAT ENGAGES
MANY IN THE ROOM ON DETERMINING
THE UP COMING YEAR PREDICTIONS.
SO THOSE PREDICTIONS ARE MIXED
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY OCEAN
SALMON FISHERY BECAUSE- ON THE
SACRAMENTO FALL RUN CHINOOK
SIDE THINGS LOOK TO BE IN
DECENT SHAPE RIGHT NOW. AND DUE
TO STRONG TURNS LAST SUMMER.
THE PROTECTIONS WE WOULD
OTHERWISE PUT IN PLACE FOR THE
LEGALLY PROTECTED SACRAMENTO
WINTER RUN CHINOOK. WE DON'T
EXPECT TO HAVE TO PUT SUCH
STRANGER WAS PROTECTIONS INTO
PLACE THAT WILL SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE THE FISHING OPPORTUNITY
IN THE OCEAN. SO IT LOOKS
PRETTY GOOD IN THE SACRAMENTO.
PARTICULAR COMPARED TO A COUPLE
YEARS AGO. BUT IF YOU TURN TO
THE KLAMATH FRONT IT LOOKS NOT
GOOD AT ALL SO THE CLAIM OF
FALL RUN CHINOOK STOCK FORECAST
IS NOT OPTIMISTIC. FULL STOP.
AND THAT'S FALLING FROM A VERY
POOR RETURN. THAT IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE LOWEST RETURNS WE'VE
EVER HAD ON RECORD FOR THAT
RIVER. AND IT IS BECAUSE THAT
THAT WATERSHED IS IN A DROUGHT
SCENARIO. AND IT TOO HAS A LOT
OF VERY SIMILAR WATER TENSIONS
ABOUT WATER MANAGEMENT GOING ON
BOTH IN A LEGAL ARENA. AND YOU
KNOW ASSOCIATED WITH STOP FROM
OREGON DOWN TO THE PACIFIC
OCEAN. SO WE EXPECT OCEAN
FISHING OPPORTUNITIES NORTH OF
POINT ARENA TO BE PRETTY
LIMITED IN TWENTY TWENTY
BECAUSE OF THE DYNAMIC THAT'S
PLAYING OUT ON THE CLAIM. SO
THAT'S A UPDATE ON- PROJECTIONS
YOU ASKED ABOUT DISASTER. SO WE
DID GET THE DIRECT PAYMENT OF
CRAB DISASTER FUNDS OUT LAST
YEAR. RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
FOR THE RESEARCH PROJECTS THAT
WERE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
DISASTER RELIEF. WE'RE
EVALUATING THEM WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND THE PACIFIC MARINE
FISHERIES COMMISSION. TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT PROJECTS SHOULD BE
AWARDED TO IMPROVE THE ABILITY
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO DO TESTING
CAPACITY THIS IS AROUND THE
DEMO A GAS AT ISSUE. WE DO NOT
HAVE DATES FOR PRO GOVERNMENT
YET FOR THE DISBURSEMENT OF
EITHER THE SALMON OR THE
SARDINE FUNDS TO US. BUT
KNOWING WE NEED A QUICK
TURNAROUND I WOULD SAY WE THINK
WE'VE ALREADY FIGURED OUT THE
SARDINE DISASTER SPEND PLAN SO
ONCE IT GETS TO US WE HAVE A
WAY TO TURN AROUND THE FUNDING
PRETTY QUICKLY. AND ON THE
SALMON DISASTER FRONT. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS
EXPENDITURE PLAN WE'VE GOT
FEEDBACK FROM INDUSTRY- ALL OF
THAT IS UNDER REVIEW BY US
RIGHT NOW. WE ARE ON A TIGHT
TIME LINE TO GET THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN SET. AND I
THINK IF YOU WERE ASKED NO OR
DAVID GOLDBERGER ROB ROSS THEY
WOULD AGREE THAT. GIVEN
PRIORITIES WE SHIFTED A TOUCH
TO BE THINKING ABOUT SOME OF
THE SALMON MANAGEMENT DECISIONS
WE HAD TO MAKE IT RIGHT NOW.
WITH THE DISASTER EXPENSE PLAN-
OUT TO THE BACK BURNER. BUT NOW
WE HAVE TO BRING IT. BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE FRONT DOOR. SO
THAT'S DISASTER. OKAY OPEN
ACCESS GOOD STORY. IF YOU GO
BACK IN TIME. CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED A DRAMATIC DECLINE
OF ITS GROUND FISH TOOK IN LINE
ROCK FISH FISHERIES OFF OUR
COAST. AND THE FEDERAL COUNCIL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT SEVERELY RESTRICTED
BOTH THE COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
FISH FOR THOSE FISH. IT WORKED.
WE'RE NOW AT A PLACE WHERE JUST
LAST WEEK AT THE FEDERAL
COUNCIL OUR DEPARTMENT ALONG
WITH MANY INDIVIDUALS IN THE
ROOM WENT PUBLIC AND SAID WE
THINK THIS GROUND FISH
POPULATION HAS REBUILT AND
REVITALIZE SUCH THAT WE OUGHT
TO PUT AS A HIGH PRIORITY
OPENING BACK UP THE FISHING
OPPORTUNITY EXCEPT FOR TROLL
EVERY OTHER THE- BALL. TO
REBUILD A COMMERCIAL
OPPORTUNITY THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
OFTEN. IT'S DUE TO THE HARD
WORK OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
BEHIND US WHO TOOK THE PAIN OF
THE RESTRICTION HOPING ONE DAY
WE WOULD GET BACK TO REBUILD
POPULATION WE THINK WE HAVE AND
THAT'S A GREAT STORY. LAST
NIGHT ACTUALLY YESTERDAY A
MEMBER OF THE CFA REMARKED TO
ME THAT THERE COMMUNITY IN HALF
MOON BAY CHANGED OVERNIGHT. ONE
MOMENT THEY WERE ABLE TO CATCH
GROUND FISH THE NEXT WE CUT HIM
OFF. AND THEY LOST IT. THE IDEA
OF GIVING THAT OPPORTUNITY BACK
IS SOMETHING I DIDN'T THINK I'D
SEE IN MY TENURE. COULD WHAT
TAX IT'S KIND OF WAY IN THE
WEEDS BUT IT WAS WHEN YOUR
QUESTIONS AS YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS IS WE PUT TINY LITTLE
MICROCHIPS IN SALMON. HATCHERY
I'VE ACTUALLY DONE IT. FOR A
DAY. THIS STUFF. KIND OF IN-
YOU KNOW TAKE YOUR JOB TAKE
YOUR BOSS OUT FOR A DAY KIND OF
THING. THAT'S WHAT THEY ASKED
ME TO DO. AND IT'S INCREASE THE
DATA SAID TO UNDERSTAND HOW
FISHER MOVING. AND IT FUELS THE
INFORMATION INTO THOSE
MODELING. EFFORTS I WAS
DESCRIBING. WE'VE BEEN LAGGING
BEHIND IN THE ABILITY TO TAKE
ALL THE INFORMATION IN AND GET
OUT THE REPORT WE KNOW THAT. SO
WE GOT OUT THE- TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN REPORT IN DECEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN REPORT OUT BY AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY. WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
REPORT OUT BY NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA MEMORIALIZE AN
INTERNAL PROCESS AND PROTOCOL.
THAT WILL COMMIT OURSELVES TO.
ISSUE ONCE A YEAR AND A HALF
AFTER YOUR DAD A RECEIPT. AND
GET THIS WAY MORE STRUCTURED
RELIABLE AND PREDICTABLE. LET
ME JUST SHIFT THE HOPE. AND IN
THERE BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE
QUESTIONS I MEAN YOU HEAR IT
ALL THE TIME. BUT WHAT ANGLER
RECREATIONAL OR COMMERCIAL
DOESN'T GO OUT TO THE WATER
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SOME
SEMBLANCE OF HOPE LEFT RIGHT
EVERY TIME YOU CAST THAT LINE
OR DROP DECK YEAR YOU HOPE YOU
HAVE A BOUNTIFUL RESPONSE.
RIGHT SO WHAT AMAZES ME EACH
YEAR IS BOTH YOUR DEDICATION
CHAIR AND CO CHAIR AND TOM BUT
THE FOLKS IN THE ROOM. AND WHEN
I THINK ABOUT THIS AS TO SALMON
I'M PRETTY MUCH A SALMON GEEK.
I WOULD ARGUE THERE'S NO
GREATER JOURNEY IN NATURE. THEN
THOSE FISH THEY ARE BORN IN A
RIVER. THEY SWIM OUT TO THE
OCEAN YEARS LATER SOMETHING
CLICKS. IN THEIR DNA AND THEY
COME BACK TO THE VERY SAME
PLACE. DESPONDENT START THE
CIRCLE OVER AGAIN I CAN'T THINK
OF ANY OTHER CREATURE THAT HAS
THAT KIND OF LIFE JOURNEY. SO
I'M JUST PLEASE EACH YEAR IN
AND OUT YOU NEVER EVER EVER
GIVE UP. ONE TRYING TO SECURE
THE FUTURE OF SALMON IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHILE THE
DECLINE FEELS OVERWHELMING. IT
IS FOR ME PERSONALLY AWAY I
KEEP GETTING UP. IS TO MAKE
SURE I CELEBRATE THE SMALL BUT
OFTEN REALLY IMPORTANT
SUCCESSES ALONG THE WAY. THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER RESTORATION
PROGRAM WHICH SOME MEMBERS IN
THE NEXT PANEL OF BEEN
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN. WE'RE
SEEING FISH COME BACK TO THAT
RIVER SPRING WRENCH ENOUGH.
FIRST TIME IN DECADES. WE MADE
A SUBMISSION TO THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION
LAST WEEK. THAT WERE ON TRACK
ON BUDGET AND ON PACE TO TAKE
OUT THE DANCE IN THE KLAMATH
RIVER WHICH WILL BE THE
NATION'S LARGEST RIVER
RESTORATION PROJECT. EVERY CALL
OVER. THE GETS FIXED EVERY
WATER EFFICIENCY PROJECT WITH
THE WATER DISTRICT ALL THAT
COUNTS WE CAN DO THIS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH STRICTER GREAT JOB
TODAY BREAK GRATEFUL WOULD LIKE
ME TO SEE IF THE VICE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO EVENT ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. ARE
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU THE DIRECTOR FOR
YOUR FOCUS ON THE RAMP I'LL
COME DRAFT DRAFT RAGS RIGHT-
BECAUSE THEY HAD THEIR EARLY.
AND LOOK THEIR CANDIDLY WERE.
SOME CONCERNS SOME DEEP
CONCERNS- FROM THE FLEET AND
OTHER DIRECTOR HAIR HAS MADE
HIMSELF AVAILABLE- WITH THE
WORKING GROUP PROCESSORS PC FFA
AND SEE SEE SEE A AND- I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT- JUST GIVE US
A LITTLE BIT A PREVIEW IF YOU
WILL NO MORE BIT OF A DEEPER
DIVE IF YOU KEEP IT THAT IN TWO
MINUTES BECAUSE WE GOT TO GET
OUR SECOND PANEL AND I HAVE TWO
MORE QUESTIONS ON WHAT TO
EXPECT HERE IN SAUSALITO. THE
TELECONFERENCE I GUESS NOW YEAH
SO. HERE ARE SOME LIKELY
CHANGES I THINK THE COMMUNITY-
SEE WHEN WE GET TO THE NEXT
DRAW PERSON DRAFT. WE TOOK UP A
BIG FOCUS ON WHETHER THE
SECTION OF THE RULE THAT HAS A
LOT OF DEFINITIONS. WAS
CREATING AMBIGUITY AND WHETHER
WE CAN TIGHTEN UP A LOT OF
THAT. SO I THINK YOU COULD SEE
THAT. WE WANT TO PUT A GREATER
EMPHASIS ON WHAT BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE MEANS RELATIVE TO THIS
KIND OF STRUCTURED DECISION
MAKING. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT CRITICISMS OR
FEEDBACK POINTS WAS WE DON'T
SEE THE PROMINENT ROLE THE
WORKING GROUP. YOU'VE RELIED ON
US DON'T CUT IS OUT SO I THINK
YOU'LL SEE A BETTER DESCRIPTION
OF THE ROLE OF THAT WORKING
GROUP IN THE STRUCTURE DECISION
MAKING. WE'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE FINER
SCALE MANAGEMENT TOOLS INSTEAD
OF. BEING STUCK SHOULD YOU
PURSUE A CLOSURE ACROSS THE
WHOLE COAST. WERE ACROSS THREE
COUNTIES. IS THE FUTURE OF THIS
GOING TO BE MORE SURGICAL AND
PRECISION BASED WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT CLOSURE
HERE BUT GREATER OPENING THEIR
CONNECTED WITH YOU EAL TIME
MANAGEMENT I THINK THAT WILL
COME OUT IN THE RULE MORE. I
THINK YOU'LL SEE.
UNACKNOWLEDGED MEANT THAT PART
OF THE CONTEXT OF THIS
STRUCTURE DECISION MAKING. IS
TO UNDERSTAND THE ECONOMIC.
ASPECT OF CLOSURES AND
RESTRICTIONS. DUNGENESS CRAB IS
PROBABLY MUCH LESS RELIABLE BUT
IT STILL REMAINS ONE OF THE
MOST LUCRATIVE FOR HARD MARK
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN TO MAKE A
GO OF IT IN OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS IT IS SOMETHING THEY NEED
CERTAINTY AROUND. SALMON IS NOW
BECOMING HIT OR MISS AND CAN'T
REALLY HELP IN THE SHOULDER
SENSE SO THINKING ABOUT THE
PRESERVATION OF THAT CRAB
INDUSTRY. WHILE KNOWING EVEN
ONE IN TEN A MONTH IS ONE TOO
MANY IS REALLY OUR TASK. NOW
THAT'S I APPRECIATE THAT
PREVIEW AND YOU HIT ALL THOSE
POINTS HAVE BEEN ADVANCED- BY
C. C. C. A.'S WELLS PCF A IN
THE PROCESS WAS SO GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. I THINK ON THE ISSUE
BUDGET- AND WE HAD DISCUSSIONS
ON THE TO RE OPEN THAT ONE.
WHAT THE DIRECTORS PROPOSING-
DIDN'T ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN BAND WITH A
HATCHERIES DESPERATELY NEEDED.
THE PLANE- WE SOUGHT. EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND THE CHALLENGES WE
HAD VERY GOOD THAT SEASON
OPENED IN WE NEED THAT DIRECT
COMMUNICATION AND I APPRECIATE
YOU BRING IT IN I THINK THE BIG
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
WORKING THROUGH I KNOW IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS JUST THE
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE AND WHERE
IT COMES FROM RIGHT AND SO-
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU ARE. SPOT ON.
ON THE INVESTMENT. AND AGAIN.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
MINISTRATION BASING HIS
DECISIONS ON SCIENCE AND DATA.
IN WHAT IS GOING TO HELP THE
SPECIES. JUST WISH. ALL
MINISTRATIONS WOULD DO THAT IF
I COULD BE CANDID SO. I
GRATEFUL FOR ON THAT. YOU WILL
TALK ABOUT THE DENTURES CRAP
TASK FORCE IN FUNDING. ACTUALLY
I MEANT TO MAKE NEWS ON THE
YOU'RE GOOD IF YOU FOR
REMINDING ME NO NO YOU'RE GOOD
YOU'RE GOOD ME. JUST MAKE SURE
THAT THE RIGHT. THE DATA TO THE
NEWS YEAH DEPARTMENT COME I'M
GOING TO COMMIT THE DEPARTMENT
TO FUNDING THE DUNGEON THIS
CRAP TASK FORCE WE KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS WE HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DO THIS SO
WE'RE GONNA COMMIT THE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR- TO KEEP THAT
TASK FORCE GOING IT'S IN
STATUTE IS IN TROUBLE- WE'RE
ALSO GONNA HAVE ARE JUDGES CROP
ACCOUNT FUND MANAGER. COMPLETE
ALL THE DETAILED ACCOUNTING
THAT YOU AND OTHERS IN THE TASK
FORCE ARE ASKING FOR AND WE
HAVE A TARGET DATE TO GET THAT
DONE BRING IT BACK AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION AROUND. SHE TO
THINK YOU FOR IT KNOWN AS WELL
BREAK GRATEFUL. THE LAST ITEM
IF YOU DON'T MIND I TAKE A LOOK
AT IS. AS WE ADVANCE. ARE ON
THE ISSUE OF THE BIOLOGICAL
OPINION. YOUR BELIEF AND WHAT
IT WOULD DO. TO FISH SPECIES IF
IT WAS ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED.
THE OPINIONS THE FEDERAL ID THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BIOLOGICAL
OPINION WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN
WHAT'S THE IMPACT IF THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED. WORSE THAN THE
OUTCOME WE BELIEVE WILL OCCUR
UNDER A SCIENCE BASED STATE
PERMIT UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT SO I'LL
TAKE SALMON AS AN EXAMPLE. AND
FOR THOSE THAT HAVEN'T YOU KNOW
I THINK THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLAINT FILED IN
FEDERAL COURT. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS WHAT'S CALLED A
SIXTY DAY NOTICE OF INTENT TO
SUE UNDER THE FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT BECAUSE
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES IN
DESCRIBING CONCERNS SO THAT'S
THAT'S THE MOST APPROPRIATE
REFERENCE POINT. BUT JUST
THINKING ABOUT SALMON ONE OF
THE THINGS ON OUR DEPARTMENTS
MIND. IS. AND YOU'LL LOS
THRESHOLDS WHICH WE UNDERSTAND
AND I BELIEVE HAVE A RATIONALE.
BUT IN IN IN YOUR MANAGEMENT
SINCE YOU'RE GOING THROUGH A
CALENDAR YEAR ARGUABLY
ACCUMULATING IMPACT AS YOU GO.
IN YOUR THRESHOLD IS LOOKING
ACROSS A LONGER TIME FOR IT. AS
COMPARED TO. A CONSTRUCT-
ACROSS THAT TIME HER RISING
YOU'RE DOING INTERIM MOMENTS
WHERE YOU'RE CHECKING IN. TO
OBSERVE ANALYZE AND DESCRIBE
IMPACTS SO YOU'RE BREAKING THE
TIME HORIZON INTO DIFFERENT
THRESHOLD MOMENTS. MY ANALOGY
IS YOU I'VE GOT AN OLD PICKUP
TRUCK I ALSO HAVE A HYBRID. AND
YOU KNOW IT IT'S A MANUAL SO
YOU CAN GO UP TO FIFTY YEAR AND
YOU CAN BE FINE AND FIFTY OR
FOR A LONG TIME BUT YOU KNOW
YOU MAY NEED TO DOWNSHIFT.
CONVERSELY WHAT THE FOURTH
FIRST YEAR CHECK YOUR RPM'S YOU
CAN TRANSITION SECOND AND THE
THIRD AND FOURTEEN GET THE
FIFTH. I THINK FOR ARTICLE. OUR
ORIENTATION IS AROUND THE
SHIFTING UP THE GEARS IF YOU
WILL WHY YOU'RE KEEPING TRACK
OF LOS THRESHOLDS RATHER THAN
GOING UP TO YOUR HIGHEST GEAR.
WITH THIS THEORY THE CHILL DOWN
SHOULD IF THAT MAKES SENSE
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF A
DIFFERENT ORIENTATION. FROM THE
STATE THINKING AND WHAT YOU MAY
SEE IN THE FEDERAL OPINION.
ACTUALLY THINK IN A MORE
PERFECT WORLD. AND I BELIEVE IN
THE ABILITY TO HAVE A MORE
PERFECT UNION IN THE UNITED
STATES. YOU CAN SORT OUT THOSE
DIFFERENCES WITH GOOD
CONVERSATION BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS AND DIFFERENT
AGENCIES. APPRECIATE SORT OF
THIS RECORD. GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE AGAIN APOLOGIZE
THAT WE STARTED LATE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- AS WELL. I
IN NICE JOB TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH STRICTER
THANK YOU CHIEF BEST AS WELL.
WE SEE. THANK YOU NOW COULD BE
MOVING FORWARD WITH OUR- THE
SECOND PANEL OF THE DAY THE
SECOND PANEL IS TITLED SAVING
CALIFORNIANS ENDANGERED FISH
SPECIES ARE BRIEFING ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S DANGEROUS
YOU WATER POLICY THAT WERE
FIRST CAN HEAR FROM KATE POOL.
EIGHT IS THE SENIOR DIRECTOR-
WATER AND THE WATER RESOURCE
FOR THEM WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCE. COUNCIL GIVE ME.
TERMINATE COMING HERE FOR
CHINOOK SALMON I IN LIGHT OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
BIOLOGICAL OPINION- ADVANCEMENT
WERE SECONDLY WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM JOHN MCMANUS HE'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
GOLDEN STATE SAMUS DITION HE'S
GONNA BE PRESENTING. THE
CHALLENGES THE CHALLENGES THAT
RECREATIONAL SALMON FISHERMEN
WILL FACE WITH THIS DUE TO THE
IN RIVER IMPACTS WHICH ARE
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR- AND THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
ADEQUATE FLOWS- IN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RESTORATION
FIVE. WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM THE
SHORT TIMER IN WERE STILL UPSET
WITH THEM- AS HE'S MOVING TO ME
I KNOW I COULD NOT EASY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
ENTERTAINMENT SO SHE CAN A WHAT
WAS ALSO HONORED AT LAST NIGHT
AT THE DINNER IF YOU WEREN'T
THERE. BUT WE THANKED HIM FOR
HIS SERVICE ON BEHALF OF
FISHERMEN IN PROTECTION OF
FISHING THE STATE AND GIVEN THE
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. NO IS ALSO
OKAY SEEN ON ALL IS. OF FLOW IN
HABITAT NEEDS. LIGHT OF THE
RECENT DISASTERS FEDERAL
CHANGES SO UP FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER
IN HIS POOL THIS BILL WILL HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR ADVOCACY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING THERE IF YOU DON'T
MIND JUST PULL THAT MIKE A
LITTLE CLOSER TO SO WE CAN PICK
UP EACH OF THE VOICES IN IF
EACH OF OUR- SPEAKERS IT WILL
BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT MIKE CLOSE
TO THE MATH. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TERM
ACQUIRING. OR STONE GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M MY NAME IS KAY
PAUL I'M A SENIOR DIRECTOR AND
SENIOR ATTORNEY AT THE NATURAL
RESORCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. FOR
TWO QUIT. WITH I CALL. A FULL
FOR THAT GREAT FOR YOUR TODAY.
I'M GONNA TELL BRIEFLY ABOUT
THE TWO BY OPINION FOR THE
STATE WATER PROJECT AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT- THEY'RE
LIKELY IMPACT ON SALMON AND
OTHER NATIVE FISH AND THE
STATE'S RESPONSE BUT I'D LIKE
TO START BY REMINDING US HOW WE
GOT HERE- YOU REMEMBER WAY BACK
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN
CALIFORNIA BEGAN EMERGING FROM
WHAT. MANY DESCRIBED AS THE
WORST DROUGHT THE STATE IS EVER
EXPERIENCED SINCE RECORD
KEEPING BEGAN. THAT MULTI YEAR
DROUGHT WRECKED HAVOC ON FISH
WILDLIFE AROUND THE STATE- WAS
PARTICULARLY BAD IN THE DELTA
NUMEROUS SALMON RUNS DELTA
SMELT. OTHER THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED FISH. PLANS TO SOME
OF THE LOWEST LEVELS EVER SEEN
AS A RESULT OF BOTH THE DROUGHT
IN POOR. DECISIONS MADE DURING
THE DROUGHT. AND IN RESPONSE TO
THOSE ALARMING DECLINES THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CULVER FOR REVISITING
THE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS THAT
WERE THEN IN PLACE THE
200-082-0009 BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. FOR THE EXPLICIT
PURPOSE OF STRENGTHENING THE
PROTECTIONS OF THOSE OPINIONS.
THEN INTERIOR SECRETARY JEWEL.
CAPTURE THAT INTENTION IN A
MEMO TO THE PRESIDENT WHERE SHE
SAID THAT THIS PROCESS WILL
LIKELY LEAD TO NEW OR AMENDED
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS THAT WILL
INCREASE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
SPECIES AND THAT THOSE EFFORTS
COULD LEAD TO FURTHER
REDUCTIONS IN WATER SUPPLY.
FAST FORWARD TO LAST YEAR. WHEN
I PROCESS FELL INTO THE HANDS
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
THAT HAS BEEN TURNED ON ITS
HEAD AND INSTEAD OF THIS
EXERCISE BEING FOCUSED ON
INCREASING PROTECTIONS FROM
PEARLED FINISH. IT'S BEEN
TURNED INTO A PROJECT-
EXPLICITLY DESIGNED TO MAXIMIZE
WATER DELIVERIES. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS WHICH WERE FINALIZED
LAST OCTOBER DO THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE BIOLOGIST
SAID WAS NECESSARY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND NAY ELIMINATE OR
WEAKENED PROTECTIONS FOR SALMON
AND OTHER SPECIES ALMOST ACROSS
THE BOARD. AND FOR SPECIES THAT
ARE BARELY SURVIVING YEAR TO
YEAR THESE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
ARE QUITE LITERALLY LITERALLY A
RECIPE FOR EXTINCTION. BUT
DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT I'D
LIKE TO READ A FEW QUOTES FOR
YOU FROM A LETTER- TWO LETTERS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN
FISHERIES SOCIETY WHICH HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE CAL NEVA CHAPTER OF THE
AFS. REPRESENTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FISHERIES AND AQUATIC
SCIENTISTS. ESTAMOS FROM
SEVERAL DIFFERENT AGENCIES
ACADEMICS OTHERS WHO ENGAGED IN
FISHERIES WORK TRUCK CALIFORNIA.
THIS GROUP OF EMINENT
SCIENTISTS RECENTLY SAID THAT
THESE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS QUOTE
SEVERELY TRUNCATE OR ELIMINATE
EXISTING PROTECTIONS ON QUOTE
QUESTION WHY. QUOTE DESPITE
THESE ADDED IMPACTS TO THE
SPECIES AND THE DOWNWARD TREND
IN POPULATION ABUNDANCE ON
QUOTE THESE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
DON'T INCLUDED JEOPARDY
DETERMINATION AND INCREASE
PROTECTIONS. THEY ALSO NOTE
THAT THESE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
QUOTE INCREASE THE UNCERTAINTY
OF RECOVERY OF LISTED SPECIES
BY FURTHER EXACERBATING
CONDITIONS IN THE SACRAMENTO
AND SAN JOAQUIN RIVER BASINS
AND DELTA. THIS STATE IS
REITERATED MANY OF THESE
CONCERNS AND THEIR- COMMENTS
AND IN THE COMPLAINT THAT-
DIRECTOR BONHAM REFERRED TO. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS AND- DO YOU
SEE IN MY COLLEAGUES UP HERE IN
SEVERAL OF OUR OTHER ALLIES
HAVE SUED TO INVALIDATE THESE
HARMFUL AND SCIENTIFICALLY
BASED BUS BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS I
HAVE ASKED THE COURT TO PREVENT
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION- OUR
CHALLENGE IS BEING HEARD. I'M
AS FOR THE STATE WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR EIJI BUT SERRA AND
THE STATE COMING IN RECENTLY
AND ALSO FILING SUIT AGAINST
HIS BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS. AND
THEY'VE RACED MANY OF THE SAME
CONCERN SO WE HAVE. ARE THE
OTHER GOOD NEWS ABOUT THE STATE
RESPONSE TO THE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS ISSUED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. IS THAT THE
STATE HAS THE ABILITY TO IMPOSE
ITS OWN. REQUIREMENTS ON THE
OPERATIONS OF BOTH THE STATE
WATER PROJECT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT. TO PREVENT
THESE TRUMP ROLLBACKS MOST
DIRECTLY UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT. YOU MAY
RECALL LAST YEAR'S SENATE BILL
ONE SPONSORED BY PRO TEM ATKINS
THAT ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO
FULLY USE THIS AUTHORITY TO
PROTECT THE STATE'S NATURAL
RESOURCES FROM TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ATTACKS
INCLUDING THESE ANTICIPATED
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS. WHEN THE
GOVERNOR VETOED SB ONE HIS
ADMINISTRATION ASSURE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC THAT
THE STATE HAD ALL THE AUTHORITY
IS NEEDED TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
THESE BAD BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
AND THAT THEY WOULD DO SO.
UNFORTUNATELY TO DATE WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE STATE'S ACTIONS LIVE
UP TO THAT PROMISE. INSTEAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
HAS PROPOSED A WATER PROJECT
OPERATIONS THE CLOSELY NEAR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
IS ABOUT ONE MINUTE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
HAS NOT EXERCISED IT SEES THE
PERMITTING AUTHORITY OVER THE
FEDERAL CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT
ALTHOUGH IT HAS A FORTY TO DO
SO. NEITHER OF THESE AGENCIES
HAVE YEP FIND MISTER APPROACH
SO THERE'S A CHANCE FOR THE
CORRECT THEIR WAYS AND INSIST
ON MORE PROTECTIVE ACTIONS
CALLED FOR IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
BUT IF THE STATE AGENCIES
CONTINUE DOWN THE PATH OR ON
NOT ONLY WILL SALMON ANOTHER
SPECIES CONTINUED THEIR
DOWNWARD SLIDE PERHAPS
IRREVOCABLY. BUT ANY
DIFFERENCES IN PROTECTIONS
IMPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE WILL ONLY BE
APPLIED TO THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. WHICH WILL HAVE TO
REDUCE THEIR WATER DIVERSIONS
TO MAKE UP FOR WHAT MORE WATER
BEING DELIVERED TO THE FEDERAL
PROJECT. I'LL STOP THERE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR SPORT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE OUR TWO
OTHER PANELISTS AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO QUESTIONS THAT WORK FOR
YOU PARKS ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IS IN GENERAL INTRANET
FLORIDA JOHN MCMANUS HE'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
GOLDEN STATE SEVEN ASSOCIATIONS
MINISTER GREAT FREE THAT YOU'RE
HERE. FOR YOUR WORK IN YOUR
FIVE MINUTE SIR. GREETINGS
SENATOR ASSEMBLY. I'M JOHN A
TENNIS ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
GOLDEN STATE SENATE ASSOCIATION
OF BEEN. HERE BEFORE I THINK
YOU KNOW WHAT WE REPRESENT. OF
SPORT AND- COMMERCIAL SALMON
FISHERMEN AND WOMEN AND RELATED
BUSINESSES. FIRST I JUST WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ITS WORK ON SB
ONE LAST YEAR THAT- KATE JUST
MENTIONED. WE'RE SORRY THAT
THE- GOVERNOR VETOED IT. IT WAS
INDEED AN INSURANCE BILL. TO
PROTECT US FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
TAX. FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION- YOU SAW VERSION
OF THIS THAT WEIGHED SHOWED.
THIS IS BASICALLY TO SHOW IN
THE POPULATION TREND FOR.
CENTRAL VALLEY SALMON. THIS
GOES BACK TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE YOU GET THE IDEA WE'RE
GOING DOWN I WANT TO. JUST REAL
BRIEFLY THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED
OUT IN THE OCEAN LAST YEAR THIS
PAST SALMON FISHING SEASON WHAT
I WANT TO POINT TWO IS THE
CONTRIBUTION OF NATURAL ORIGIN
FISHER. KNOWS NATURAL ORIGIN
FISH ARE CODE FOR. WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN A RIVER SYSTEM SO
YOU CAN SEE THE NATURAL ORIGINS
ALMOST WILL THEIR WAY OVER 40%
BOTH THE RECREATIONAL IN THE
COMMERCIAL OCEAN FISHERY- WE
POINT BACK TO- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE WET SPRING A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH REALLY HELP
THESE FISH GET OUT TO THE OCEAN
WE HAVE HEALTHY RIVERS WE GET A
GOOD CONTRIBUTION FROM THE
NATIONAL ORIGIN AND WE NEEDED.
TO HAVE A DECENT FISHERY THE
HATCHERY FISH ALONE ARE NONE
AND NOT ENOUGH TO GET US THERE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS I JUST
WANT TO SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS
ABOUT THAT. AND THAT IS YEAH I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD OTHERS
REFERENCE THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE
THEY CAN WORK UNLESS THE
FEDERAL TRUMP BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS ARE REVERSED. AND THE
REASON WHY AS YOU HEARD. WAIT
CROWFOOT TELL YOU THAT HE
THOUGHT THERE WAS ANOTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER.
THAT COULD COME OUT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INTO THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS. BUT WHAT
THEY MIGHT GIVE OUT WOULD BE
TAKEN BY THE TRUMP BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. SO THE BIOPSY
BASICALLY. WILL BE BACK UP JUST
FOR A SECOND. YOU'LL NOTICE A
CONGRESSMAN KEVIN MCCARTHY
STANDING THERE AT THIS VERY
EVENT HE TOLD THOSE PEOPLE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE HOUSE
THERE BAKERSFIELD. THAT THESE
BY OPS ARE GOING TO DELIVER UP
TO A MILLION ACRE FEET OF
ADDITIONAL WATER. WELL THERE
GOES A SEVEN TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FEET THAT WEIGHT
CROWFOOT JUST TOLD US ABOUT. SO
WE CAN GET THE BENEFITS UNLESS
THOSE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS ARE
STOPPED AND IT'S KATE MENTIONED
WERE IN COURT ALL OF THE GROUPS
THAT AT THIS. ARE PLAINTIFFS IN
THAT SUIT. AND THANKFUL TO THE
STATE FOR COMING IN AND JOIN US.
IF THOSE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS GO
FORWARD THIS IS WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT WE'RE GONNA SEE
YESTERDAY'S MOVIE ALL OVER
AGAIN YOU CAN SEE THE BLUE LINE
SHOWS WATER EXPORTS FROM THE
DELTA IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS THEY MIMIC. WHAT THE
TRUMP BY OFFICER CALLING FOR
NOW THE RED LINE SHOWS YOU WHAT
HAPPENED WAS SALMON RETURNS AND
THEY JUST FELL FELL OFF A
CLIFF. SO WE DON'T WANT TO LIVE
THAT MOVIE AGAIN WE WERE SHUT
DOWN IN 200-082-0009 WE COULD
NOT FISH. BECAUSE OF THAT BLUE
LINE INCREASE WATER EXPORTS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW. ANOTHER ASPECT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH THE TRUMP
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS IS THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THE UPPER
SACRAMENTO RIVER THAT'S A
PICTURE SHASTA DAM RIGHT THERE
THE UPPER SACK COULD OVERHEAT
THIS YEAR THERE'S ALREADY
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT IT HAS TO
DO WITH THEM GIVEN TOO MUCH
WATER WAY TOO EARLY IN THE YEAR
NOT KEEPING THE COLD WATER
WE'RE NOT THERE YET WE HOPE WE
CAN AVOID IT BUT THERE ARE SOME
WORRISOME SIGNALS. AND IF THAT
HAPPENS THIS IS WHAT WE END UP
WITH AND THIS JUST DOESN'T WORK
FOR SALMON. MY QUESTION IS AND
I WONDER IF THIS BODY CAN HELP-
PRO THIS QUESTION. WHAT ROLE
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD IN THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
PLATE TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
OVER HERE. IN THE UPPER SACK
THIS YEAR THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY THEY CAN DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY
WILL AND WE SEEK THE HELP OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND GETTING
THEM. TO DO SO I'M CHANGING
TOPICS HERE. SENATOR MCGUIRE
YOU MIGHT RECOGNIZE YOUR
SIGNATURE THERE I WAS STUDYING
THAT SIGNATURE. AT WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS LETTER THAT
WAS SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES SEEKING HELP TO
GET OUR THERMAL LEGAL PROBLEM
SOLVED THIS IS THE HOT WATER
PROBLEM ON THE FEATHER RIVER
WHERE WHERE THAT D. W. R.
RESPONDED WITH A FLAT NO TO THE
REQUEST THAT THEY DO SOMETHING
IT WAS VERY HEARTENING TO HEAR
SECRETARY- CROWFOOT TODAY SAY
THAT MAYBE SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN THERE WHEN IT COMES TO
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT- A VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT WAS STAR STRUCK
REGARDING THE RE LICENSING OF
THE OROVILLE DAM THIS IS YOUR
BILL DAM ON THE FEATHER. IN
THAT OF VA WAS STRUCK BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX AND YET IT'S
NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED SO FOR
THOSE OF US ON THE PERIPHERY
WATCHING ALL THIS TALK ABOUT
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND WE'RE
WONDERING WHAT BECOMES OF THESE
PROMISES WHEN THEY'RE NOT CAP
SOME FOURTEEN YEARS LATER. THIS
VIDEO THE SHOULD START TO
CIRCULATE ON YOU TUBE AND
ELSEWHERE RIGHT NOW IT'S PUT
OUT BY THE NOR CAL GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND-
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY DOCUMENT
IS SOME THIRTY THOUSAND FALL
RUN SALMON WERE YANKED OUT OF
THE FEATHER RIVER NOT ALLOWED
TO SPAHN NOT CAUGHT BY
FISHERMEN NOT ALLOWED TO
CONTRIBUTE THEIR NUTRIENT LOAD
TO THE ENVIRONMENT YANKED OUT
LAST YEAR AND SENT TO A FOR
PROFIT COMPANY UP IN.
WASHINGTON IS COMPLICATED
REASONS HERE SOME OF THOSE FISH
THAT'S JAMES STONE WAS SHOT UP
IN WASHINGTON STATE WHERE THEY
PUT THESE HATCHERY FISH BACK UP
FOR SALE AT THE YANKED OUT OF
THE RIVER AND HERE'S THE
THERMAL LIDO OUTLET COMING OUT
OF THE THERMAL YOU KNOW AFTER
BAY THAT'S HOT WATER COMING.
INTO THE FEATHER RIVER. ALL I
WANT TO SAY IS WE GET THIS
PROBLEM FIXED. WE CAN GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE OF THIRTY THOUSAND FISH
BEING YANKED OUT THEY PICK UP
FIFTEEN MILES OF SPAWNING
HABITAT DOWNSTREAM IT'S NOW TOO
HOT. AND WE CAN LEAVE THOSE
FISH IN THE RIVER AND THEY
COULD SUPPLY THE LOCAL ECONOMY
AND EVERYBODY ELSE- YOU'VE SEEN
THIS PICTURE BEFORE SOCIAL A
CORE A BILL OR A BILL DAM. OF
THE FAMILY TO VERSION IT'S SET
FOR ITS ULTRA. ABOUT ONE MINUTE
SIR AND I'M GETTING CLOSE-
SWITCHING AGAIN JUST A SHOT OUT
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. FOR
HELPING US ON SHASTA. THIS IS
FLOOD CONTROL RELEASES THAT YOU
SEE COMING OUT OF SHASTA DAM
WHICH ARE CRITICAL TO KEEPING
THE HEALTH OF THE UPPER RIVER.
IN GOOD SHAPE FOR SALMON
SPAWNING THEY REACH THAT WE
DON'T SEE THESE FLOOD CONTROL
RELEASES ANYMORE THEIR THING OF
THE PAST. GRATUITOUS SHOT TO
SHOW WHEN YOU'RE YOUNG KIDS
THAT WE TOOK FISHING LAST YEAR.
AND HOW STOKED THEY ARE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE A SALMON HOME TO
THEIR PARENTS. THEIR HEROES IN
THEIR OWN FAMILIES ON THEIR
BLOCK IN CITRIX SPECTRA ONE OF
THE REASONS WE LIKE TO KEEP
SALMON IN THE PICTURE. AND THAT
IS THE END OF MY PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS TO MAKE
MASS WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO
YOU FOR SOME QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- HERE IN JUST A MOMENT
BUT FIRST LET'S HEAR FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S. ASSOCIATION NO
OPPENHEIM YOUR FIVE ANSWER AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU ONE IN A PROMPT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. JERRY
MCGUIRE AND AN INVESTOR STONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ATTENDING- AND TO BOTH OF YOU
FOR. BOTH YOUR YOUR KIND WORDS
LAST NIGHT AT THE- FISHERMANS
FORMER SECTION. MY NAME'S NO
OPPENHEIM ON THE- SHORT TIMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS. WHICH
IS A NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
FOURTEEN PORT. ASSOCIATIONS
HARVESTING COMMERCIAL FISHERIES
FROM SAN OF ART ACROSS THE
CITY. AND FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS
THE FEDERATION HAS BEEN WORKING
TO FIGHT ON BEHALF OF WORKING
FISHERMEN AND WOMEN. THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC TRUST
RESOURCES THEY DEPEND ON AND
IT'S SAFE TO SAY. THAT TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY HAVE
BEEN IN SOME OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING. YEARS IN THE
RECENT POLITICAL HISTORY. OF
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES. IN
PARTICULAR CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC
KING SALMON FISHERY THE THREE
FOOT FISH THAT WE'RE ALL
FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF. THERE'S
A GLIMMER OF GOOD NEWS IN THIS
ARENA BECAUSE OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY RAINS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THE COMMERCIAL
HARVEST WAS BOUND TO THE LAST
SUMMER BEST WE SEEN AROUND
FIFTEEN YEARS AND THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARY- IT'S BASED ON
THE- HIGH ABUNDANCE OF
SACRAMENTO FALL RUN CHINOOK
SALMON. NOW TWENTY NINETEEN
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN AVERAGE YEAR
A COUPLE DECADES AGO BUT IT'S
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW AND
YOU SIGNED THAT EARLIER
PRESENTATIONS. THAT'S BECAUSE
OUR BASS LINES HAVE SHIFTED-
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT THE GOOD
NEWS ENDS. ON THE ONE HAND
KLAMATH RIVER SALMON
POPULATIONS ARE IN DIRE STRAITS
THESE DECLINES WILL LIMIT OCEAN
FISHERIES THIS SUMMER THESE
DECLINES ARE DRIVEN BY THE
DEVASTATING KLAMATH BASIN
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS FOR WATER
OPERATIONS IN THE CONTINUED
EXISTENCE OF POOR DEBBY DAMS
THAT LOCALLY ARE SLATED FOR
REMOVAL. ON THE ONE HAND AN
ARRAY OF MONEY POLITICAL
INTERESTS ARE- SUCCESSFULLY
HIJACKING THE WATER POLICY
APPARATUS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR IN ORDER TO DIVERT AND
DELIVER WATER AWAY FROM SAM AND
FUNCTIONING RIVERS AND TOWARDS
UNSUSTAINABLE MUNICIPAL AN
AGRICULTURAL WATER USE. WERE
AWARE OF THE CAMPAIGN PROMISES
MADE BY THE PRESIDENT TO HIS
BASE IN THE VALLEY. PROMISES
THAT CAN ONLY BE REALIZED AT
THE EXPENSE OF SALMON FISHERMEN
AND COASTAL COMMUNITIES
DOWNSTREAM. IN ORDER TO DELIVER
ON THESE PROMISES FORMER OIL IN
CORPORATE AG LOBBYIST DAVID
BURKHART WHO IS NOW AT THE HOME
OF INTERIOR ORDERED THE
SUBVERSION OF NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE BIOLOGICAL.
BUT THE CENTER VALLEY. LAST
WELL NATURAL FISHERIES SERVICE
SCIENTISTS CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED
THAT THE PROJECT. THE PROPOSED
BY. YOUR RESULT J. TO YOU WITH
THE COURT EASY DOCUMENT
DEPRESSED MANY OF THE SITE
FIFTEEN MEMBER AT THE AGENCY
REDUCED. WITH DIRECT WATER
USING USE INPUT SANK BY THE DO.
NGUYEN ACT THE CONCLUSIONS WERE.
IN THE RELATIVE BLINK OF A
BUREAUCRATIC AYE JEOPARDY
BECAME NO JEOPARDY AND HERE WE
ARE TODAY. MEANWHILE THE
IMPACTS OF THE NEW CVP
OPERATIONS ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE WILL ALSO RESULT IN
ADVERSE MODIFICATION OF
ESSENTIAL FISH HABITAT
DESIGNATED BY THE PACIFIC
FISHERY MANAGEMENT. WHICH
SUPPORT IT'S THE- OF CA. HOW
SAM RUNS AS WELL AS THE ESA
LISTED STOCKS WELL THE NATIONAL
OCEANIC AND ATMOSPHERIC
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTS TO
CENTRAL SALMON FISH HABITAT.
THEY WERE MET WITH LIP SERVICE
AT RECLAMATION AND A RECORD OF
DECISION WAS SIGNED WITH NO
PROJECT MODIFICATIONS TO
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTS.
RECOGNIZING THE EXTRAORDINARY
CALLOUSNESS OF THESE FEDERAL
ACTIONS GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
ADMINISTRATION HAS JOINED OUR
ORGANIZATIONS IN FILING SUIT
AGAINST HIS BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
AND THE FEDERAL PLANS FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT AND WE
APPLAUD THESE ACTIONS WE
APPLAUD ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
SERRA TO STAFF. FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT AND HARD WORK WE'VE
ASKED THE COURT TO ENJOY THIS
PROJECT. AND WE IMPLORE THAT
THE STATE DO SO AS WELL THE
TIME IS STILL THERE FOR THE
REQUEST FOR AN INJUNCTION.
REPORTS ARE ALREADY COMING IN
AS MY COLLEAGUE JOHN MCMANUS
STATED THAT SHASTA OPERATIONS
ARE ALREADY RAMPED UP BEYOND
LEVELS THAT WOULD MAKE US
COMFORTABLE AND CERTAINLY WE
COULD BE ON TRACK FOR EXCESSIVE
DEPLETION OF COLD WATER POOL IN
CHASKA. PARTICULARLY OF DRY
WEATHER CONDITIONS YOU RECEIVE
DENTAL DEVASTATING IMPACTS TO
SAM UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR EYES
THE STATE CAN ASK THE FEDERAL
COURTS TO STOP THIS AND IT
SHOULD. UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL
ORGANS OF THE STATE ARE
FIGHTING TO. THE FIGHT TO
PROTECT SALMON AND THE
ENVIRONMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES HAS CIRCULATED
STRAP THE I. R. THAT IN MANY
WAYS AS WAS STATED EARLIER
PARALLELS. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IT'S RACE THE
BOTTOM. WE DO HAVE DAILY IN THE
STATE WATER OF ALL COMMENTED ON
THE- DIRECTION THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IS PROPOSING TO TAKE AND WE
HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS OF
WELL. IN PARTICULAR THE STATE
WATER PROJECT SHOULD NOT
PROPOSED OPERATE OLD MEN NO
RIVER FLOW RATES- MORE NEGATIVE
THE NEGATIVE FIVE THOUSAND CFS.
THE STATE SHOULD MAINTAIN THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER INFLOW EXPORT
RATIO IN APRIL AND MAY. THE
STATE PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE DELTA
OUTFLOW OVER AND ABOVE WHAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED BOTH DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. IN THE PROJECT MUST
INCLUDE DAILY AND ANNUAL LIMITS
ON THE NUMBER OF FISH THAT CAN
BE KILLED AT THE PUMPS THAT ARE
TRULY PROTECTIVE. OF ESA LISTED
FISH THAT CONSTRAIN OUR MEMBERS
AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC TRUST
FISHERIES RESOURCES LIKE FALL
RUNNING LATE FOR RUN CHINOOK
SALMON. EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
WORKING IN STATE FISHERIES
MANAGEMENT HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUTURE IS
NOT. WORSE BUT IS BETTER FOR
THE SENATE FISHERY. DOUBLING
GOALS ARE NOBLE BUT THEY FAILED
IN THE PAST. AND IT'S IPORTANT
NOTE THAT TODAY WE STILL DON'T
HAVE THE CERTAINTY ABOUT THE
BASS LINES FOR THE DOUBLING
GOALS. TWO TIMES NOTHING IS
STILL NOTHING THESE NEED TO BE
MEANINGFUL DOUBLE ANGLES- IN
THIRTY YEARS. IS A LONG TIME TO
ACHIEVE THEM PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE FLUCTUATING WATER
CONDITIONS. AND THE HYDROLOGY
THAT COULD IF THESE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS ARE IMPLEMENTED-
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
CURTAILMENT. MAYBE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS OF THE PATH FOR IT I
CAN'T SEE HOW THAT HAPPENS WITH
OF THE STATE WATER BOARD BEING
PREPARED. TO ORDER UP
UNIMPAIRED FLOW REQUIREMENTS BY
DATE CERTAIN THESE NEGOTIATIONS
FAIL. FOUR TO SIX MONTHS IS A
IS AN AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE TO
PUT TOGETHER CONTRACT THAT WILL
BE CLOSE TO TWO YEARS AFTER THE
STATE WATER BOARD ACTED LAST
DECEMBER OR DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. ANDWITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE RAPID PACE THAT
THE NEWSROOM MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSED FOR THIS PROCESS. WE
NEED ACTION NOW AND WE NEED
DATE CERTAIN FOR FALL BACKS WE
NEED TO GO BACK TO THE STATE
WATER BOARD PROCESS. IF
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS DON'T WORK
AND I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR-
STRICT ENFORCEABLE TIMELINE FOR
THAT ACTION. OUR FISHING
INDUSTRY SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD A
REPEAT OF THE MISTAKES OF THE
PAST WE NEED ACTION- AND I
THANK YOU. ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WE MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
DROP AND I AM- WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ASK OUR PANEL STRUCTURE
ANY ITEMS THAT YOU HAVE. I
THINK. I LOOK. WE HAVE HEARD
FROM SOME CENTRAL VALLEY
FARMERS AT THAT THIS WOULD NOT.
THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
ALARMIST THEIR WORDS NOT MINE.
THAT THERE'S NO WAY THIS WOULD
CAUSE AN EXTINCTION OF IT. I IN
TWO MINUTES IF YOU ALL DON'T
MIND- WALK US THROUGH. HOW THAT
COULD HAPPEN IF THIS BIOLOGICAL
PLAN OPINION OR IMPLEMENTED.
FIRST. UP LET ME START OFF-
THEY SHASTA COLD WATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT THAT BOTH
MY COLLEAGUES REFERRED TO. WHAT
WE'RE ON A PATH TO THIS YEAR
RIGHT NOW GIVEN THE DRY
CONDITIONS WE'VE EXPERIENCED
IS- HAS BEEN MODELED TO LOOK
SOMETHING LIKE WHAT WE
EXPERIENCED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN MORE
THAN 95% OF THE SALMON.
SPAWNING AND REARING BELOW
SHASTA DAM WERE KILLED BY WATER
TEMPERATURES THAT WERE TOO HOT
90% MORE THAN 95% OF THOSE EGGS
AND FRY. UNDER THIS BIOLOGICAL
OPINION EVEN THOUGH
RECLAMATIONS MODELING SHOWS
THAT IS UNLIKELY EVENT AND IT'S
GOING TO GET WORSE BECAUSE THAT
WAS BEFORE WE HAD TO DRIVE
FEBRUARY. THAT'S ALLOWED THEY
CAN GO AHEAD AND OPERATE THAT
WAY AND WIPE OUT A 100% OF THE
SALMON SPAWNING IN REARING
BELOW SHASTA. THEY CAN DO THAT
FOR THREE YEARS IN A ROW. THIS
IS A THREE YEAR LIVED SPECIES-
YOU WEBER MOB THREE YEARS IN A
ROW AND WINTER RUN CHINOOK OR
GOD WHO ONLY SURVIVE BELOW
SHASTA DAM AND FOREIGN SPRING
RUN ARE ALSO FOUND THERE AND-
WILL NOT BE. IMPROVED BY THAT
SCENARIO. NO I APPRECIATE
DIRECTS MISSION THANK YOU SO
LET'S THIS DO ANOTHER LAYER ON
THAT THERE'S. DEVASTATING
NOMINAL IMPACT. LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF JOBS HOW
MANY JOBS ARE RELYING ON A
HEALTHY SALMON FISHERY AND IT'S
A TOP TIER FISHERY IN THE STATE
AS WELL SO IF YOU ALL DON'T
MIND. LET'S JUMP INTO WHAT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO LOOK LIKE
FOR I THINK TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND FOLKS ARE DEPENDENT A
HEALTHY SEVEN FISHERIES TO WALK
US THROUGH THAT SHEILA TRIED AS
WELL OBVIOUSLY SO KENYA CAN
TALK TO US ABOUT THAT ALSO A
COUPLE THINGS IN ACOSTA NOAH.
AT TEN THOUSAND FEET WE'RE
LOOKING AT TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND JOBS RELATED TO THE
SAME INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
A NORMAL YEAR WHEN WE GET A
DECENT SEASON- A LOT OF THOSE
JOBS. SIR IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR SUMMER AROUND THE SPORTS
SIDE AND THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT MULTIPLIERS TO LIKE THE
HOTELS AND RESTAURANTS THE
LAUNCH RAMPS THE MARINAS. THE
TACKLE SHOPS AT CENTRO THAT ALL
GET IN ON IT I'M- NOAH CAN
EXPOUND ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE
I JUST WANT TO SAY. A LOT OF
TIMES IT'S NOT OBVIOUS ARE
VISIBLE BUTOVER ON THE SPORTS
SIDE THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY BEING SPENT. I
THINK OF THE NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE RECORD SHOWS
SOMETHING LIKE A HUNDRED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS PER
PERSON PER DAY THAT THEY GO
SALMON FISHING. BOATS IN THE
OCEAN AND INLAND SIDE NURSED
TENS OF THOUSANDS ACTUALLY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO CHASE SALMON. FOR SPORT
CELL THERE'S A HUGE ECONOMY
JUST AROUND THE SPORT FISHERY
NO. JOHN IT IS. CENTER OF OUR
IN A GOOD YEAR IN THIS DECADE
YOU CAN EXPECT TO SEE AROUND
PERHAPS. NINE HUNDRED TO NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN INDIVIDUAL BOATS
OPERATING IN THE SALMON FISHERY
AND THAT'S THAT'S IN THE BEST
YEAR THAT WE'VE SEEN IN QUITE
SOME TIME. ON THE OTHER END IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES WE
COULD EXPECT TO SEE FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE THOUSAND VOTES SO
IT UNDER BETTER CIRCUMSTANCES
WE'VE LOST 75% OF THE FLEETS
CAPACITY- IN REALITY WE HAVE
PERHAPS A HUNDRED BOATS THAT
ARE COMPRISING THE MAJORITY OF
THAT FISHING EFFORT IN A GIVEN
SEVEN SEASON- AND CERTAINLY THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THAT EFFORT IS
NOT- IS. TRACKING THE
HISTORICAL TRENDS WE ARE LOSING
FISHERMEN LEFT AND RIGHT TO
EITHER JUST EXASPERATION OR- TO
SEEKING OTHER FISHING
OPPORTUNITIES THIS IS A
PORTFOLIO FISHERY SALMON IS THE
TRADITIONAL SUMMERTIME FISHERY
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
THERE IS THE THIRD LEG OF THE
TRADITIONAL SMALL SCALE FISHING
STOOL SALMON. CRAB ROCKFISH
WITHOUT ONE OF THOSE LEGS THE
WHOLE INDUSTRY FALLS APART IF I
CAN JUST PUT A FINE POINT BOTH
OF YOU HAVE COASTAL DISTRICTS.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. I'M A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN I THINK YOU BOTH
ARE TUNED AND YOU'VE WATCH
WHAT'S HAPPENED WE HAVE A
DIVERSE ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
IN A LOT OF THE COASTAL
COMMITTEE. OUT COMMUNITIES WILL
PERSIST BUT NOT ALL OF THEM.
YOU'VE GOT SOME IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND I BELIEVE YOU TO
ASSEMBLYMAN SO WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING JOBS IT'S ALSO- COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS BELIEVE
IT OR NOT SOME OF THE INLAND
COMMUNITIES THAT RELY ON SALMON
FISHING EVERY FALL. ON THIS
WITNESS THINGS HAVE REALLY GOOD
POINT YOU TAKE A LOOK AT RULE
COASTAL COMMUNITIES IN THE LIFE
FLIGHT IS FISHING INDUSTRY- AND
WE ARE COMPLETELY HOST-
ESPECIALLY OF A DOUBLE WHAMMY
OF A CHALLENGING CRAB SEASON.
AND IN NON EXISTENT SALMON
SEASON ADVANCE IS DEVASTATING
FOR THE LOCAL ECONOMY. I'D LIKE
TO TURN TO MISS POOL- QUICKLY.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT SALMON
BUT THIS IS ALSO ABOUT. LARGER
MAMMALS IN WALES. RIGHT SO TALK
TO US ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT WE
SEE. ON THAT FOOD STOCK- OUT IN
THE OCEAN IS WHAT IS THAT THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. FOR THAT FOOD STOCK FOR
THESE BEAUTIFUL MAMMALS THAT
ARE FEEDING ON SAME AS WELL.
WELL THAT'S RIGHT THE- THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE BIOLOGICAL
OPINION THAT THIS NEW ONE IS
REPLACING. WASN'T JEOPARDY
OPINION FOR ORCAS AS WELL
BECAUSE- SALMON ARE ORCAS MAIN
FOOD SUPPLY AND SO WHEN THE
SALMON STOCKS ARE PHÃN NOT
ONLY ARE THESE GUYS AND ALL OF
THEIR- CONSTITUENTS. BADLY
IMPACTED BUT- ALL OF THE- LARGE
MAMMALS BOTH IN THE OCEAN AND
UPSTREAM THAT RELY ON THEM FOR
FOOD FOR REPLENISHING THE SOIL
FOR. FERTILIZING REDWOOD
FORESTS ALL OF THOSE- BENEFITS
ARE GONE. AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
ALSO TALKING HERE ABOUT- THE
BIOLOGICAL OPINION FOR DELTA
SMELT WHICH YOU KNOW IS
FREQUENTLY CHARACTERIZED AS-
THE CANARY IN THE COAL MINE FOR
THE DELTA SO IN THAT SENSE THE
DECLINE OF THE SPECIES FROM YOU
KNOW NOT TOO MANY DECADES AGO
IS THE MOST ABUNDANT IN THE
DELTA ONLY LIVES HERE. TOO NOW
FUNCTIONALLY EXTINCT BY MANY-
MANY BIOLOGISTS ASSESSMENT THAT
MEANS WE'RE DOING SOME REALLY
BAD IN THE DELTA THIS THIS
SPECIES IS TELLING US HOW THAT
ECOSYSTEM IS FARING IN ITS NOT
DOING WELL I THINK THAT IT IS
IF YOU'RE NOT INVOLVED IN THE
FISHING COMMUNITY HAVE NO IDEA.
THAT THE STOCK IN THE
SACRAMENTO. IMPACTS WESTERN
STATES IN ALL THE WAY UP TO
CANADA SO- IF YOU DON'T MIND.
AT QUICKLY TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
JUST IMPACT IN OUR NECK OF THE
WOODS. OUR THAT THAT'S CORRECT.
I THINK NO I CAN TALK MORE
ABOUT HIS- MEMBERS OF PC FFA UP
IN OREGON BUT ARE CALIFORNIA
THE SACRAMENTO BORN CHINOOK
SALMON STOCKS SUPPORT THE
FISHERY UP AND DOWN THE WEST
COAST IT'S NOT JUST CALIFORNIA-
SO FOR AGAIN SOME IN WASHINGTON
AND BEYOND- OBVIOUSLY WE ARE
EXPERIENCING THREATS TO SALMON
POPULATIONS ALL THE WAY UP TO
ALASKA FROM DIFFERENT. TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS AND
OTHER THINGS SO. THIS IS REALLY
A- IT'S NOT JUST IN A THREAT TO
UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA ARE UNIQUE
TO OUR CHINOOK SALMON RUNS IT'S
A IT'S AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
SALMON IN THE WAY OF LIFE THEY
SUPPORT. WITH THE FREE TRIAL
SO- ABOUT 60% OF THE KING
SALMON CAUGHT IN THE OCEAN OFF
OF THE OREGON COAST ALL THE WAY
UP TO KEEP FALCON WHICH IS
ALMOST UP TO THE BORDER WITH
WASHINGTON COME OUT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. HUGE VOLUME OF
FISH FROM CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
RELIED ON BY OREGONIANS ON THE
PRIOR QUESTION ABOUT THE
NUTRITION VALUE- WE'RE ONE OF
THE RARE PLACES IN THE WHOLE
EARTH WHERE THIS INCREDIBLE
WELL IN THE GOES ON OFFER COAST
EVERY SPRING NGUYEN TURNS ON
THE NORTH WEST. WATER COMES UP
FULL OF NEW TRICKS THERE'S
EXCLUSIONS OF KRILL AND BECAUSE
OF THE SAM AND WE'RE BLESSED TO
HAVE THIS VEHICLE IT SUCKS UP
ALL THAT CREEL IN BODIES IN THE
SPANISH BRINGS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND FERTILE. WHOLE
CENTER FELL. SO OUT WERE
SITTING ON CERTAIN REALLY
SPECIAL HERE IT DOESN'T EXIST
EVERYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND
THAT IS PROBABLY WOULD COST
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT YEAH THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT FOUR FOUR
MAIN HOME AT THIS REVENUE- LESS
COMPLETE THEY'RE JUST VERY
BRIEFLY WHEN THE SET AND- THAT
ARE PRODUCED IN OUR RIVER AT
THE OCEAN THEY JUST REALLY TURN
RIGHT. AND AS THE STATE THEY
ARE. ARE TO THE- SEVENTY OF
COMMERCIAL AND- FISHERY. UP AND
DOWN THE WEST COAST TRUE OUR IN
PRODUCING RIVERS ARE- A BREAD
BASKET FOR BOTH PEOPLE AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE OCEAN AND- I
LIKE TO SOMETIMES REMARK THAT-
IF WE DON'T PROTECT. OUR SALMON
THEN WE'RE GOING TO LOSE THE
MAIN COURSE IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE SALAD LET'S NOT DO THAT
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THIS STRATEGIC PROTEIN
RESOURCE- FOR THE BENEFIT OF
PEOPLE AND- OUR COMMUNITIES
FOREVER IN IN. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH KATE JOHN NOAH PRESHEAF
YOUR HARD WORK IN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR FIGHT IN ADVOCACY
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH LAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING FORWARD TO OUR
THIRD PANEL IT'S GOING TO FOCUS
ON THE CRAFT ENTRY WAY ON
TANGLING- WE'RE GONNA HEAR AN
UPDATE FROM THE WORKING GROUP
AND OF COURSE ON ALL ISSUES OF
RAMP. UP WE'RE GONNA AT CLASS
ASK FOR A QUICK AUDIBLE BECAUSE
WE'VE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S GONNA
NEED TO BE A- CATCH A FLIGHT TO
LAST FLIGHT OUT TO SEATTLE
TODAY. SO AFTER OF THE CRAB
FISHERY WELL TANGLING IN RAMP
UP THE PANEL WE'RE GONNA MOVE
IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH EVERYONE.
THE AQUACULTURE- IN LEGISLATIVE
UPDATE PANEL. NEXT AFTER THIS I
JUST SO- RAIN IS ABLE TO CATCH
THAT FLIGHT. ALL RIGHT IF WE
COULD HAVE- DOCTORS IN TORA
PLEASE COME FORWARD- GEORGE
BRADSHAW THE PRESS IN THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
FISHERMAN'S ASSOCIATION PLEASE
COME FORWARD. IF WE GET BEN
PLATT THE PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE CRAP ASSOCIATION TO
PLEASE ADVANCE AT THIS TIME.
AND THEN WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
CHEN HUMBERSTONE IS HERE SHE'S
A FISHERIES PROJECT DIRECTOR.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY SHE
COULD ALSO COME FORWARD- WE
WANNA. TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BOTH
PRESIDENTS MISTER PLAQUE MISTER
BRAD SHOP. WHO ARE HERE
REPRESENTING BOTH ASSOCIATIONS
AND- CRESCENT CITY RESIDENTS
SO- PRETTY COOL THAT BOTH YOUR
HERE TODAY IN THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK. A
GENTLEMAN. FIRST AND FOREMOST-
WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER TO DOCTOR
JEERED TEN TORE UP- FROM KNOW
WHAT FISHERIES HE CAN BE HE'S
AN ECOSYSTEM SCIENTISTS. AND
OUT OF THE SOUTHWEST FISHERIES
SCIENCE CENTER AT THE DOCTOR'S
GOING TO HAVE TEN MINUTES THE
REMAINING PAYMENTS WILL HAVE
FIVE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS WE
WERE COMMITTEE. IF YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE DRUG
COMMITTEE MY NAME MY NAME IS
JARED SANTA. A MANY CAUSES
SCIENTISTS WITH NO A FISHERIES
THE FISHERIES ECOLOGY DIVISION
THE SOUTHWEST FISHERIES SCIENCE
CENTER LOCATED IN SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO A
SCIENTIFIC ADVISER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS CRAB WELL
ENTANGLEMENT WORKING GROUP.
THANK YOU FOR THE REQUESTED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE.
TESTIMONY REGARDING MARINE
ECOSYSTEM SCIENCE IN THE RECENT
INCREASE OF WELL ENTITLEMENTS.
NO WAS VISION IS AN INFORMED
SOCIETY THAT USES COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROLE THE
OCEANS COASTS. AND ATMOSPHERE
IN THE GLOBAL ECOSYSTEM TO MAKE
THE BEST SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
DECISIONS. NO WAS MISSION IS TO
UNDERSTAND AND PREDICT CHANGES
IN THE EARTH'S ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL NEED SO I'D LIKE
TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY A BRIEF
SUMMARY REGARDING HOW THE
SCIENCE. WE'D OF THAT WE TELL
UP THIS HELPING TO BENEFIT
WILDLIFE AND FISHERIES IN THE
CALIFORNIA CURRENT ECOSYSTEM
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE VISION
AND- MISSION STATEMENTS. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I RESPUBLIKA TO
STUDY DESCRIBING ECOSYSTEM
DYNAMICS WITHIN THE CURRENT CAP
FOR CURRENT SYSTEM. RECENT HE
WAVED 1-000-142-2000 SIXTEEN.
OUR RESEARCH PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK ON HOW TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND COMPLEX ISSUES
ARISING FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
FISHERY CONFLICTS ARE PROTECTED
SPECIES SUCH AS I ONE TIME
WOMEN'S HOW OCEAN ECOSYSTEM
MONITORING DATA CAN BE USED TO
BENEFIT DECISION MAKING.
REGARDING FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
AND IMPORTANTLY HOW WE CAN
BETTER COMMUNICATE AND USE
SCIENCE TO DETECT AND MITIGATE
FUTURE RISK TO WILDLIFE AND ARE
FISHING COMMUNITIES. QUESTION
WATER WELLS INCREASE CAUGHT IN
CRAB FISHING GEAR DURING THIS
PERIOD BECAUSE OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED WARMING EVENT
INFLUENCED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
IN FACT THE PROBLEM WELL
ENTITLEMENT THAT ALSO EXISTED
FOR DECADES AT A VERY SMALL
LEVEL IN OUR COASTAL ECOSYSTEM.
THE CHALLENGES POSED BY THE
MARINE HEAT WAVE ANOTHER
WARMING EVENTS- AND OTHER
FACTORS REPRESENTED TO SOME
EXTENT AND EMERGING A NEW
EMERGING PROBLEM. FOR WHICH
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING
GREATLY BENEFITED FROM
ECOSYSTEM SCIENCE. I'D LIKE TO
SUMMARIZE FOUR POINTS FOR MORE
STUDY. CLIMATE CHANGE AN
INCREASED VARIABILITY IN
INTENSITY OF CLIMATE CHANGE. IS
INCOME COMBINATION WITH
RECOVERING PROTECTED SPECIES
POPULATIONS AND HIGHLY
CAPITALIZE FISHERIES ARE POSING
NEW CHALLENGES FOR FISHERIES
MANAGEMENT. THIS IS THE CAR
PROBLEM I THINK LINKS TO ALL OF
OUR OUR CONCERNS FISHER THAT
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING. TODAY WE
OBSERVE HAVE BACK IN. COAST
WHAT. ENGINES FELL ABILITY OF
FOR SPECIES SUCH AS KRILLIN. IN
SORT AND ADD SHORT TO BE SHIFT
FORWARD IN WALES THIS WAS
COINCIDENT BUT OF A- BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN SHIPPED THAT WE
SHOULD THE- DID IN PREVIOUS.
YEARS WE PROPOSE THAT THESE
BECAUSE CHANGES COMBINED WITH
RECOVER WELL POPULATIONS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE EXACERBATING
OF ENTITLEMENTS ROUTE THE
MARINE HEATWAVE WAS THE PROBLEM
WITH THE- CELL IT WAS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE THE ECOSYSTEM
SHE THAT OCCURRED IN R. COASTAL
WATERS. WE PRESENT A
RETROACTIVE ASSESSMENT OF
ENTANGLEMENT. TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT COOPERATION OF TEACHERS
RESOURCE MANAGERS AND BUYING
COULD COME TO THE MINUTE IF YOU
THINK. AND TANK THE REST BY THE-
BECAUSE RAY. FISHER APPROACHES
TWICE A THRIVING FOR COMMUNITY.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS THIS IS THE
BEST. AVAILABLE SCIENCE THAT
WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR ENSURING
FOR TO APPLY. AND WE TO BE A
DOT ABOUT. IN OTHER WORDS A RE
LIEU. HOW MARINE HEATWAVE
ALTERS THE STRUCTURE IN AREAS
OF UP WELLING HABITAT OFF
CALIFORNIA. COASTAL UPWELLING
IS THE PROCESS BY WIND BLOWING
ALONG THE COAST AND THEY DRIVE
THIS DEEP COLD NUTRIENT RICH
WATER TO RISE TO THE SURFACE
THIS NORMALLY. RESULTS IN AN
EXPANSION OF THIS COOL OF RICH
FOOD WEB THAT EXPANDS A HUNDRED
KILOMETERS OFF THE COAST THAT'S
THE TYPICAL CASE WHAT. DURING
THE MARINE HEATWAVE WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO WEEK TWO. PERFECTLY
DESCRIBED THAT BECAUSE OUR
NORMAL INDICES ARE JUST LOOKING
AT THE MAGNITUDE OF UP WELLING
IT'S NOT LOOKING AT THE SPECIAL
FOOT PRINT OF THE UP WELLING
HABITAT. SO DURING THE MARINE
HE WAY WHAT WE NOTICE WAS THIS
EXTREME COMPRESSION OF THAT
COOL UP WORLD WATER HABITAT
ALONG THE COAST JUST TO A
NARROW BAND. AND THAT CAUSES-
AN ECOSYSTEM SHIFT AND THE
ESSENTIALLY THE OFFSHORE
ORGANISMS ARE MOVING IN SHORE
AND THE CLUSTER IN THE ONLY
AVAILABLE COOL HABITAT SO YOU
CAN THINK OF THIS AS A REFUGE
IF YOU WILL. THE CALIFORNIA
CRAB FISHERY WHICH TYPICALLY
OPENS IN MID NOVEMBER AND BY
LATE WINTER AND EARLY SPRING
THE CATCH IS A REALLY LOW AND
MOST OF THE GEAR HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE WATER SO WE
REALLY HAVEN'T HAD. PROBLEMS IN
THE PAST WITH RICK WAVES
BECAUSE IT I'M SHIFTING USING
THIS. TWO THOUSAND IN DUE TO
THE DELAY OPENING THE CRAB
FISHING SEE. ALL THE FISHING
GEAR WHEN OUR RIGHT DOOR THE
PEAK OR- OF WALES SO THIS MADE
WORSE WHILE SHORT INCREASE IN
ENGLAND SIT. WITH UNFORTUNATE
HI CAUGHT TENSION MAN MADE
DISEASE AND THE- TWO THOUSAND.
IS NOT THE HOLES. IN FACT WE
START SEEING. IN THE SPIKE
AROUND EGGMAN LATER THE FOR
TEAM. WELL BEFORE THE BLADE
CRABS NOT. STAND AS THE RESULTS
OF HOW THE FEEDING IF YOU'RE-
WAY. THE. THROUGHOUT THE
ENSURING OFF YOUR HABITS
COLLECTIVELY MOVED IN SHORT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE FOOD
WAS THE CRUEL THAT THE NORMALLY
FEED ON THE OFF SHORE
ENVIRONMENTS IS MUCH MORE
WIDELY DISBURSING THE OUTER
SHELF BRAKES TO A QUESTION YES
TO TALK RIGHT I'M INTERRUPTING
I REALLY DO SPACE ONE MAKE SURE
I'M- E. MADE A COMMENT. SO IT
EVERYONE. ALL SPECIE. CROWDED
UP CLOSER TO SHORE. RIGHT OUT
WHERE TRAPS ARE ALSO BEING
DRAFT. IT'S NOT ABOUT HAVING
COOL WATER CLOSE TO THE SHORE
EIGHT DIGIT WALKING THROUGH
THAT ONE MORE TIME. I'M GOING
TO GET TO IT AGAIN IN A MOMENT
OF THIS HOME BYE BYE BIRDIE
HAPPY TO DO THIS OF IT. BUT SO
WHEN WE HAVE A HE WAY YEP THIS
ON SHORE WHICH IS. YOU KNOW
JUST FROM AFTER GLOBAL WAR
THAT'S BECAUSE THE NOR PACIFIC
WARM THAT WE WAR FROM THE OFF
SHORE ENVIRONMENT ENCROACHES ON
THE BOUNDARY OF OUR UP WELL
WATER WHICH IS IDENTIFIED
PARTICULAR ISOTHERM JUST
DEGREES CELSIUS SO THAT WARM
WATER SHRINKS HELPS PUSH THAT
COLD RECLINING AGAINST THE
COAST THAT'S THE NARROW BAND
THAT'S THE ACTUAL MECHANISM. OF
HABITAT COMPOUND. THIRTEEN
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE. WELL WILL
ACTUALLY HAPPEN IN THE TO THE
THIS AND MOM THIS IN REAL NOW
THAT'S OF WHAT RESEARCH ABOUT
HAS ITS FASTEN THOUGH COST
DOCTOR IT I THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
WHAT THE REALLY THE KEY IT'S
THE- OF WHY IT'S JUST NUMBER OF
WELLS THERE'S ALWAYS TO BE. OR
WELL OUT. OFF OUR COAST MAYBE
EVEN MORE WHICH REALLY THIS.
CHAIN IN THE UP WELLING HABITAT
AND DYING OF THE- IT'S THERE
ARE. SITE POST THE GREATEST CON.
BETWEEN A CRAB YEAR AND
POTENTIAL WELL AND TRYING SO
THE HAVE COMPRESSION INDEX IT'S
JUST. TIMES IT ACTUALLY. THE
VERY. OF THAT UP WELL TO WATER
AND IT'S NOW WE CAN'T YOU THIS
SINGLE. WE HAVE A GOING BACK TO
THE EIGHT RIVER LONG TERM OF
IT. IT'S A TIME ZERO PROVIDES A
NEW. REAL TIME MAJOR OF UP
WELLING HAVE THAT'S NOT AND I'D
THAT WE CAN. THAT TOOL TO
DETECT FUTURE LIMITS. IN THE
HABITAT FOR WELL AND OUR SHOES
AND FISHED OUT COMMUNITIES. THE
RESULTS OF STUDY DATA PEAK OF
MANY THERE'S HAVE BEEN USED FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS TO HELP ME.
ENTANGLED REST IT'S TI<c.cyan></c>
VALUE THAT. OPS ARE. IN MY- DAY
BE YOU TO GUIDE DECISION MAKING.
WE HAVE THE- TO Mà THE-
CLIMATE CAN. AND NOR PACIFIC AN
OFF TELL. A REMARKABLE REST.
AND WE ARE A TO TRY FUTURE
MARINE HEAT WAVE WE CAN SEE THE
MONTH IN ADVANCE. DEVELOPING
AND WE HAVE SATELLITES AND
TOOLS TO TRACK THE THINGS. WELL
AS WELL AS THE L. NAY. THEIR
IMPACT ON UP ON. SO ARE STILL
FOCUS ON DEVELOP A RE TO. OF
THE- INDICATOR. IN PARTICULAR.
THE HABIT SECOND. AND WHICH I
HAPPEN. NOW TO ROUTINELY UP.
FOR MONITORING AND WE BUILDING
A WEB AND IT'S GOING TO
RELEASED HAS ALL. THE OF THESE.
FULL TRANCE. ALL THE ON. DATA
THE OLDER REACH WHY IN THE
THREE. THAT. IT'S REALLY
VALUABLE FOR MONITORING SINCE
SOME RUN OUT OF TIME I AM I. A
I'LL SKIP AHEAD INTO CONTINUE
TO FOR ON THE BUT TOOLBAR THAT
WE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THE
RELEVANT ISSUE FOR TODAY
HEARING. I BELIEVE THAT THESE.
IN THE- AND BASIC AND- IN TELE
ON MONITORING. THESE HELP SET
THE GUARD. FOR DECISION MAKING
YOU WANT TO MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN TO OUR
FISHER'S OR WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
TO WALES YOU CAN'T DO IT IN THE
BUNKER INSIDE THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. BEING COMPLETO
COMPLETELY SOME YOU KNOW. GET
NOT HAVING THE BASIC
ENVIRONMENT ECOSYSTEM
INFORMATION COMING IN THAT GUY.
I WAS OF HIS DECISION. AND THE
RE WHY TO JUST. THIS LESS. IS
THE CURRENT. I AM REGULATE THAT
I LET SAW A JANUARY AND NATURAL
SHE- OF THE RAMP AS- AS ITS NOW.
IS NO LONGER INCLUDE OCEAN
ECOSYSTEM AND FOR DINE OUT. AND
IT'S FUTURE STRAW PERSON PAUL
THAT WHATEVER THEY'VE BEEN
PRODUCING. AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO URGE THIS INFORMATION.
IS AVAILABLE IT'S THE KERR THE
BAY AVAILABLE SCIENCE THAT WE
HAVE. AND IT SHOULD BE USED AND
THEY'VE SORT OF DECISION MAKING
AND- COMMUNICATION AND BUILDING
THIS- COALITION OF THE FISHING
COMMUNITY SCIENTISTS RESOURCE
MANAGERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER IS A VALUABLE ASSET
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN. RAP SO BY MATTER
TIME ALL I'LL JUST PAUSE THERE
AND SHIPPED OVER NOW I
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE GONNA
SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU IN A-
THAT. REALLY GOOD SIR IN GRAPE
FOR YOUR READ AND WE DO A SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU WERE YOU CAN
TURN OVER THE FIRST GEORGE BRAG
I HE IS THE- OF A COAST BETTER
OF FISHERMEN'S. CAN HEAR FROM
BEEN PLAY. AT THE CALIFORNIA CO
CRAP ASSOCIATION YOU FIVE
MINUTES MISTER. IN THE RETURN
OF ROOMS. RIGHT NOW. YOUR LIKE
YOU SAY I'M MY NAME'S GEORGE
BRADSHAW LEARN PRESS OF PEACE
YOU HAVE A FAIR WHY. FOR THIRD
GEN. HAVE TWO YOUNG. FOREIGN TO.
YOU MIGHT. I THINK IS GOOD TO
BE MORE THE LINES OF WORK TRUCK
STOP WITH HOPE. AND I'M HERE
BECAUSE OF THAT I'M NOT A- MADE.
I AM A FOR FISHERMEN AND. AND
YOU'LL COME UP WITH A SOLUTION
FOR PROBLEM OF MARINE MAMMAL
WELL ENTANGLEMENTS AND- YOU
KNOW. THE FULLY AS BEN DEL
PROFOUND CHANGES AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT TAKING YOU KNOW A
NEW APPROACH IN THE WAY THAT
WE- OPERATE. AND YOUR THE
COOPERATION WITH THE STATE AND
THE DEPARTMENT- YOU KNOW. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DEALING WITH TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S A WORKS THIS
THIS THIS PROCESS HOUSE TO WORK
FOR US IN OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU KNOW TALK AND SAKE.
AND THE MEMBERS ARE A PART FOR
YOU ALL THE TIME AND EFFORT
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING IN I LIKE
TO THINK YOU. AND VICE CHAIR
AND TOM YOU KNOW FOR GIVING US
THIS FORMING A PLATFORM TO TALK
AND YOU'LL MAKE IT REAL TO
PEOPLE- YOUR RAMPS THE RAMP
RENT REGULATIONS OF CAME A LONG
WAYS- FROM THE FIRST ROUND. AND
YOUR WAITING HERE TO SEE THE
THIRD ROUND OBVIOUSLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EVERYONE BECAUSE
THAT'S NO THREE ROUNDS OF PRE
PRE ROUNDING BEFORE WE GET TO
THE FIRST REAL ROUND AT. AT YES
LEE AND BURDEN AND NEED TO KNOW
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IT COMES
OUT I. YOUR AYE A- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT IT DOES
AFFECT YOU KNOW I WAS BROUGHT
UP WE TALK WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT IT TODAY YEAH I MEAN AND
I WOULD LOVE TO SET YOU CAN
TALK TO YOU GUYS FOR AN HOUR
ABOUT EVERY ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
PRODUCT BECAUSE IT DIRECTLY
AFFECTS ME IT'S NOT JUST YOU
KNOW CRAB- YOU KNOW BUT THE
PANEL THAT I'VE BEEN HERE TO
TALK ABOUT IS YOU KNOW. THE
RAMP PROGRAM AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD AT THE RAMP. AND
THE WELL WORKING GROUP. TO
REMAIN IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT YOU
OFFER ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT AND
FOR BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE- YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT CREATIVE WAYS
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX OF
KEEPING THE FLEET. ON THE
WATER. AND ALSO YOU KNOW TRYING
TO AVOID YOU KNOW INTERACTIONS
WITH. THE MARINE MAMMAL THE
GOOD THING IS AND IT'S GOOD FOR
EVERYONE THE WELL POPULATION IS
GROWING I MEAN NOT AS A BENEFIT
FOR ALL WE JUST NEED TO. FIGURE
OUT HOW TO WORK FLEXIBLY AROUND
THAT. YEAH WE NEED TO BUILD WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
IN THIS IN THIS RANT PROPOSAL
THERE'S NO FLEXIBILITY IN IT
AND WE NEED TO TRY TO MINIMIZE
THE HARD CAPS YOU KNOW IT THE
OCEAN IS A WONDERFUL THING LIKE
HE WAS JUST EXPLAINING IT
CHANGES CONSTANTLY YEAH I MEAN
WHEN WE GET HARD CAPPED THAT
THAT THE OLD. MINES OUR HANDS
FROM STRAIN AND NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT AND
THE OLD MAYBE RELAX ON SOME OF
THESE HARD CAPS MOVING FORWARD
IN THESE AROUND PROPOSALS. DR I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO REITERATE
ONE MORE TIME YOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO MAKE THIS
WORK IN THE COASTAL COMMUNITIES
WHICH YOU GUYS REPRESENTS THE-
A IT'S MAKE OR BREAK FOR THEM
YEAH I MEAN IT. IT'S GONE. YOU
KNOW TO WHERE THERE ISN'T A
WHOLE LOT THERE HANGING ON TO
YOU I MEAN A GOES LIKE I'VE
SAID THIRD GENERATION I'VE GOT
BOYS WHICH- YOU'LL MAY OR MAY
NOT FISH- YOU KNOW AND I. WILL
GO BACK TO WHERE I STARTED THIS
WITH AS WITH HELP YOU I MEAN
THE REASON WHY I'M HERE I DROVE
DOWN FROM CRESCENT CITY I'VE-
IN THE STATE CAPITAL IS TO. YOU
KNOW CONVEY THAT WE ARE HOPEFUL
FOR A SOLUTION THAT YOU KNOW
WILL BE WORKABLE FOR ALL.
SPREAD YOUR WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK ADVOCACY AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP- IN SO APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND IT IS A HELL
OF A DRIVE. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR. THERE YOU GO- AND-
THE GERMAN THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO
HEAR FROM MR PLATT- DRUG JUST
AS FAR AND IT WAS REALLY NICE
TO MEET- DESPLAT LAST NIGHT. AT
TO AT DINNER AS WELL- ENDED
HE'S PRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
COAST CRAP ASSOCIATION. SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES. THANKS MIKE TOM AND
MARK- I ALSO AM A MULTI
GENERATIONAL COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN- SECOND GENERATION
I'M THE FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST GRAVEL SO
SEASON THE TRIPLE CA IS THE
FIRST EVER STATEWIDE INDUSTRY
ONLY COMMERCIAL CRAB FISHING
TRADE ASSOCIATION IN HISTORY
CALIFORNIA. JOINT PLEASE PULL
THAT MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE ARE
INDIVIDUAL CRAB BOAT OWNERS
HARD CAPTAINS AND BUYERS EIGHT
MEMBER BOARD OF THE TRIPLE CA
AS A COMBINED TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY YEARS A CRAB FISHING
EXPERIENCE. OUR MEMBERSHIP
COMPRISES A MAJORITY OF CRAP
PRODUCTION THE STATE AND ARE
BUYING MEMBERSHIPS ALSO
MAJORITY OF CRABS ARE CAUGHT
HERE. OUR MEMBERS COME FROM
EVERY CRAP PORT ON THE COAST
FOR MALLET CRESCENT CITY AND
RAIN FROM THE SMALLEST BOATS
WITHOUT BIRD MOTORS TO THE
BIGGEST BOATS THE HARDLINERS ON
THE COAST. THE TRIPLE CA FORMED.
AFTER THE- OUT OF COURT
SETTLEMENT FROM CBT VERSUS
BONHAM. THIS IS THE WORST THING
THAT'S HAPPENED TO THE CRAB
FISHERY IN ITS IN ITS HISTORY
IT'S AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS FOR
US. WE ARE UNIQUELY CAPABLE TO
HELP CITY OF W. NAVIGATE
THROUGH THE ESSAY PROCESS THAT
HAS BEEN. TRIGGERED BY THIS
LAWSUIT IN A WAY THAT CAN BOTH.
PRESERVE THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY
THE FISHERY WHILE ALSO
MITIGATING THE RISK OF MARINE
MAMMAL INTERACTIONS. THE FACT
IS THAT THE CRAB FISHERY AND
THIS INDUSTRY HAS BEEN WORKING
SUCCESSFULLY FOR YEARS TO
MINIMIZE THESE INTERACTIONS.
WITH THE HELP OF STATE
LEGISLATURE AND DUNGEON IT'S
CRAP TASK FORCE. BEFORE THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
CITED THAT INSTEAD OF WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY THEY WANTED TO
BURN IT TO THE GROUND. BECAUSE
IN REALITY CBT VERSUS BONHAM
AND SHE WOULD BE STRONG ARMED
OUT OF COURT SETTLEMENT. IS
NOTHING SHORT OF NEW IN A SCENE
OVERREACH OF FISHERY
REGULATIONS. IT'S MOST OBVIOUS
ISN'T OBVIOUS PRESIDENT IS THE
S. A LAWSUIT OVER SPOTTED OWL
HABITAT WHICH- WHICH DESTROYED
CALIFORNIA DECIMATING THE
ECONOMIES OF OUR COASTAL TOWNS.
A FEW OF THE MEMBERS BIRTH
FIRST WHO WENT ON TO START T.
B. D. HAVE PUBLICLY STATED THAT
THEY HAD IT HIT UPON A WINNING
PLAY WHEN THEY REALIZE THAT
THEY COULD USE YES AND ITS
DESIGNATION OF CRITICAL
HABITAT. AS A WEAPON TO MAKE
THE AGENCIES QUOTE BAND TO
THEIR WILL. CBT HAS BEEN USING
THE SAME STRATEGY EVER SINCE IN
A NONSTOP CAMPAIGN AGAINST
SMALL FAMILY FARMS RANCHES
TIMBER HARVESTERS AND
FISHERMEN. THE INCONVENIENT
TRUTH FOR C. B. D. AND FOR NO A
TODAY IS. IN THE CASE OF THIS
FISHERY ACTUAL CONFIRMED
ENTANGLEMENTS BETWEEN
COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS CRAB GEAR.
AND MARINE MAMMALS. OF THAT ARE
EITHER ESA LISTENER THREATENED
UNDER THE UNDER THE DISTINCT
POPULATION SEGMENTS ARE
EXTREMELY RARE AND
STATISTICALLY INSIGNIFICANT TO
THE HEALTH OR SIZE OF THESE
POPULATIONS ALL OF THE DOMINANT
POPULATION GROUPS A WELL SAID
MARGARET OFF BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
FOR PART OF EVERY YEAR ARE
ROBUST IN THE HUMPBACK
POPULATION IS GROWING AT A RATE
OF 8210% A YEAR. THIS EVEN
WHILE THE SHIPPING INDUSTRY
OFFER COAST. HAS ADMITTED
PUBLIC T. PUBLICLY TO RUNNING
DOWN SCORES WELLS EVERY YEAR AS
USUAL THE NGOS AND NO ARE GOING
AFTER THE LOW HANGING FRUIT.
NOT BECAUSE WE ARE THE CULPRITS
BUT BECAUSE THE IMAGE OF A
WHALE ENTANGLED IN A BLUE LINE
FITS THE DESIRED OPTICS.
APPARENTLY CVD MADE THE
CALCULATION THAT COMMERCIAL
CRABBING. CRABBERS ARE
DISORGANIZED UNDERFUNDED AND
DEFENSELESS. WELL I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU THAT THIS TIME CVD.
AND THEIR COHORTS HAVE PICKED
THE WRONG GROUP OF FISHERMEN TO
TRY TO PUT OUT OF BUSINESS THE
BUCK STOPS HERE TODAY WITH THE
LEADERSHIP AND GUIDANCE OF THE
TRIPLE CA WHERE A WELL
ORGANIZED WELL FUNDED AND WELL
POSITIONED TO GO TO THE MAT. TO
PROTECT. OUR JOBS AND OUR WAY
OF LIFE. THE TRIPLE CA IS
WORKING WITH THE TOP EXPERTS ON
IS A LEGAL PROCESS AND
FISHERIES IN THE NATION RYAN
STEEN AND IT'S CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATE DANIEL QUICKLY. OF
THE STORIES GROUP. E HAVE AN
EXPERT SCIENCE TEAM HEADED UP
BY MERYL ROAD. OF THE UNITED
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON WHO IS
A RISING STAR IN THE MARINE
SCIENCE COMMUNITY. WE ARE
ALREADY FULLY ENGAGED IN THE
WELL WORKING GROUP AND HELPING
GUIDE TO DFW AND CRAFTING FAIR
AND FLEXIBLE RAMP GUIDELINES.
TRIPLE CA MEMBERS OCCUPIED
TWELVE OF THE THIRTEEN INDUSTRY
SEATS ON THE WORKING GROUP. WE
ARE CURRENTLY DOING FOCUS
RESEARCH ON RISK FACTOR
ASSESSMENT FLEET AND FISHING
DYNAMICS AND A COMPREHENSIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACT STUDY OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF DUNGENESS CRAB.
TO THE ECONOMIES OF OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. ABOUT ONE MINUTE
OKAY. THE TROUBLE CA ONE CDF W.
AND THE STATE LEGISLATURE. TO
REALIZE THAT WE ARE THEIR
ALLIES NOT THEIR ADVERSARIES.
AND THAT OUR GOAL IS TO
CONVINCE SHE DFW THAT THE
PROCESS OF APPLYING FOR AN I.
T. P. FROM NO FOR THE CRAB
FISHERY IS A NEGOTIATION AND
NOT A HARD DICTATE HEADED DOWN
FROM UP HIGH. OUR YES SAY
EXPERTS CAN HELP CFW NAVIGATE
THROUGH THE PROCESS TO AN
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE CRAB
FISHERY THAT PROTECTS BOTH. OUR
COASTAL ECONOMIES AND YES A
LIST AND MARINE MAMMALS. WE
WOULD LIKE CITY OF W. TO LET US
HELP THEM. AND LET THEM HELP US
IT I'M ALSO EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
OF TRIPLE CA IS SPONSORING AND
COORDINATING THE COAST WIDE
LOST YOUR RECOVERY PROGRAM THE
GOAL OF ZERO LOST YOUR LEFT IN
THE OCEAN AFTER THE END OF CRAB
SEASONS I BELIEVE THAT'S AN
ACHIEVABLE GOAL WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING TO ESTABLISH A
MANDATORY CERTIFICATION
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR CRAB BOAT
SKIPPERS TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
FLEET IS CONFIGURING THE GEAR
AND FISHING IN WAYS THAT ARE
PROVEN TO MINIMIZE RISK OF
INTERACTIONS THIS CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
DISSENTING WITH TRAINING FOR
CAPTAINS OF LARGER STEELER FAR
BEST VESSELS THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO WORK AND
OTHER FISHERIES IT WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF SOME OF
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT OPC
IS CONSIDERING TO AND I CANYON.
IS ON OTHER. THAT MAKE NO SENSE
AT ALL TO FISH MINUTE AND WON'T
HELP LIKE ROPE WAS HERE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE OPC TO
INSTEAD HELP FACILITATE THE
TESTING OF OUR OWN IDEAS FOR
GEAR MODIFICATIONS. AND FOR CDF
W. TO ALLOW TESTING ON OUR OWN
BOAT IN SEASON. GOT ONE MORE
HAVE A MINUTE REALLY QUICK OKAY.
I'VE BEEN HEARING WE WERE IN
THE LAST DAYS OF COMMERCIAL
FISHING SINCE I WAS NINE YEARS
OLD WHEN WAREHOUSE OR
CORPORATION FIRST STARTED
FARMING SALMON BUT AT THE HAD A
RICH AND REWARDING LIFE AND
COMMERCIAL FISHING DURING THE
FORTY NINE YEARS SINCE THEN. SO
OBVIOUSLY I'M AN OPTIMIST AND
THE TRIPLE CA IS HOPEFUL THAT
OUR INDUSTRY CAN GET THROUGH
THIS PROCESS TO COME OUT THE
OTHER END WITH THE REAL NOT
TOKEN COMMERCIAL FISHERY BUT WE
WILL NEED THE FULL SUPPORTOF
THIS COMMITTEE THE NIXON
ADMINISTRATION CDF W. TO GET
THERE. AND SO WE- ARE COMMITTED
TO THE GOAL OF THIS NOT
BECOMING THE FISHING INDUSTRY
SPOTTED DAHLE. R. COSTA
COMMUNITY SIMPLY CAN'T HANDLE.
ANYMORE LOSS OF REAL JOBS. I'D
I'D RECENTLY MOVED BACK TO THE
NORTH COAST AFTER GOING TO
HUMBOLDT STATE. BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES. AND YOU CAN STILL SEE
THE LONG TERM EFFECTS OF THE-
DEVASTATION THE TIMBER INDUSTRY
IN IN THESE COASTAL BOUNCE A
CHRONIC UNEMPLOYMENT.
UNDEREMPLOYMENT HOMELESSNESS
DRUG ADDICTION. PLACE LIKE
CRESCENT CITY WE HAVE TO
INDUSTRIES A PRISON AND
COMMERCIAL FISHING. AND
SEASONAL TOURISM. IF WE CAN'T
GET THROUGH THIS AND THE DEVIL
IS REALLY GONNA BE IN THE
DETAILS OF HOW THIS COMES OUT
THE DETAILS ARE GOING TO
MATTER. AND SO WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS WITH THE RIVER.
DUNGEON AS CRAB FISHERY PLACES
LIKE TRINIDAD YOUR- CITY. ARE
YOU. WOULD BE TROUBLE. SO WE
WOULD APPRECIATE CONTINUE
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH BUT
WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU HERE THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THE TRACK IS
WELL WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OUR FINAL MEMBER OF THE PANEL
IT'S GEN HUMBERSTONE SHE'S THE
FISHERIES PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. IN
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE THE
FORESHORES YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES ON AB ONE MINUTE
PROMPT. THANK YOU- THANKS AGAIN
SEVEN REQUIRE INTO THE JOINT
COMMITTEE. FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
PANEL. SHE SAID MY NAME IS JOHN
HUMBERSTONE OF TREES PROJECT
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
TNC HAS BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH CALIFORNIA JUDGES CRAB
FISHERMEN IN MANAGE OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS. IN TANGLED
ARREST ELLSWORTH COURTING A
THRIVING FISHERY. I TAKE IN THE
FACE OF CHANGING CLIMATE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
CHANGING OCEAN CONDITIONS.
FASTER AND MORE EFFECTIVELY THE
WAY TO DO THAT IS BY BRINGING
MORE COOPERATIVE MANAGEMENT
CAPACITY IN FUNDING TO THE
TABLE. BY LEVERAGING
PARTNERSHIPS AND BY ENSURING WE
HAVE HIGH QUALITY INFORMATION
TO ACT ON. THEIR SCIENCE AND
IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION. THIS
IS BETTER APPROACH WORKING WITH
THE DENTIST CRAP FISHERY. WE'VE
INVESTED IN THE DUNGEON ASCRIBE
FISHING YOU'RE WORKING ROUP
AND COLLABORATIVE RESEARCH TO
SUPPORT THE RAMP. WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH NO WAY TO EXPAND
THE ENTANGLEMENT RESPONSE
NETWORK AND REDESIGNED THAT
WE'LL TRACKING TOOL THAT THEY
USE TO FREE ENTANGLED WHALES.
AND WE PARTNERED WITH THE HALF
MOON BAY COMMERCIAL FISHERIES
TRUST AND MEMBERS OF THE HAPPY
BAY SEAFOOD MARKETING
ASSOCIATION TO NINE. AND THREE
LEAD MANTA. MODEL FOR. HERE
INITIATIVES HAVE. THE EFFECTIVE
OF THE APPROACH AND WE THINK
THEY CAN SERVE AS A MODEL FOR
ADDRESSING A TANGLE RISK ON THE
WEST COAST. FIVE YEARS INTO OUR
PARTNERSHIP IN AN INDUSTRY LED
COMMERCIAL LOSSKY RECOVERY
PROGRAM WE'VE EXPANDED THE
PROGRAM'S OPERATION THE TWO
MAJOR CRAP PORTS. WE'VE
DEVELOPED A WEAPON PHONE
APPLICATION THAT PROVIDES FOR
STREAMLINED TRACKING OF GEAR
FROM OUT SEE RECOVERY TO FINAL
DISTRIBUTION. AND WE SUPPORTED
THE CREATION OF REGULATIONS
FORMALIZING THIS PROGRAM. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE WERE
COVERED OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
LOS POTS. THIS YEAR WITH TRIPLE
CA LEADERSHIP. WE'RE HOPING TO
EXPAND THE INDUSTRY LEAD
PROGRAM UP THE COAST. WE ALSO
PLAN TO CONTINUE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
ENSURE THAT REGULATION SUPPORT
AND EFFECTIVE PROGRAM OPERATION
AND EFFICIENT REPORTING. WE
THINK THIS PROGRAM IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW LEVERAGING
PARTNERSHIPS AND TECHNOLOGY CAN
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR MARINE
LIFE AND ARE FISHING
COMMUNITIES. AND WE THINK IT'S
A STRONG COMPLEMENT TO AN
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT APPROACH AS
WE'VE SEEN IN THE RAMP. THE
WORKING AS AN ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT ENTITY. AND THEY
CREATED THE RAMP AS A FIRST OF
ITS KIND ADOPTIVE RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOL. DRIVING
SUPPORTING RESEARCH THAT HAS
POSITION THE WEST COAST AS A
LEADER AND ENTANGLEMENT RISK
SCIENCE. IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
THE REGULATIONS TO FORMALIZE
THE RAMP TAKE AN ADAPTIVE
APPROACH INCLUDING A MEANINGFUL
ROLE FOR THE WORKING GROUP AND
USE OF ALL BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE. OUR SCIENTIFIC
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS DYNAMIC
ISSUE WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE
AND THE RAMP REGULATIONS MUST
BE WRITTEN TO ADOPT WITH THIS
PROGRESS IN THE WAY REGULATIONS
ARE WRITTEN MATTERS. WRITING
THE RAMP REGULATIONS USING
STANDARDS ALLOWS US TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ADAPT AS WE GAME
BETTER SCIENCE AND MORE
INFORMATION. IF WE'VE LEARNED
HUNTING IT'S THAT THIS IS A
DYNAMIC SITUATION AND WE NEED
TO AVOID OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE
LANGUAGE AND REGULATIONS. THE
FISHERMAN MANAGERS ARE BETTER
PREPARED FOR CHANGE. DOCTOR
CENTER IS RESEARCH PRESENTED
HERE TODAY IS A FANTASTIC
EXAMPLE OF INFORMATION WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PULL UP TO THE
RAMP. AND ADOPTED REGULATIONS
ARE BUT A LOT TO. WE ENCOURAGE
THE HERE- FROM DIRECTOR BONTA
FROM THE DEPARTMENT EARLIER
THAT. ROB DATED REGULATIONS
INTEND TO BE INCLUSIVE OF. ALL
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
WE'VE HEARD THAT THAT WILL
INCLUDE CONSIDERATION OF
OCEANOGRAPHIC AND FORAGE
CONDITIONS. AND FISHING
DYNAMICS. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE INDICATION THE UPDATED
REGULATIONS WILL BETTER TO FIND
THE ROLE THE WORKING GROUP AND
WE BELIEVE THIS SHOULD INCLUDE
THE WORKING GROUP'S ROLE AND
ASSESSING RISK. PROVIDING
MANAGEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THE ROLE AND CONTINUING TO
REFINE THE RAMP AND DRIVING
SCIENCE IMPROVE TECHNOLOGY.
WITH THIS THERE'S A NEED TO
EMPLOY ENSURE THE WORKING GROUP
HAS A PLAN TO BE ADEQUATELY
RESOURCE. WE BELIEVE THE SHOULD
INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR NATURE
FACILITATION WHICH HAS BEEN
CRUCIAL TO THE SPONSOR BODY. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ONGOING
LEADERSHIP. CENTER REQUIRE AND
OF THE OPC. INCLUDING FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF REGULATIONS
FORMALIZING THE RAMP AND THE
LOST YOUR RECOVERY PROGRAM WE
ALSO SUPPORT YOUR CURRENT BILL
SB ONE ONE TWO EIGHT. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE PARTNERSHIP
WITH MANAGERS THE OPC FISHERMEN
SCIENTISTS AND NGOS AS WE
CONTINUE TO DRIVE COOPERATIVE
ADAPTIVE SOLUTIONS TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR MARINE LIFE AND
OUR FISHERIES. THANK YOU FOR
BEING SUCH A GREAT PLAYER HERE
TODAY YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
WOULD OPEN UP TO PAY ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER VICE CHAIR AT
I THINK JUST A COMMA BECAUSE IT
IS COME UP SO SIGNIFICANTLY
WITH THIS PANEL BUT IT'S ALSO
INHERENT. TO A LOT OF WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING OF THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS IN THIS
THIS NOTION OF ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT AND BUILDING AND
SOME FLEXIBILITY. BECAUSE TOO
OFTEN. REGULATORY SCHEMES ARE.
SET UP BASED ON AN
UNDERSTANDING OF SCIENCE. AND
THEN AS THAT PROGRESSES IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT THAN FOR
THE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT TO
FOLLOW SO SETTING UP A SCHEME
THAT ALLOWS FOR SOME
FLEXIBILITY. IN ORDER TO KEEP
TRACK OF AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE
QUICKLY MOVING SCIENCE AS LONG
AS WE HAVE A WAY OF BEING ABLE
TO VERIFY VALIDATE AND MAKE
SURE THAT THAT SCIENCE IS
KEEPING UP THAT SHOULD INFORM.
THE REGULATORY PROCESS THERE
AND- I THINK WE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY WITH ESPECIALLY
HERE TO BE ABLE TO TRY AND DO
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY THAT HAS TYPICALLY
BEEN DONE. IN GOVERNMENT BEFORE
AS LONG AS WE HAVE APPROPRIATE
LEVELS OF OVERSIGHT. FROM THE
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS FROM ALL OF
THE PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THESE ISSUES.
ENSURING THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IMPACTS. TALK ABOUT THE SITE
AND BRING IN THE SCIENCE AND SO
UNLIKE WHAT WE ARE SEEING AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. WE COULD DO
SOMETHING. MUCH MORE
EFFICIENTLY I THINK HERE AND
KEEP THE STATE ALSO I THINK
NEEDS TO EXPAND ITS ROLE IN.
FUNDING EXPERIMENTATION FUNDING
SCIENCE AND ENSURING THAT WE
ARE KEEPING THAT INFORMATION
COMING TO US THAT'S ONE OF
THINGS WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THAT IS WHEN THINGS THAT. THAT
WE IS AS A BODY NEED TO PAY A
LITTLE BIT. MORE ATTENTION TO.
AND WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
LOOKING AT ADAPTIVE PRACTICE
SAYS AND EVEN STARTING TO
SEPARATE IN PERMITTING. WHAT IS
BENEFICIAL TO THE ENVIRONMENT
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT EVERY
PERMITTING ACTION AS- WHETHER
IT'S POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENT ALL AS THE KIND OF
SAME THING SO. WE'RE LEARNING
WE'RE TAKING STEPS AND THEN THE
THAT'S WHY THIS TESTIMONY AND
PERSPECTIVES ARE VERY
INFORMATIVE TO US AS WE LOOK
FOR TO REALLY MOVING THESE
THESE FRAMEWORKS FORWARD AND
EVEN THE DISCUSSION ABOUT. FISH
WILD BY FLOODING THE NEW
AIRCRAFT WELL. BY UTILIZING THE
SCIENCE IT'S A BIG OCEAN AND
IT'S SO IT AND THERE'S A LOT TO
LOOK AT OUT THERE. THE BETTER
WE UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE THE
BETTER WE CAN DIRECT THOSE
RESOURCES TO BE EFFECTIVE. MORE
QUICKLY AND- MORE APPROPRIATELY
GIVEN THE AND DID WHATEVER THEY
THEY THE IMPACTS HAPPENING IN
THE ENVIRONMENT SO I. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE EACH OF THE
PERSPECTIVES HERE I THINK THAT
FEEDS IN VERY MUCH WHAT WE WERE
HEARING FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
EARLIER AND I THINK NOW. FOR US
AS WELL SETTING STATUTORY.
POLICY AND FRAMEWORK CENTER
WHICH REGULATIONS ARE DONE ANY
WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF. THIS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
THE RELATIONSHIPS THE
PARTNERSHIP THE INFORMATION
FLOW AND HAVE AS BEST EFFECT AS
WE CAN REALLY ACROSS THE BOARD
ON THE FISHERIES. THAT'S WHAT'S
EXCITING ABOUT THE- TASK FORCE
IN LOOKING AT. THE HAVING ALL
THE PARTICIPANTS AT THE TABLE
AS WE TRY AND SORT THROUGH THE
CHALLENGES FOR THE INDUSTRY BUT
ALSO AS WE TRY TO MANAGE OUR
ENVIRONMENT SO I- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORTY THESE
PERSPECTIVES. AND I THINK WE'RE
WE HAVE A ROADMAP IF WILL STICK
TO IT. THANK YOU MISTER ASHER
ANY COMMENTS ON VICE CHAIRS-
COMMENTS THAT HE SAID. ANY
FEEDBACK. LIKE TO SAY ONE THING
ABOUT THE PLANO WE SEEM TO GET
CHEN THEM ON THE MIKE IF THAT'S
ALRIGHT. SO SOME OF THE IDEAS
THAT WE HEAR COMING- FROM
OUTSIDE INDUSTRY ARE NOT
PRACTICAL AND WOULD ACTUALLY
HELP- ADDRESS THE ISSUE ON THE
OCEAN- ONE OF THOSE IDEAS IS
ROBUST HERE DOT DOT WE THINK WE
HAVE MUCH BETTER IDEAS WITHIN
INDUSTRY AND- IF YOU LOOK
AROUND OTHER FISHERIES THAT
HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH THE S. A.
ISSUES AN APPLICATION PROCESS
THAT. THE MATH SKILLS USED COME
FROM INSIDE INDUSTRY SOMETIMES
AS PART PARTNER FOR OUR
RESEARCH BETWEEN- DIFFERENT
GROUPS BUT ALWAYS TESTED BY
FISHERMEN ON THE WATER. WEEK
CIRCLE HOOK IN- PELAGIC
LONGLINE FISHERY THE TROLL
EXCLUDE OR IN THE TRIAL
FISHERIES OFF THE WEST COAST
THESE ARE SIMPLE PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS AND THAT'S USUALLY
WHERE WE'RE GONNA THAT'S WE'RE
GOING TO. THAT THE MAGIC PILL
HERE IT'S GONNA BE A SIMPLE
PRACTICAL LOW COST SOLUTION
THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE HUGE
MODIFICATION THE GEAR THAT WE
ALREADY FISH. AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE LIKE THE- JUST LOOKING
AT MORE CLOSELY. WHETHER IT'S-
IT'S NOT EVEN NECESSARILY
FINDING IT'S JUST BEING ALLOWED
TO GO OUT THERE AND TEST SOME
OF OUR OWN IDEAS IMPROVE THAT
WHAT DOES AND DOESN'T WORK AND
WHAT DIRECTION WE MIGHT WANT TO
HEAD WITHOUT. PUTTING A PLANE
IN THE AIR TO MONITOR CRAB
BOATS WHILE THEY'RE FISHING AND
ORCHESTRATOR MOVEMENTS AS A
COMPLETELY IMPRACTICAL IDEA.
THEY WANT TO USE THAT PLAN FOR
MORE SURVEYS MORE COMPREHENSIVE
WIDER SURVEYS AND BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WELL DYNAMICS
RIGHT ON. IF THEY THINK THEY'RE
GONNA PUT THE PLANE IN THE AIR
AN ORCHESTRATED CRAB FLEET
THAT'S NOT A CRAB FISHERY
WORKS. BUT I THINK THE IDEA IS
TO BE MONITORING THE ANIMALS
OUT THERE. AND I THINK WE ALSO
HAVE. WELL INTENDED TO SERIOUS
ISSUE BUT WELL STRIKES FROM
SOME OF THE COMMERCIALS THAT
NOT THE FISHING INDUSTRY BUT-
FROM THE- THE SHIPS THAT ARE
OUT THERE. SO THAT AIRCRAFT IS
A RESOURCE REALLY TO MONITOR A
NUMBER OF THINGS WHICH IS WHY.
THE BETTER WE UNDERSTAND THE
SCIENCE AND BEHAVIORS AND SO
THAT. AS THE WARM WATER AND-
COOL WATER OF UP WELLING GIVE
US IDEAS OF ZONES TO LOOK AT.
TRACKING THE WHALE MOVE MADE
COULD BE INFORMATIVE TO YOU. ON
THE WATER SO AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
TRACKING THE FISHING FLEET AS
MUCH AS TRACKING THE WHALES. TO
INFORM THE FISHERY ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE FACING A AND IN WHAT
THAT LANDSCAPE OUT THERE LOOKS
LIKE. TO MAKE DECISIONS THERE
SO THAT WE MINIMIZE
INTERACTIONS BUT I THINK THE
AIRCRAFT IS THE ALSO BORN AND
I'M HOPING WILL HELP US WITH
THE SHIP STRIKE ISSUE. TO BE
ABLE TO MONITOR OTHER SHIPPING
AND LAST I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE. A SUBSET OF
THAT IS GOING TO BE HELPING.
CRAB INDUSTRY HERE. BY
MONITORING IF THEY KNOW BETTER
WHERE TO LOOK BECAUSE WE'RE
USING MORE APPROPRIATE SCIENCE
REALLY WAS MY POINT. THAT BACKS
GOING TO NARROW. THE KIND OF
THEIR TASK AND THEY MAKE IT
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EASIER TO
GET YOU THE INFORMATION YOU
NEED ABOUT THE WELLS AREWHERE
THE WELLS ARE SO THAT WE CAN
AVOID THE CONFRONTATIONS YEAH-
YEAH I'LL JUST CHIME IN AND SAY
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH WHAT
YOU'VE SAID ABOUT SCIENCE BEING
ABLE TO. STEER OUR RESOURCES
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND I THINK
THAT'S A BIG BENEFIT- AND WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT THIS BEING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
REALLY BE A LEADER. IN
DEVELOPING AN ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT MODEL FOR THIS. THIS
DYNAMIC AND REALLY CHALLENGING
ISSUE. AND THE BAND'S POINT
EXPERIMENTATION AS CRITICAL-
THE INDUSTRY'S PERSPECTIVE. IS
CRITICAL AND THE INNOVATION
THAT WE CAN SEE HERE- COMING
OUT OF THIS OUT SEE
EXPERIMENTATION IT WILL BE
FUNDAMENTAL TO SOLVING THIS
ISSUE AND- WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
AN EXPERIMENTAL FISHING PERMIT
PROGRAM- UNDER DEVELOPMENT HERE
AND- AND NOT TO PROVIDE A GOOD
POP WAY FOR THAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WOULD LIKE TO GO TO MRS
IN TORA. TAKING YOUR FINDINGS
AND THE DATA. TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK. TO MAKING- FUTURE
PREDICTIONS ON CONDITIONS COULD
BE BAD COULD BE GOOD BUT TALK
ABOUT THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
ABOUT USING- THE DATA AND HOW
WE CAN APPLY YOUR RESEARCH TO.
HAVING BETTER PREDICTIONS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. I THINK OVERALL
IT IT REDUCES OUR- FIND
UNCERTAINTY IN THE AND INCREASE
THEIR BILL ABILITY TO DETECT
FALSE POSITIVE SOMEONE I MEAN
BY THAT IS SAY SAY WE MAKE A
DECISION MARCUS SO WITH THAT
DECISION IS BUT THIS IT'S
RATHER SEVERE AND- IT'S GONNA
HAVE SOME SEVERE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE FISHERY I THINK
WE WOULD WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE OCEAN
ENVIRONMENT. IT'S NOT A BLACK
BOX WE KNOW A LOT ABOUT THE
OCEAN WE WITH MODERATE ON
INCREDIBLE RESOLUTION OF
SPATIAL AND TEMPORAL SCALES BUT
ULTIMATELY I MEAN THE THING
THAT'S MISSING FROM TODAY'S
CONVERSATION ARE HEARING RATHER
IS CLIMATE IN CLIMATE
VARIABILITY AND IT IS
INCREASING THERE'S THAT'S A
FACT YEAH WITH INREASE CLIMATE
VARIABILITY THAT MEANS
INCREASED ECOSYSTEM VARIABILITY
WHICH MEANS GREATER UNCERTAINTY
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE TOOLS YET
WE HAVEN'T BUILT THOSE TOOLS.
AND I THINK THIS ECHOES BACK TO
EARLIER WHEN WE WERE- THE
SECRETARY WAS MENTIONING
ASPECTS ABOUT- COMPLIANCE
SCIENCE INCOME COMBAT SCIENCE
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU
HAVE THE MANAGEMENT LEADING THE
SCIENCE WE DON'T INVEST IN
CREATIVE TRANSFORMATIVE SCIENCE
TO SOLVE THESE REALLY
CHALLENGING PROBLEMS AND TO DO
THIS WE NEED A DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP WE NEED TO
HEAR FROM OUR FISHING
COMMUNITIES ARE SCIENTISTS AND
A CONSERVATIONIST TOGETHER SO.
SPECIFICALLY THE TOOL BOX THAT
I CREATED WITH MY COLLEAGUES-
THAT IS GOING TO BE LIVE IN A
LIVE THERE FOREVER AND MORE MY
HOPE IS THAT WE CAN WE CAN
DEFINITELY SEE THESE LOOMING
MAJOR PER PERFECT STORMS IF YOU
WILL OF- EITHER A MARINE HEAT
WAVE WE HAD ONE LAST YEAR AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WE'VE BEEN IN
THIS PROLONGED MARINE HEAT WAVE
STATE. WE CAN SEE THESE THINGS
COMING AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THESE THESE INDICATORS
THAT WE DEVELOPED TO PREVENT
WHAT HAPPENED DURING TWENTY
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN IT WAS
UNNECESSARY WE COULD BE SORT
COMING IT WAS A FAILURE ON THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY'S PART TO
GET THE MESSAGE OUT TO THE
RESOURCE MATT AND THAT'S WHY
I'M- TO REINSURER THAT. WE DO
HAVE THE SCIENCE AND WE CAN.
UTILIZE IT NO THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU. LISTEN CHEN
ON THE PANEL WE WANT TO SAY HOW
MUCH WE APPRECIATE EACH OF YOU
BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY YOUR ADVOCACY WE
LOOK FOR WORK WITH YOU HERE IN
THE MONTHS TO COME. THANK YOU
pGONNA BE MOVING FORWARD AS WE
TALKED ABOUT. WITH THAT AUDIBLE
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING IN. ITEM
NUMBER SIX ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AQUACULTURE LEGISLATIVE UPDATES
TO OUR NEXT PANEL. WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE ROB HUCK
ROCKS HERE TODAY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ISSUES AND SEE VERY INSTITUTE
IN GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ADVISER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AQUACULTURE
ASSOCIATION IN ADDITION WE HAVE
MARIE THERESE WAS CATCHING A
FLIGHT- SO HEAD ON BACK HOME TO
SEATTLE I DIRECTOR OF
REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR PACIFIC
SEAFOOD BUT WE WANT TAKE MOMENT
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BOTH
YOU BEING HERE- EACH OF YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES SO GIVE YOU A
ONE MINUTE PROMPT. IT REALLY
MEANS A LOT- THAT YOU TOOK THE
TIME TO BE ABLE TO COME SOUTH-
RAIN THAT YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES THANK YOU
SENATOR GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARIE THERESE AND AS A
SENATOR SAID MY NAME IS EXCUSE
ME I AM THE DIRECTOR REGULATORY
AFFAIRS FOR PACIFIC SEAFOOD. I
HAVE THE GREAT PLEASURE OF
TRAVELLING PACIFIC COAST ON A
DAILY BASIS- THROUGH WASHINGTON
THE OREGON COAST AND DOWN TO
THE CALIFORNIA'S HUMBOLDT BAY.
I MYSELF AM IS A FOURTH
GENERATION SHELLFISH. FARMER MY
GRANDFATHER LIKE MANY IN THIS
ROOM. CAME TO THE UNITED STATES
SEEKING A BETTER LIFE. AFTER
FIGHTING IN WORLD WAR TWO WORLD
WAR ONE EXCUSE ME HE CAME TO
CITIZENSHIP AND BECAME A
FISHMONGER SAVING EVERY PENNY
IN TEN YEARS HE WAS ABLE TO
EXPAND THE RAPIDLY GROWING
SHELLFISH FARMING WORLD. AND
BOUGHT HIS OWN FARM. SIMILARLY
THE COMPANY I NOW WORK FOR
PACIFIC SEAFOOD AND ITS
FOUNDERS THE DEL SUCH FAMILY
BEGAN WITH MEAGER MEANS AND
THROUGH HARD WORK AND
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITIES
IT OPERATES AND HAS BEEN ABLE
TO GROW TO OPERATE IN FORTY ONE
FACILITIES IN ELEVEN. DIFFERENT
STATES. IN MY WILL HOUSE I GET
TO MANAGE SIXTEEN THOUSAND
ACRES OF TIED LANDS. ACROSS THE
BUTTE BEAUTIFUL WEST COAST A
PRIVILEGE AND AN HONOR THAT I
HOLD IN THE HIGHEST REGARD.
ADDITIONALLY I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS THE
THIRD TERM PRESIDENT OF THE
PACIFIC COAST SHELLFISH GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AN ORGANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS SHELLFISH
FARMERS FROM ALASKA OREGON.
WASHINGTON HAWAII AND HERE IN
THE GOLDEN STATE A CALIFORNIA.
THIS ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS A
WIDE VARIETY OF SPECIES
INCLUDING OYSTERS CLAMS. AND
MUSSELS OR OUR ORGANIZATION
ALSO REPRESENTS EVERYONE FROM
THE MOM AND POP FARM WHERE
EVERY COST NEW REGULATION. IS
FELT RIGHT AT THE DINNER PLATE.
WE ALSO REPRESENT COMPANIES AS
MINE THAT REPRESENT THE BIGGEST
INDUSTRIES THAT ALSO FEEL THE
SAME BURDEN WE FEEL THE BURDEN
OF OVER REGULATION HELPING TO
REPRESENTS NOT JUST OURSELVES
BUT OUR FELLOW MOM AND POP
FARMS. AND OFFERED RESOURCES
WHERE OTHERWISE THEY WOULD BE
LOST. NOT SURE IF EVERYONE IN
THE ROOM REALIZES THIS BUT ONE
MATURE OYSTER HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE ABILITY TO
FILTER FIFTY GALLONS OF WATER
EVERY DAY. IN FACT IN ESTUARIES
ON THE EAST COAST WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO SEE INVESTMENTS
INTO REINTRODUCING OYSTERS INTO
THESE WATER BODIES FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF WATER QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT. THESE ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES NOT ONLY IMPROVE THE
WATER BUT THEY OFFER AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SEE HOW
WE CAN PULL FARM AND WORK
WITHIN THE ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT
IN OVER BURDENING REGULATORY
SCHEME. WATER IS A RESOURCE ONE
THAT IS IMPERATIVE TO HUMAN
LIFE. SHELLFISH IS A PARTNER IN
THAT GOAL SHELLFISH OF SOME OF
THE HEALTHIEST PROTEIN ON THIS
PLANET. IN FACT SOME THE
OYSTERS THAT MANY IN THIS ROOM
ENJOYED LAST NIGHT ARE
NATURALLY HIGH IN THINGS LIKE
ZINC IRON CALCIUM AND B. TWELVE
AMONG AMONG OTHER NUTRIENTS.
HEARING CALIFORNIA OYSTERS HAVE
BEEN PART OF THE CULTURE SINCE
THE GOLDRUSH THE ICONIC OLYMPIA
OYSTER WAS ALMOST DEPLETED IN
THE EARLY EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS DUE
TO THE OVER HARVEST AND MASS.
MASSIVE INTO INDUSTRIALIZATION
OF THE HYDRAULIC MINING
RESULTING AND DESTROYING.
HABITAT AND OVER SILTING
THANKFULLY THAT POPULATION IS
RETURNING. TO INTO ICONIC
PLACES LIKE THE SAN FRANCISCO
HARBOR. IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS THE PACIFIC OYSTER WAS
ALSO INTRODUCED. INTO THE
WATERS OF THE WEST COAST AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE DEPLETED
OLYMPIA OYSTER THIS SPECIES WAS
A ROARING SUCCESS IT GREW
FASTER IT GREW BIGGER AND HAD A
FLAVOR PROFILE ENJOYABLE. BY A
WIDER VARIETY OF PEOPLE AND WE
HAVE IT LOOKS BACK. UNTIL NOW.
WE'RE FACING AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOLKS WITHIN STATE AGENCIES TO
FORBID. THE GROWING AND
CULTIVATION OF THE PACIFIC
OYSTER. AND NATURAL AYE SPECIES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR IT TO BE CONSIDERED
INVASIVE IS REALLY A SAD SAD
SHAME. THE PACIFIC OYSTER THE
MANILA CLAM IN THE OLYMPIA
OYSTER ARE ALL AS WELL AS THE
BURGEONING OYSTER NOW BEING
GROWN ALL OVER THE GOLDEN STATE
THE SHELLFISH INDUSTRY EMPLOYS
HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
LIVING WAGE JOBS AND OUR
BUSINESSES CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE STATE'S
TAX REVENUE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ROBUST NIXON'S OF COASTLINE.
GROWING SHELLFISH TO FEED
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD IS
CLEARLY A GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
HOWEVER IT'S NOT WITHOUT ITS
CHALLENGES. WELL THERE FARMS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE BEEN IN
OPERATION FOR CLOSE TO A
CENTURY NAVIGATING THE
REGULATIONS IN THE VAST NUMBER
OF AGENCIES INVOLVED IN
DUPLICATIVE AND EXPENSE OF
PERMITTING IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
THANKFULLY LAST YEAR WITH YOUR
HELP SENATOR. WITH A UNANIMOUS
VOTE THE STATE SENATE PASSED
SENATE BILL TWO SIX TWO.
REQUIRING AGENCIES LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND OTHERS TO ENGAGE. WITH EACH
OTHER AND WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO STREAMLINE AND REMOVED
DUPLICATIVE PERMITTING AND
MONITORING THE ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU. THE STREAMLINING IS
A WIN WIN FOR THOSE AGENCIES
AND THE STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE
RESOURCES BEING SAFE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
BUSINESSES INVOLVED IN THESE
ACTIVITIES. AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF SHELLFISH FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR DILIGENT AND
CONTINUED EFFORTS IN GETTING
SENATE BILL TWO SIX TWO PASSED
YOU HAVE BEEN CONTINUE TO BE A
CHAMPION FOR INDUSTRY. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THOSE AGENCIES EVEN
THOUGH THAT WORK HAS NOT YET
BEGUN. WE HAVE NINE MONTHS LEFT
BASED ON WHAT THE WAS WRITTEN
IN THAT BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THAT WORK
STARTED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
POINT OUT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
CONTINUING FUNDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. RIGHT NOW WE'RE FACING
US EXTENSION CRISIS WITHIN NOT
JUST THE STATE BUT AROUND THE
WORLD. AND THE THOUGHT OF
REMOVING A RESOURCES TO THINGS
LIKE STATE LABS IS JUST ON
ACCEPTABLE. WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR PARTNERS WITH
OUR LABS WITH OUR INSPECTION
TEAMS WITH OUR WATER QUALITY
PROGRAMS TO REACH AND THAT WAS
REQUIRES STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
BUT ALSO REQUIRES RA RESOURCES.
HEARING CALIFORNIAN ALONG THE
WEST COAST OUR INDUSTRY RELIES
ON GOOD SENSIBLE REASONABLE
REGULATION PROTECTING WATER
SENSITIVE HABITATS POLLUTION
WASTE IS OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY WE NEED THESE EFFORTS
TO BE BASED IN SCIENCE. AND
BASED IN OUR LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTS. WE NEED MORE
PARTNERS IN THIS EFFORT WE ARE
SO THANKFUL FOR THE PARTNERS
THAT WE HAVE IN MANY OF THE
EXISTING AGENCIES CONSERVATION
GROUPS AND NGOS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO GROWING HOPEFULLY.
INCLUDING THOSE AGENCIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LESS FAVORABLE TO OUR
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE AND TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OUR
INDUSTRY. THREE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GO TO HEAR- INTO SECOND
MISTER ROSS. BUT I WAS JUST ME
WITH A GOOD FOLKS. FROM HI
ISLAND OVER THE WEEKEND. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE NINE
MONTHS ENDED UP WHAT WE LIKE TO
BE A TO DO IN JULY- PUT
TOGETHER- KIND OF A CHECK IN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT- WHETHER
IT'S IN HUMBOLDT OR POTENTIALLY
WEST MARIN. I BRING SOME
REPRESENTATIVES- FROM
DEPARTMENT OUT. AND HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
AT. AND HOW WE'RE GONNA
IMPLEMENT- IN THAT THIS IS TO
GET THIS IN MONTHS SEVEN. SO WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME IN
CASE WERE GOING OFF THE RAILS
AS FAR AS TIMELINE. TO GET BACK
ON SO WOULD LOVE TO BE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT WONDERFUL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT IT'S GREAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A
CONCERN OF- MANY OF YOUR
MEMBERS AS WELL SPEAKING CHIU
ABLE. TO GET I WILL SAY WE
CHECKED IN WITH CALLS
COMMISSION A. BEEN GOOD- AT TEN
THERE CAN BE A HIT. CHALLENGES
ONLY HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
DOING THE WHOLE THING SO- AND
MORE TO COME ON THAT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THE
REALITY WE DEAL WITH WITH THAT
AGENCY THEY HAVE VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES AND- A LOT OF IT AND
UP IN ONE PERSON'S PLATE YEAH.
IN HIS I KNOW HE'S HUSTLING BUT
IT'S- SO MORE TO COME WE LOOK
FOR THE WORK WITH YOU ALL
RIGHT. I LAYS IN YOUR WE'RE NOW
GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
ROB ROSS THE EXACTLY DIRECTOR
THE COMPANY FISHERIES AND
SEAFOOD INSTITUTE- IN HIS THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS PAC-
ADVISER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
AQUACULTURE ASSOCIATION. THRUST
COULD SEE SIR IT SEE YOU SIR
AND THANK YOU WE DON'T GET TO-
SAY THANK YOU TO YOU. AND TO
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND TO TOM. A NOT
FORGET TO SAY THANKS TO TOM
QUITE A BIT BUT I HAD. EVEN
MORE TO THE EFFORTS. OF ALL OF
YOU. I'M THANKS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE INDUSTRY- AND
WHAT YOU DO TO PROTECT. AND
ENHANCE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY. I
HAVE TO TOP THINGS TO SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY. ONE IS THIS
COMMITTEE INITIATED THE
DISASTER RELIEF THAT
UNFORTUNATELY WAS NEEDED FOR
THE CRAB INDUSTRY THE SALMON
INDUSTRY. THE STARTING INDUSTRY
THE URCHIN IN DISARRAY AND-
PERHAPS EVEN IN THE FUTURE THE
SQUID INDUSTRY. BUT WE HAVE ALL
BENEFITED FROM YOUR DOG
DETERMINATION AND FOR THE AID
RECEIVED AND THE PENDING- AID
THAT IS STILL- EXPECTED- RANDY
FISHER FROM THE PACIFIC STAYS
RAIN FISHERIES COMMISSION LEFT
FOR WASHINGTON ON SUNDAY HE'S
BEEN LOBBYING WITH THE TEAM TO
GET OMB AND COMMERCE. TO BUST
LOOSE SOME OF THE FUNDS THAT
SEEM TO GET LOST IT'S IMPORTANT
TO US I KNOW IT'S- PENCIL
SHAVING DOES TOO- OMB INTO
COMMERCE BUT IT'S GOING TO BE.
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE IN THE SEAFOOD
INDUSTRY. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ON BEHALF OF A GRATEFUL
INDUSTRY FOR- YOUR AUTHORSHIP
OF TWO SIXTY TWO LAST YEAR AN
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THIS YEAR
THAT IF ENACTED WILL PROVIDE A
VERY IMPORTANT OPTION TO PEOPLE
IN THE CRAB INDUSTRY IT'LL
ALLOW AN OPTION OF YOU THIS
RATING CRAB AS YOU KNOW THE
TWENTY PART PER MILLION DEMOC
ACID LEVELS THAT TRIGGER
WHETHER OR NOT CRAB FISHING CAN
GO ON. THOSE LEVELS ARE
NORMALLY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CUTS. THE VISCERA OF THE CRAB.
BUT IF WE CAN REMOVE THAT. AS
IS DONE NOW AS AN INDUSTRY%
PRACTICE QUICKLY BODY MEET AND
THE LET ME. WE DO AWAY WITH THE
PROBLEM OF DEMO CASTED BEING IN
THAT CRAB MEAT. AND I'LL
CONCLUDE THE SAYING WE NEED
MORE SEAFOOD WE NEED MORE
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES AND WE
WILL. NEED TO AUGMENT THESE
RESOURCES GOING FORWARD. FOOD
SECURITY IS NATIONAL. SECURITY
IN MORE WAYS THAN ONE. AND WE
CAN AFFORD TO DENY THIS. IN THE
THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW GLOBAL
DEMAND FOR SEAFOOD WILL
INCREASE BY SEVENTY PERCENT.
THAT'LL BE THREE BILLION MORE
PEOPLE ON THE PLANET. WE MUST
DO OUR PART BY INCREASING
ACCESS TO- FISHING AND FISHING
AT MAXIMUM SUSTAINABLE. YIELD
LEVELS WE MUST ALSO AUGMENT.
WHERE WE CAN THE SEAFOOD. TO
OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR CITIZENS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS MUCH
AT MR RUSS'S VERY GRATEFUL AND
I THINK. I THINK YOU'LL AGREE I
THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IS A NUMBER
ONE- BEING ABLE TO FARM OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST- AND THE
NUMBER TWO HAVING A CERTAINTY
WHEN IT COMES TO REGULATION
RIGHT- TIMELINE HOW LONG IT
WOULD TAKE TO BE A TO GET
PERMITTED- AND- CAN REALLY WHAT
I'VE HEARD A LOT FROM. YOUR
CLIENTS IS GIVE US A BOX RIGHT
WE NEED TO LIVE IN. AND TELL US
WHAT WE NEED TO BE TO DO TO GET
THERE I AND I THINK THAT'S BEEN
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE- OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST SPREADABLE BUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH IN A LIGHT
AT- COMMENT ON THAT WILL TURN
OVER THE VICE CHAIR. IF HE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS AS WELL. PLEASE
ZERO TO THE VICE CHAIR OF. WELL
DID NOT VISIBLE THEY'RE NOT
SPECIFICALLY A QUESTION BUT
THIS SOON TALK ABOUT THE OYSTER
INDUSTRY. AND THIS NOTION OF
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT AND BRING
SCIENCE TO BEAR. LIKE WHAT
WE'VE BEEN LEARNING ABOUT
PLACES THE EEL GRASS THAT ARE
BENEFICIAL THEY ARE. SO
REGULATORY SCHEMES THAT HAVE
EXISTED FOR A LONG TIME HAD
WANTED TO SEPARATE THOSE BUT RE
THINKING THAT THAT THAT'S- YET
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHERE BRING
SCIENCE. INTO THE REGULATORY
CONTACTS ENSURING THAT HOW
WE'RE DOING PERMITTING AND
BEING WILLING TO LEARN AS WE
MOVE ALONG IS BENEFICIAL TO THE
INDUSTRIES AND THAT'S ALSO COME
THROUGH PART. BY WORKING WITH
THE INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THE
AGENCIES IN ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT INFORMATION AS
WE NEEDED AS WE ARE MAKING
DECISIONS IS ULTIMATELY VERY
IMPORTANT. MR SO MISTER VICE
CHAIR OF THE NAY. THAT COULD BE
PART OF AQUACULTURE RIGHT
ENHANCING EELGRASS BY GROWING
HILL GRASS AND PUTTING IT WHERE
WE WANT TO HAVE A BENEFICIAL
USE MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
RESPONSE WITH REGARD TO- THE
BOX IF YOU MENTION. ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN A NEW
WAY OF AQUACULTURE TO AUGMENT
EXISTING COMMERCIAL FISHING
SUPPLIES OF FISH. WHAT IN
ESSENCE BE A NEW FISHERY BUT IT
ALSO HAS A PROCESS WE HAVE A
SEQUEL PROCESS WE HAVE A NEPA
PROCESS AND CONCERNS AND IDEAS
AND- AND COMMENTS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO IMPROVE THAT. IS PART
OF A PROCESS AND WE LOOK
FORWARDTO DOING THAT JUST LIKE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO AFTER
SEVENTEEN YEARS HAVING A-
PROMISED PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. THERE WE GO. YEAH AND
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE HAVE
AN INDUSTRY THAT IS NOT AGAINST
REGULATION WE DEPEND ON GOOD
SENSIBLE SCIENTIFICALLY BASED
REGULATION TO PROTECT OUR
INDUSTRIES AS WELL. AND SO.
MAKING DECISIONS THAT ARE BASED
ON THAT SCIENCE IS IMPERATIVE
AND IT CAN'T BE SCIENCE THAT
IS- PROHIBITIVE OF GROWTH.YOUR
SPOT ON. AND TELL US WHAT YOU
WHAT I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
HIS. TELL US WHAT YOU NEED IT
WILL MEET YOU THERE RIGHT BUT
WE NEED THAT CONSISTENCY AND WE
WANT TO BE AT THE TABLE WE WANT
TO BE PARTNERS WE KNOW OUR
FIELD WE'VE MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS LIKE I SAID FOR
MULTIPLE GENERATIONS. WE KNOW
THE ESTUARIES AND THE WATER
BODIES THAT WE WORK AND IT'S IN
OUR INTEREST TO PROTECT THOSE
AND SO TO BE LOOKED AT AS NOT A
PARTNER IN THAT RELATIONSHIP
IS- VERY DISAPPOINTING. AND
DISHEARTENING. VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE TREK.
DOWN SOUTH THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY IT IS ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU SIR- AND VERY GRATEFUL. HEY
IT WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
JULY IS WELL IF THAT WORKS FOR
YOU ALL. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
SAFE TRAVELS ON. IF YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING BACK TO- OUR
NEXT PANEL IT THAT'S PANEL
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER FIVE AN
URGENT AND THIS IS ALL ABOUT
FISHERIES AN OFFSHORE WIND.
ENERGY AT THIS IS IN UPDATE
THAT WE LIKE TO BE A PROVIDE
FOLKS- LOOK. WE HAD A WHOLE
HEARING UP IN. YOU RE GOT-
ABOUT. AND WHAT WAS IT TOM YEAR
AGO. LAST MAKE COMING UP ON A
YEAR- AND WE WANT TO BE A TO
GET AN UPDATE ON ALL. ISSUES
RELATED. TO WIN- IN FULL
DISCLOSURE WE'RE GONNA BE
PUTTING TOGETHER. A WORKING
GROUP- WITH REPRESENTATIVES
FROM- THE OFF SHORE WHEN
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION REMAIN
BODY IN THE C. E. C. TO BE
PARTICIPATE- AND SOME
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. JUST TO
BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT. WHAT IS
NEEDED TO BE- TO MOVE FORWARD
ON OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY AND
SPECIALLY FOCUSED ON THE
STUDIES SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
OUR NEXT. PANELIST FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE WANNA IS A WELCOME
TO COMMISSIONER DOUGLAS A KAREN
DOUGLAS IS COMMISSIONER THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
SHE'S REALLY BEEN THE POINT
THAT FOR THE COMMISSION ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. SHE'S GOING TO
GIVE SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND ON
THE STATE'S APPROACH RAUSCHER
WIND. AND PERSPECTIVESIN
OPPORTUNITIES AND POTENTIALLY
OBSTACLES UP FOR OFFSHORE WIND
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE THEN I
DANIEL MILLS IS HERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ATTENDING. DIRECTOR
THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION SHE'S ME PROVIDING
AN UPDATE ON- THE INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW A SURE WIN
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING. BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL AS
WELL AS ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
HERE TO- THE GOLDEN STATE SHE'S
ALSO GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON
FROM THE INDUSTRY'S
PERSPECTIVE. ABOUT STATEWIDE
PLANNING IN OUT WHY THAT'S
GOING TO BE CRITICAL. AND THEN
WHAT WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT MIKE
CONROY IS HERE HE'S A PRESENT
IN THE WEST COAST FISHERIES- OF
WEST COAST FISHERIES
CONSULTANTS. HE IS GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON OFFSHORE RENEWABLE
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT FISHERIES.
FISHERMEN IN FISHING
COMMUNITIES AND HOW TO BE A TO
AVOID IT. MITIGATED AND
MINIMIZE AT IMPACT AND THAT'S
AT A HUGE PRIORITY. FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AS AT AT FISHING
COMMUNITIES HAVE ENOUGH ON THE
PLATE- IN HAVING ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES IS THE LAST THING WE
NEED ALL RIGHT. SO WITHOUT
FURTHER DO YOU THINK YOU THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE IT WAS SO
GOOD TO BE TO SEE THE
COMMISSIONER AT AT THE DINNER
INDEED YOU HAVE THE VOICE. I
DID HAVE THE OYSTER THEY'RE
DELICIOUS ALL RIGHT HEY IDEA. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MEDICALLY
SURE WE LOVE SENIOR HERE AT IN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIRMAN
WEIR VICE CHAIR STONE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AND TO PROVIDE
THE COMMITTEE WITH AN UPDATE ON
ACTIVITIES WITH REGARD OFFSHORE
WIND IN CALIFORNIA. SO I WAS
ASKED TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS
OPPORTUNITIES CHALLENGES AND
STATUS OF WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW AND SO I WILL DO THAT- IN
TERMS OF OPPORTUNITIES OFFSHORE
WIND HAS BECOME A MATURE
INDUSTRY ACROSS THE WORLD IT
IT'S A- VERY EFFECTIVE-
RENEWABLE ENERGY TECHNOLOGY
VERY COST EFFECTIVE IT'S BEEN
DEPLOYED AT SCALE. IN MANY
PARTS OF THE WORLD.
PARTICULARLY IN EUROPE-
INCREASINGLY IN ASIA AS WELL.
AND WHILE. THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE WOULD NEED IN CALIFORNIA OF
FLOATING OFFSHORE WIND IS LESS
DEVELOPED IT'S COMING ALONG AND
I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF- AND THE
RESOURCE WE HAVE OFF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST. OFFSHORE WIND
COULD PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING THE STATE. MEET ITS
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND CLIMATE
GOALS. WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT
RESOURCE OFF OF THE CENTRAL
COAST IN AN EVEN BETTER
RESOURCE OFF OF THE NORTH COAST
IN TERMS OF THE TECHNICAL
POTENTIAL AND CAPACITY FACTORS-
OFFSHORE WIND IS REASONABLY
COMPLIMENTARY TO THE SOLAR
GENERATION PROFILE SO. WHAT
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS THAT-
WHILE SOLAR GENERATION PEAKS IN
THE MIDDLE THE DAY OFFSHORE
WIND CAN ACTUALLY HELP US WITH
OUR EVENING RAMP WHEN WE ARE
OTHERWISE- RELYING ON- NATURAL
GAS FOR THE MOST PART. OF THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND- IT
OFFERS US ON THE CENTRAL COAST
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE USE OF
EXISTINGOF TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES. ARE
THERE ARE ALSO MANY CHALLENGES
WITH REGARD OFFSHORE WIND OF
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS TO OUR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE SO ON
THE CENTRAL COAST WE COULD
PROBABLY ACCOMMODATE. TWO TO
THREE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF
OFFSHORE WIND GENERATION IN
EXISTING. INFRASTRUCTURE AT
MORRO BAY IN DIABLO CANYON AND
THAT'S A HUGE POTENTIAL
BENEFIT. TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND TO OUR SYSTEM- BEYOND THAT
HOWEVER WHEN WE LOOK UP AT THE
NORTH COAST- IT WOULD TAKE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT TO
EXPORT OFFSHORE WIND FROM
THERE- AND REALLY IT BECOMES.
NOT ONLY A QUESTION OF COST BUT
IT SOME DEGREE A QUESTION OF
FEASIBILITY I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND MUCH BETTER AND
WE'RE TAKING SOME STEPS TO DO
THAT. THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT IS
COMPLEX. ECOSYSTEMS ARE COMPLEX
AND ALREADY IMPACTED AND YOU'VE
HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSION. ON
THAT TODAY- WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT WITH PROACTIVE
DATA COLLECTION SPATIAL
PLANNING RESEARCH AND OUTREACH-
THE COMMERCIAL FISHING INDUSTRY
IS THE INDUSTRY MOST DIRECTLY
IMPACTED. BY A OFFER WHEN
DEVELOPMENT AND- FROM WHAT I
HAVE SEEN LOOKING AT
EXPERIENCES IN OTHER COUNTRIES
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN- CREATIVE
AN IMPORTANT. EFFORTS TO ENGAGE
WITH THE FISHING COMMUNITY TO
THINK ABOUT MEDICATION TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU DO. ABOUT THAT
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS.
CERTAIN KINDS OF FISHING
PARTICULARLY TRAWLING JUST
REALLY. IS FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD
FROM FISHERMEN THEMSELVES LIKE
THAT THERE'D BEEN A WANT TO
pRISK THEIR EQUIPMENT DOING THAT
AROUND OFFSHORE WIND FACILITIES
AND SO- THERE'S A REAL-
CHALLENGE THERE. AND FOR THAT
REASON. OBVIOUSLY IN THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TO HAVE
HERE THE FISHING INDUSTRY HAS
TO BE AT THE TABLE AND PART OF
THE PROCESS AS WE LOOK AT WHERE
DO WE GO WHEN WE'RE DON'T WE GO
AND HOW MUCH POTENTIAL IS THERE
AND HOW DO WE GET THIS DONE-
TECHNOLOGY AND QUSAI I'VE
MENTIONED BRIEFLY THE LAST.
ISSUE A MENTION VISUAL IMPACTS
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE IS.
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS. IN THE
PROCESS WITH THE BUREAU OF THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF OCEAN ENERGY
MANAGEMENT WHEN WE WERE LOOKING
AT WHERE OFFSHORE WIND SHOULD
GO- THE STATE WAS PRETTY
ASSERTIVE ABOUT SAYING OFFER
WHEN SHOULD BE FURTHER FROM
SHORT TWENTY MILES OR MORE
FURTHER FROM SHORE AND- THE
FEDERAL AGENCY WENT ALONG WITH
THAT. IN ITS INITIAL ITERATION
OF CALL AREAS OR OR AREAS
WHERE- LEASING COULD OCCUR YOU
THE ONE. AGO WHEN THEY'RE
PERFECT. ALL RIGHT SO. BUT
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT HAPPENING-
WE HAD OUR THIRD TASK FORCE
MEETING ON TUESDAY- THE FOCUS
OF THAT MEETING WAS TO LOOK AT
SOME ADDITIONAL POSSIBLE AREAS
THAT A GROUP OF AGENCIES
FEDERAL AND STATE CAME UP WITH.
TO PROBLEM SOLVE ON THE CENTRAL
COAST BECAUSE THE CALL AREAS
THAT WE HAD INITIALLY COME UP
WITH. WERE DEEMED INCOMPATIBLE
FOR MILITARY ACTIVITIES- SOME
OF THOSE AREAS GO CLOSER TO THE
THOSE AREAS IN GENERAL GO
CLOSER SURE WE WOULD HAVE A MAP
WITH THE SEVENTEEN MILE LINE
AND A FIFTEEN MILE LINE. THERE
ARE VISUAL SIMULATIONS BEING
PREPARED THIS PUBLIC OUT
REACHES IT WERE WERE AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF INFORMAL OUT
REACH ON THAT AND I THINK I
THINK OF. THE LAST THING I'LL
SAY IS THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
THE ENERGY COMMISSION WE HAVE A
STRONG GROUP OF STATE AGENCIES
WORKING TOGETHER THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAVE REALLY
PARTNERED. ON THIS AND- THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IS
FUNDING A NUMBER OF REALLY
IMPORTANT. STUDIES THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE. AND I'LL
TALK ABOUT A COUPLE OF THEM I
I'M SURE AS WE GET INTO Q. NA
BUT THE ONE THAT ALL ALL
MENTIONED RIGHT NOW. IS THAT
THE- PC IS CURRENTLY FINALISING
A GRANT TO THE HUMBLE
FISHERMAN'S MARKETING
ASSOCIATION FOR MAPPING
EXERCISE THAT WOULD DIRECTLY
INVOLVE US FISHERMEN FROM DAHLE
NORT HUMBLED MENDOCINO COUNTIES
AND THEY'LL BE LOOKING AT
SPECIES SPECIES COMPLEX YOUR
TYPE FISHING AREA BY DEATH FOR
THE- SEA FLOOR SUBSTRATE. IN
SEASON AND MORE IN ORDER TO
BRING FISHERMEN CAN ENTER AND
THEIR INPUT DIRECTLY INTO SOME
OF OUR GEO SPATIAL PLANNING AND
SO THAT'S ONE THING I WANT TO
MENTION NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
COMMISSIONER REALLY GRATEFUL
WILL COME BACK IN JUST A BIT-
IF IT'S ALL RIGHT WE'RE IN TURN
OVER MISS MILLS AFTER AMERICAN
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION. BASED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA OF COURSE IS
BILLS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES A
NO GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE PROMPT
THE FLOORS YOURS MA'AM THANK
YOU FOR BEING COMMITTEE TODAY
COURSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR FOR THE
IMITATION AND THANK YOU TOM FOR
SETTING THIS ALL UP- I'VE JUST
BEEN VERY STRUCK BY THE-
ENGAGEMENT. AND REFERENCE. NOW
PROCESS. THAT I'VE HEARD TODAY
AND- THE NEED TO GET EVERYONE
WORKING TOGETHER NOT ONLY TO
PROVIDE GOOD SUSTENANCE. FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND BEYOND- BUT
I'M HERE. IN THE NAME OF.
PROVIDING CLEAN RELIABLE ENERGY
FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S-
PROBABLY INHERENTLY SOME
TENSION THERE SINCE WE'RE BOTH
LOOKING AT THE SAME AREAS FOR
THIS DEVELOPMENT BUT- I'M
REALLY HERE OUT OF RESPECT IN.
WANTING TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE FISHING INDUSTRY AND
WITH ALL OF YOU ON THIS. SO I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN%
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION- AND
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE U. S. WIND INDUSTRY ARE
PROTESTING PARTICIPATING
COMPANIES- DEVELOP SOLAR
STORAGE. TRANSMISSION OFFSHORE
WINDS- AND DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION AS WELL SO WE IT
TAKE A SORT OF ALL OF THE
ABRUPT ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH TO RENEWABLE ENERGY-
AFTER WIND IS VERY CLEARLY ON
THE HORIZON IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT PRESENTS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO ADVANCE ITS
POSITION. AS A CLEAN ENERGY
LEADER WHILE REALIZING
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCEBENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CLEAN ECONOMY JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF POTENTIAL
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE GIGAWATTS
WORTH OF TECHNICAL POTENTIAL
FOR OFFSHORE WIND ALONG ITS
COAST- THAT THOSE AREAS HAVE
BEEN SLOWLY SORT OF WINNOW DOWN
TO LOOK AT COMMERCIAL VIABILITY
AND POTENTIAL CONFLICTS AND- IN
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT STUDIES-
UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER. WHEN
OF THAT DOWN TO TWENTY ONE
GIGAWATTS OF TOTAL POTENTIAL IN
A STUDY OF FIVE SITES ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COAST. FOR
REFERENCE TWENTY ONE GIGAWATTS
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY WOULD BE
ABOUT 11% OF THE STATE'S TWENTY
FORTY FIVE RENEWABLE ENERGY
DEMAND- ANOTHER STUDY THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER NGUYEN PROJECT
BY THE AMERICAN JOBS PROJECT
IDENTIFIED- THAT EIGHTEEN
GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE WIND.
COULD SUPPORT. SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED JOBS IN
DOWNSTREAM INDUSTRIES. THANK
MANY TRAINING CONSTRUCTION%
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE AS
WELL AND THEN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- THE BUREAU OF OCEAN
ENERGY MANAGEMENT ISSUED A CALL
FOR NOMINATIONS AND INTEREST-
FOR THREE OFFSHORE WIND CALL
AREAS ALONG CALIFORNIA'S COAST.
ONE THE AREAS THAT COMMISSIONER
DOUGLAS REFERENCED AS WELL- AND
WE'RE WORKING TOWARD FINDING A
WAY TO CREATE ABOUT EIGHT
GIGAWATTS OF POTENTIAL FROM
THOSE THREE CALL AREAS FOR THE
OFFSHORE WIND INDUSTRY. THE
COMPANIES THAT RESPONDED TO
THAT- CALL INCLUDED FOURTEEN
GLOBAL DEVELOPERS OF FLOATING
AFTER NGUYEN TECHNOLOGY MANY OF
WHOM ALSO DO OTHER TYPES OF
ENERGY EXPLORATION SO THE
INTEREST IS REAL AND INVESTMENT
DOLLARS ARE ALREADY COMING TO
CALIFORNIA- IT'S ALSO WORTH
NOTING THAT I'M SURE WHEN CAN
COMPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
GENERATION AND LOAD PROFILE.
THAT WAS MENTIONED THIS AS WELL.
BUT IT I IN IN A STUDY BY THE
NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
LABORATORY LOOKING AT SIX
DIFFERENT SITES ON CALIFORNIA'S
COAST IT FOUND THAT ALL SIX OF
THOSE REFERENCE SITES HAD
HIGHEST WIND SPEEDS BETWEEN
FIVE AND SEVEN PM. IN THE
EVENING. HAS BEEN MOST FUNDING
FOR THE STATE AS WE TRANSITION
TO CLEAN ENERGY- I GET CARBON
OFFER SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN WE TEND TO RUN OUR FUTURE
PLANS- AND THEN VARIOUS THESE
OF ALSO ASSESS THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF OFFSHORE WIND AS
WELL- DENTAL REPAIR. FITS OF
ONE TO TWO. ONCE THE INDUSTRY
COMES SCALE AND IDENTIFYING
WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITIES IN
BEING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
IN MANUFACTURING CONSTRUCTION.
CONSTRUCTION OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE- BUT OF COURSE THIS
HEARING IS A COMMITTEE ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE SO ON
EDGE- SHIP WITH THE- MINISTRY.
AM I COLLEAGUES ON THE EAST
COAST AVE WORKED WITH A
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY COMMERCIAL
RECREATION. I THINK IT PRODUCT.
I CAN'T SAY. THESE HAVE BEEN
1100% REAL THERE IS A GOOD FIT
FOR TO WORK TOWARD RESOLUTION A
NUMBER OF PROJECT DEVELOPERS
ALSO HAVE BEGUN TO REACH OUT TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND FISHING
COMPANIES IN THE STATE- AS
TEY'RE INTERESTED IN SPECIFIC
AREAS FOR THEIR OWN PROJECT
SOME ARE JUST SORT OF WATCHING
THE MARKET TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE BILL I'M LEASE SALES
BEFORE REALLY HAPPEN SING ONE
PARTICULAR AREA OR WHAT
COMMUNITY. AND THEN YOU KNOW
THE BUREAU. MY PROCESS AS- I
HAVE TO BALANCE THE CIVIC
FACTORS AND FEEDBACK FROM THE
PUBLIC I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S SOME CONCERN THAT
THAT'S NOT SUFFICIENT FOR
RESOLVING SOME OF THESE
CONFLICTS- BUT INDUSTRY IS ALSO
WORKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOMB
PROCESS TO ENGAGE WITH STINK
AND IS AND THEN WE'RE PROPOSING
A STATEWIDE PLANNING PROCESS TO
HELP BUILD THE INDUSTRY TO
SCALE TO REALIZE THE MANY
BENEFITS THAT OPTION WE CAN
PROVIDE AND I CAN. OF WHAT WHAT
WE'RE BANQUET ENCOMPASS WOULD
BE STAKEHOLDER REACH TO AVOID
MINIMIZE AND MITIGATE CONFLICT
AS THE OPTION WHEN IT WIND ST
GROUP WAS I WE WANT TO CREATE A
FORM THEIR FEEDBACK THE FISHING
COMMUNITY ANTI BY DATA OR RISK.
FOR WHEN AMPLE OF. THAT WERE
CONTEMPT. PLAN BE A AN ANALYSIS
OF PORT INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW
PORTS COULD BE. ARE POTENTIALLY
RETROFITTED TO HELP SUSTAIN AN
OFFSHORE WIND INDUSTRY I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S ALSO
CONCERN AMONG- THE FISHING
COMMUNITY THAT. THAT COULD
OVERBURDEN THE FACILITIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY THERE FOR THE
FISHING. INDUSTRY SO WE WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER AND FINDING WAYS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S CO
EXISTENCE AND COMPATIBILITY IN
AND- OUT AS THE INDUSTRY MOVES
FORWARD. OTHER ELEMENTS OF THE
PLAN WOULD BE STAKEHOLDER I'D
AS STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT ON
SITE IDENTIFICATION. ASSESSMENT
OF ECOLOGICAL AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES AND PERMITTING.
TRANSMISSION AND PROCUREMENT
PLANNING. AND JUST MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN BUILD THIS INDUSTRY
TO SCALE TO GET THE WORK FORCE
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS THAT
WEEK- BELIEVE ARE POSSIBLE SO
I'M SURE NGUYEN PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
REALIZE TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE
GAINS FOR THE ECONOMY
ENVIRONMENT AND WORK FORCE- AND
REALLY TO ADDRESS ANY OF THE
MANY SIGNIFICANT THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA'S FISHERY WHICH IS
CLIMATE CHANGE. ARE WE HOPE
WORK TO ENHANCE FISHING RENO
OPPORTUNITIES YES COAST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH BUSINESS
AND HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- IN
JUST A BIT OF WE'RE GOING TO
TURN IT OVER AT NOW OF COURSE
IT TO MR CONROY AT PRESENT AT
THE WEST COAST FISHERIES
CONSULTANTS THE FOR ARE THREE
OR FIVE MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SIR
VICE CHAIR. AND TOM. THANKS
WITHIN A TWO INVITATION TO
PARTICIPATE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT MY NAME IS MIKE
CONROY I'M THE PRESIDENT WAS
BECAUSE FISHERIES SOLVENTS. WE
PROVIDE RIDE SERVICE COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL. CHARTER BOAT
FISHERMEN DIRECTLY OR- HER WERE
INVOLVED JUST ABOUT EVERY
FISHERY WHICH TAKE PLACE UP THE
CALIFORNIA COAST AND ON THE
HIGH SEAS. I CURRENTLY SAID ON
THE PACIFIC FISHERY MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL HIGHLY MIGRATORY
SPECIES VISOR PROPEL. SERVED ON
MANY THE FISHING GAME
COMMISSION'S WORK GROUP. I
THINK IN ORDER TO GET YOU HAVE
A GOOD IDEA UP. WHAT WE'RE- UP
FOR SOME REASON LET SLIDE. SHE
IS A SORRY ABOUT THIS. FOR SOME
REASON RUN. MY. TRY THE CLICKER
BY THE CLICKER. NEED TO CLEAN
MY. SORRY I'M I'M
TECHNOLOGICALLY NOT INTELLIGENT.
THERE. YEAH OKAY. IT'S OKAY
IT'S IT IT'S IT WE WAS DO
WITHOUT THE CARPORT THAT'S FINE
WE ALSO PUT IN THE WORK IN
DRIVE YOU CRAZY BECAUSE IT
WOULD DRIVE ME CRAZY THE DAM
POWER POINTS I APOLOGIZE IT'S
OKAY WHO I KNOW THAT TOM PUT
THIS UP ON THE WEBSITE SO IF
YOU WANT TO FOLLOW ALONG IT'S
NOT GONNA BE IMPERATIVE YEAH
BEFORE THE CLOSE OF ALL THAT SO.
BEFORE I MADE IT THE NEXT SLIDE
WOULD'VE BEEN REALLY NEED IT
WOULD HAVE TOLD YOU HOW WE GOT
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY BUT IT
HIGHLIGHTED THAT. FIND THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S A DEFINITE
DIFFERENCE IN HOW WE'RE-
APPROACHING OFFSHORE WIND
SENSE. THE PRE AND POST.
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
MOST FISHING INTERESTS WERE
CAUGHT OFF GUARD WHEN THE LEASE
APPLICATION TO BOMB IN EARLY
TWENTY SIXTEEN APPEARED FOR
AREAS OFTEN FEDERAL WATERS OF
SIDE MORE OBEY. WHILE THE
APPLICANT DID ENGAGE LOCAL
FISHERMEN OTHERS WITH WITH
HISTORIC DEPENDENCE ON THE
AREAS THAT WERE NOT ENGAGED FOR
EXAMPLE PARTICIPANTS IN THE
ALBACORE FISHERY. SIMILARLY
IMPORTANT STATE FISHERIES WHICH
WOULD BE IMPACTED HAVE NOT BEEN
ENGAGED SQUID FOR INSTANCE. WE
LEARNED OF THE HUMBLE CALL AREA
IN LATE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
EXPERIENCED A SIMILAR
WIDESPREAD LACK OF ENGAGEMENT.
POST TWENTY SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS IS NOT JUST A
CALIFORNIA ISSUE. LAST
SEPTEMBER BOM OREGON TASK FORCE
MEETING MADE IT CLEAR FISHERMEN
HAVE NOT FISHMAN DEPENDENT ON
THE GROUNDS OF OREGON HAVE NOT
BEEN ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS. IN
ORDER TO BENEFIT FROM THE
RESPONSIBLE OFFSHORE
DEVELOPMENT ALLIANCES
EXPERIENCES ON THE EAST COAST
WEST COAST FISHERMEN ANOTHER
ISSUE GROUPS HAVE JOINED ON TO
RHODA. WE ASK ROTOR TO
ESTABLISH A COMMITTEE DEDICATED
TO WEST COAST ISSUES AND THEY
HAVE DONE SO. LAST MAY ROAD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ANY HAWKINS
CAME AND SPOKE TO DURING
HEARING IN EUREKA. ROAD IS AIMS
TO COORDINATE SCIENCE AND
POLICY INITIATIVES TO MINIMIZE
CONFLICTS BETWEEN TRADITIONAL
AND HISTORICAL FISHING IN OTHER
PROPOSED USES ON THE OUTER
CONTINENTAL SHELF. THANKS TO
TOM FOR INCLUDING MATERIALS
REGARDING ROAD ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR THIS
MEETING AS WELL. TO DATE ROAD A
PACIFIC HAS MEMBERS RANGING
FROM SAN DIEGO ALL THE WAY TO
ALASKA. WITH REPRESENTATIVES
FROM MOST TO NOT ALL FISHERIES
THAT OPERATE WITHIN THAT AREA.
QUESTION THAT WAS OUT THERE IS
THAT I'M HERE TO ADDRESS CAN
FISHERIES AN OFFSHORE
RENEWABLES CO EXIST. SOME
STATUTES WILL REQUIRE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RENEWABLE
ENERGIES WE KNOW THIS WILD WE
WOULD PREFER A LAND BASED
RENEWABLES THAT ALONE MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH. WE CANNOT SUPPORT OR
DECISIONS MADE WITHOUT OUR
INPUTS THAT WILL HAVE PROFOUND
IMPACTS ON OUR LIVELIHOODS AND
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE A
HEALTHY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE SOURCE OF PROTEIN
TO CALIFORNIANS AND TO OUR
NATION. HAS BEEN MADE CLEAR
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS AND
WEEKS OUR NATIONAL FOOD
SECURITY IS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR
MUST BE CONSIDERED. TO THE
EXTENT THAT WHEN BASS OPTIONS
PREVENT SUFFICIENT. OPTION
AREAS WHICH WOULD HAVE NO
IMPACT ON FISHERIES WOULD BE
PREFERRED. IN ORDER TO HELP GET
TO THE POINT WERE WE GET FROM.
TO GETTING FISHERMEN SUPPORT
FOR OFFSHORE NOBLES WE DO HAVE
SOME SUGGESTIONS AND SOME
HIGHLY AND I LIGHT SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS. INCLUSION AND
TRANSPARENCY. IF YOU ARE AT THE
TABLE YOUR ON THE MENU. THE
RAPID PACE OF OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT IN FAVOR TO ENGAGE
ALL FISHING INTERESTING
COMMUNITIES. A RESULTING IN
DISHES SINCE WAS SERIOUS
IMPASSE OR SUSTAINABLE
FISHERIES IMPACTS WHICH COULD
HAVE BEEN MINIMIZED HAVE EVEN
ENGAGE EARLY IN THE PROCESS AND
PARTICIPATED IN CITING
pCONVERSATIONS. TRUST AND
PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED DIFFICULTIES
GETTING INFORMATION FROM BOWMAN
IMITATIONS TO DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
OFFSHORE WIND DURING MONDAY'S
BOMB CALIFORNIA WEAPON ARE WE
LEARNED OF A WORKING GROUP THAT
WAS FORMED BY CONGRESSMAN
CARVAJAL THIS WORKING GROUP
INCLUDES REPRESENTED SOME
CONGRESS AND PUT THAT IS OFFICE
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE BEAR
OF A MANAGE MANAGEMENT. NO WAS
THREE OFFICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NO FISHING INTERESTS
WERE INCLUDED AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY AT LEAST FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE NATIONALLY
FISHERIES SERVICE IS NOT
INCLUDED SOUTH WAS FISHERIES
SCIENCE CENTERS ON INCLUDED
PACIFIC FISHERY MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL ARE NOT INCLUDED. NEXT
THING TO LOOK OUT BIG
COMMUNICATION HONESTY WE
CONTINUE TO NOTE THE LACK OF
INCORRECT INFORMATION ABOUT
OFFER. DEVELOPMENT PLANS IN THE
FACT THAT THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE ON FISHERIES AND CONDITION
OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS INCLUDING
PROTECTED SPECIES AND OTHER
SPECIES OF CONCERN. TO BE CLEAR
IN MANY WAYS OFFICER WIND
ENERGY DEVELOPMENT AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMERCIAL FISHING
ARE DIRECTLY CONFLICTING
ACTIVITIES. COMMUNITY WHERE
IT'S NOT REACHING NEEDS TO BE
APPROVED AN UNDERSTANDING. OUT
REACHED A FISHING INTERESTS
OUTSIDE OF CITING REAS IS BEEN
NONEXISTENT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PERMITTED COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN AND COME CHARTER BOAT
VESSEL OPERATORS ARE UNAWARE OF
THE DETAILS OF THE GUARD OFFER
WENT OFF THE CALIFORNIA COAST
WE MUST AND STRIVE TO DO
BETTER. THERE ARE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS TO THE SOUTH LE'S JUST
FISHERIES SCIENCE CENTER LONG
RUNNING SERVICE WHICH CONDUCTED
IN THIS CALL AREAS HE'S CALL
THESE SURVEYS AND FOR STOCK
ASSISTANCE FOR COMMERCIALLY AND
RECREATIONALLY IMPORTANT STOCKS
AND FISHERIES IMPACT OF THESE
SURVEYS MUST BE ELIMINATED. WE
ARE UNAWARE OF ANY
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
AGENCIES IN THE SERVICE CENTER
ABOUT THIS OR ANY OTHER MATTERS.
WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE AND
MAXIMIZE BUT FOR WHEN. THE
FISHING INDUSTRY HAS AND WILL
BE THE PRIMARY LOSER IN THIS
PROCESS. DIRECT LOSSES OF
ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES AND
REVENUES. INDIRECT LOSSES AS
WELL WATERFRONT SPACE AND PORTS
AND HARBORS. IMPACTS OF
ELECTRIC CABLES ON FISH OF
ATTACKS AND MIGRATION
CORRIDORS. NAVIGATIONAL THAT
DANGERS OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPERS HAVE NOTICED ARGUES
OF THESE WATERS WILL SURELY BE
THOUGHT OF AS THE WINNERS.
ABOUT ONE IN. PROMOTING WIN WIN
SCENARIOS WOULD SEEM TO REQUIRE
PARADIGM SHIFT READ. REGARDING
HOW FISHERY INTERESTS ARE
TREATED. WITH REGARD TO
MITIGATION MEMBERS WE ARE ONLY
LIMITED BY THE BY THE- AMOUNT
OF OUR CREATIVITY. SO OUR APPS
SPECIFICALLY BE WOULD BE. TO
THE EXTENT YOU CAN INFLUENCE
BOWMAN AND THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. SURFICIAL BECAUSE-
THE ARE THE CAL. COMMISSION
FORCE. THIS IS OUR BIGGEST PROP
DE AND THE BEST DIFFICULT FOR
AVAILABLE WE'VE HEARD REPEATED
THROUGHOUT TODAY THAT DATA AND
SCIENCE MATTER. USE OURS IN
THIS AS WELL SECOND BE ENSURE A
FULLY TRANSPARENT AND INCLUSIVE
PROCESS IS REQUIRED FOR ANY
PROJECTS PROPONENT IN STATE
WATERS. WE NOTE THAT STATE
LANDS COMMISSION LAST SEPTEMBER.
WAS DANGLING ITS TOLL IN THE
OFFSHORE WIND WORLD BY
PROPOSING A- THE WIND FARM. OFF
OF HALAMA WHICH IS BETWEEN THAT
ARE WELL AND POINT CONCEPTION
IT WAS QUICKLY WITHDRAWN WHEN I
THINK JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY WAS
CAUGHT OFF GUARD NO ONE KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS UNTIL THE-
MEETING SO AND IF YOU CAN DO TO
FOSTER COMMUNICATIONS AWARENESS
BE GREATLY APPRECIATED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR LOOK
I I'M- THANK BOTTOM LINE FOR US
IN A FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO. THE
COMMISSIONER BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS SINCE
LAST YEAR AND HAVE BEEN IN THE
OFFICE MANY TIMES TWENTY. A
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU- AS WELL
AS- INDUSTRY OF COMING IN AND
HAVING CONVERSATIONS THANKS.
BOTTOM LINE PRICES THAT WE
NEEDED DO EXACTLY AGES OUT LIKE
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM. AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO OR
STATEWIDE APPROACH. MY CONCERN
I BELIEVE- I CAN SPEAK FOR THE
COMMISSION ON THIS IS. RATHER
GOING PORT BY PORT. AND DOING
THESE ONE OFTEN AGREEMENTS WE
GOTTA FIGURE OUT. WHAT WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AT. A CRISIS. RIGHT
AND THAT MEANS WE GET TO BRING
FORWARD ONE INITIAL THE- EVEN I
AM A BILL AND LIKE IF YOU FOR
ANYONE ELSE ON WHOSE HERE AT.
AND PANEL I'M A BOY THIS THE
ONLY VIABLE OPTION RIGHT NOW IS
GONNA BE THE NORTH COAST- WE
ARTICLE A STATEWIDE APPROACH
BECAUSE- I DON'T WANT ONE
FORGETTING SOMETHING ANOTHER
PORT NOT- AND IF FOR CPS ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD. ON MAKING THIS
A BIBLE RENEWABLE RESOURCE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
STATEWIDE POLICY. SO YOU HAVE
OUR COMMITMENT IN FACT WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO BRING FOR HIS
INFORMAL WORKING GROUP WITH THE
COMMISSIONER WITH INDUSTRY-
AND- HAVING A- CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS. INDIAN WHERE I'D
LIKE TO END UP IS. HOW MUCH
MONEY DO WE NEED. TO DO IS
STATEWIDE STUDY. THAT COULD THE
NEW BECOME JUST BEING VERY
CANDID ABOUT YOUR REQUEST THAT
INCORPORATES FISHERIES. INTO
THE STUDY RIGHT SO THAT'S WERE
WOULD LIKE TO BE A GO I'VE
TALKED TOO MUCH ON THIS ONE
I'LL TURN OF THE COMMISSION TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD IN- MISS MILLS AND
OF COURSE MR CONROY. BUT
COMMISSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I- IT I HAVE A FEW THINGS I'D
LIKE TO ADD I WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT IT I FULLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THE OUT REACH
ENGAGEMENT OF THE FISHING
COMMUNITY IS CRITICAL- I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT. IN THE TIME
LEAD TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF ALL
AREAS. THE STATE YOU KNOW THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CALL AREAS
LEASING IN FEDERAL WATERS
THAT'S A FEDERAL PROCESS THE
STATE. MADE A DECISION TO
ENGAGE VERY PROACTIVELY WITH
PALM AND LEVERAGE THEIR PUBLIC
PROCESS AND SO. AT OUR REQUEST
BONE DID A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
OUT REACH BEYOND TO THEIR USUAL
TASK FORCE PROCESS AYE AYE
INCLUDED IN THE PACKAGE THAT
THE COMMITTEE RECEIVED ARE OUT
OF REACH SUMMARY SO. WE DID
EIGHTEEN MEETINGS AND BRIEFINGS
WITH FISHERMEN AND IN THE
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PERIOD THAT THAT SAID. IT'S
REALLY NOT EASY AND THE FACT
THAT WE GO OUT AND WE DO A
MEETING AT YOU KNOW. PORT ST
LOUIS ST LOUIS HARBOR DISTRICT
OR OR SANTA BARBARA OR KIND OF
PORT BY PORT WENT TO CRESCENT
CITY YOU KNOW PARTICIPATED
MYSELF IN A MEETING AND- BULL
WITH A- FISHERMAN. IT WAS
STANDING ROOM ALL. IT WAS GREAT
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT LET'S NOT THE
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
APPROACH WHERE WE REALLY HAVE
THE RESOURCES AND TIME TO ROLL
UP OUR SLEEVES AND IT CAN BE
HIT AND MISS BECAUSE WE CAN
SHOW UP AND HALF THE PEOPLE WE
WANT TO TALK TO ARE OUT ON THE
BOATS AND SO IT'S CHALLENGING
IT IT'S HARD AND WE'RE
COMMITTED. TO DOING YOU KNOW
THE BEST WE CAN AND BEING
CREATIVE ABOUT IT AND
CONTINUING TO DO BETTER- I
WANTED TO JUST BRIEFLY. SAY I
AM AND YOU KNOW WE'RE VERY
COMMITTED TO BEST DATA AND
SCIENCE ANOTHER PROJECT TO THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL IS
HELPING FUND ON. IS IN THIS
CASE NOT SPECIFICALLY- FISHING
BUT THERE'S FISHING INVOLVED WE
ASKED THE BUREAU OF OCEAN
ENERGY MANAGEMENT TO CREATE A
DATA PORTAL WHERE. ALL THE DATA
THAT WE WILL RELY ON WILL EXIST
IN WILL BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
AND SO THAT PORTAL EXISTED
SCOTT OVER SIX HUNDRED DATA
SETS ON IT- PCS HELP FUND SOME
SCIENTISTS TO REALLY GO THROUGH
IN A PUBLIC WAY. AND THAT IN
ANALYZE THAT DATA. OF WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DATA IN THE CASE
OF FISHING WE THOUGHT WE NEEDED
AND A SUPPLEMENTAL APPROACH AND
THAT'S WHY THE OPC. WORK BOWL
AND SO. I REALIZE THAT'S NOT ON
THE CENTRAL COAST WERE VERY
OPEN TO A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE. AS WELL ON
THE- POST. HEY YOU KNOW. ONE OF
THE WE'VE LIKE IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR THE STATE TO GET VERY
ENGAGED IS THAT THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC PROCESS THESE ARE NOT AS-
AS OPEN AS WE IN CALIFORNIA ONE
EXPECT AND AS WE THE STATE ONE
EXPECTED THAT'S NOT THE FAULT
OF THE PEOPLE OF YOUR OF OCEAN
ENERGY MANAGEMENT IS THE WAY
THE PROCESS WORKS SO FOR
EXAMPLE TO BE A MEMBER OF THIS
TASK FORCE YOU HAVE TO BE
REPRESENTING A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY. AND IN FACT THE TASK
FORCE DOESN'T EVEN TAKE FORMAL
PUBLIC COMMENT THEY HAVE TO
ADJOURN THE MEETING AND THEN
THE PUBLIC GETS TO SPEAK AND SO
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE TO. OPEN ACROSS THE
U. WITH ON THIS COOPERATION AND
SUPPORT. IS TO PROVIDE A STATE
DOCKET FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS TO
BE SUBMITTED. AND TO SUBMIT
THOSE COMMENTS TO BOMB ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC SO WE ARE
WE REALLY WANT THIS TO BE
COLLABORATIVE AND YOUR IDEA.
SENATOR OF THE STATE WIDE LOOK
AND- I THINK IS THE WAY TO GO I
THINK IT'S REALLY GOOD NO I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMISSIONER IN
AND LOOK AND AGAIN I GOT A- PUT
PRAISE WERE BRACES DO AND IT'S
ON THE COMMISSION SHE'S BEEN.
ALL OVER THIS ISSUE- IN NEW
MORE THAN WILLING TO BE AN
INCLUDE- AND IN THE FISHING
COMMUNITY I THINK THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE. IT IS. NUMBER WE
GOT A- CATCH GOING ON RIGHT NOW
RIGHT ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
IN IN ACROSS THE WEST COAST AS
WELL WE GOT A- GET RID OF THAT.
AND WE GOT TO FORMALIZE THE
PROCESS TO INVOLVE THE FLEET.
SO ICE WHERE AGAIN I DON'T EVER
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE MEASURE
BUT I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE SAME
GOAL WE DEVELOP A FORMAL
PROCESS. THAT FORMAL PROCESS
WOULD BE FUNDED. IT WOULD BE AN
INITIAL STUDY STATEWIDE- WITH
FIVE TO TEN GOALS THAT WOULD BE
EMBEDDED WITHIN THAT STUDY THAT
WOULD BE AN INITIAL REVIEW. AND
WHO WERE GONNA OFFICIALLY
ENGAGE WITH BEING VERY GENERIC
RIGHT NOW BUT YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO COOK THIS BUT BEFORE WE
CC IT WILL BE IN A BRING-
SMALL GROUP TOGETHER TO BE ABLE
TO GET SOME IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY
WERE IN LINE AT THE FLEET IN
THAT ROOM AND THEN WHAT I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO DO. WE
GOT A GOAL GET THE DOLLARS TO
FUND. SO THAT'S WHEN I'M JUST
VERY VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
WORKING WITH THE COMMISSION ON
THIS. AND STEPPING UP- MISS
MILLS- QUICKLY ANY COMMENTS- IN
YOU'VE BEEN SUPER ENGAGED IN
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU AS
WELL. AND THEN MISTER CURRY
LIVE LAST WORD SPELLS. NO I
REALLY APPRECIATE COMMISSIONER
DOUGLAS'S WORK ON ALL THIS TO
AN AS WELL AS YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS I THINK- THE ONE THING
JUST BE CAREFUL OF AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IS. MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT PRESUMING CONFLICT
AND IMPACTS BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
DO THE WORK AND DO THE SCIENCE
AND GET THE DATA- BECAUSE I
THINK YOU KNOW. I DO I WANT TO
AVOID A SITUATION WHERE WE LIKE
THEIR WINDOWS AND LOSERS WE-
NEED TO. MAKE THIS WORK WE BOTH
NEED WE NEED THIS CLEAN
RENEWABLE ENERGY WE NEED YOU
KNOW GOOD A HIGH LEVEL. YOU'LL
FISHING STOCKS AND WE NEED TO
FIND A PATH FORWARD SO IT'S-
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN AND WHAT.
COMING TO WORK NO I AGAIN- NO
BE ESTAS BILLS IS BEEN EDITING
TABLE AND WANTING TO BE A
PARTICIPATE ON THIS AND DO THE
RIGHT THING I WILL SAY- AND
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION.
BEING CANDID UP THERE HAVE BEEN
MISTAKES IN THE PAST. AND LET'S
LEARN FROM MISTAKES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN OTHER AREAS WHETHER
IT'S IN THE UNITED STATES OR-
OVERSEAS. AND HOW WE CAN ENGAGE
EARLY AND OFTEN. THE MORE WORK
WE DO ON THE FRONT IN. WHEN I
WRITE A MINISTRY IS OFF. AND I.
EXPRESSED TO THINK THAT WILL
SHE CAUSES CANCER WE WILL THEN
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD ON.
RENEWAL ENERGY SO. THAT AIM WE
NEED TO LEARN FROM. MISTAKES
AND THAT SUPPOSE IN THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ANY THIS VOID RIGHT
AND I THINK THAT'S BEST. FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT. BEST FOR THE
FLEET. INVEST AT FOR INDUSTRIES
WELL BUT AGAIN THIS BILLS EVEN
DIVERSE WORK WITH MISS CONNELLY
HAVE LESS WORK. THANK YOU AND
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS ITEM INCLUDED AT THE AT
THE FISHERIES FORM AND I PRETTY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMISSIONERS WORDS. AND
MISSILES AS WELL. YEAH I FULLY
SUPPORT AN IDEA RELOOK AT.
SINCE THE STATE HOLISTICALLY IN
TERMS OF FISHING ACTIVITY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS REALLY
CONCERNING ABOUT THE AREA OFF
MORE OBEY AND OUTLOOK CANYON
WAS. IT DID THEN IF. TRIED IT
HAD JUST LOOKED AT THE DATA
THAT CAME OUT OF THERE THEY
WOULD HAVE SEEN THAT THIS THIS
WAS AN IMPORTANT HAVE A CORE
AREA. AND HAD THE DONE FURTHER
RESEARCH THEY WOULD REALIZE
THAT THE ALBACORE FISHERMEN ARE
NOT ALL FROM THAT AREA NOW
OFFER MORE AVAILABLE. A PAST
MAJORITY OF MEN FACTOR FROM SAN
GO. SO IT'S ONE THING TO GO
INTO MORE OF A AND THEN TO
AVALON. AND GET THE OKAY FROM
THEM BECAUSE YOU KNOW. YOU'VE
DONE WHATEVER YOU CAN TO GIVE
THEM COMFORT. IT'S WHEN YOU YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE STATE AS A
WHOLE YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
FISHERIES AS A WHOLE WHO
PARTICIPATES. IN ALL THOSE AS
WELL SO IT AT I'M ENCOURAGED
VERY MUCH BY WHAT I'VE HEARD
THUS FAR TODAY. IS CAN WE THINK
YOU AT WORK IN THE PHONE UP
WITH YOU ON THIS ISSUE-
MEDICATION- THANK YOU MISS
MILLS. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE IN FOR HANGING
WITH US TODAY AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU. FOR TO COME.
ALL RIGHT. ISN'T CHEN WE ARE IN
THE HOME STRETCH WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU- FOR THE PATIENTS. AT
THE VICE CHAIR DOES BY SURELY
TO. DREDGE THAT. ALL RIGHT. HEY
THERE YOU GO IS MAKING. GIVEN
THE BLOOD FLOWING. ALL RIGHT.
HEY THERE YOU GO. WE ARE- GIVE
ME BRINGING UP OUR FINAL PANEL
IN AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US TODAY. THIS IS
WHERE. WE HEAR FROM EACH OF THE
FISHERIES SIR COMMITTEE
REPORTS. ON WE HAVE THAT PAGE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I DON'T BUT
YOU THE NAME RUBY. DID I BUT
YOU'RE IT PAGE. OKAY I FEEL
FREE TO CORRECT ME WHAT YEAH
GIVE US THE CORRECT
PRONUNCIATION. BEAR RUBY I
BUTCHERED IT IN YOUR TO KIND
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU OUT
WE ARE GOING THAT ALSO HEAR
FROM DAVID GOLDENBERG DIG AT AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THIS YEAR
CAN COMMISSION ON PAGES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DENNIS CRAP TASK FORCE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I'M WE HAVE A AN
AWARD WINNER HERE TODAY- AND
THAT'S AT THE V. IN HELLO WELL.
SHE'S NEVER THE CALIFORNIA
ADVISORY COMMITTEE O SALMON
STEELHEAD TROUT I AND WE
RECOGNIZE HER AT LAST NIGHT FOR
HER INCREDIBLE WORK ON BEHALF
OF THE FLEET THE ENVIRONMENT IN
FISHERIES ACROSS THE STATE
LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FELICE SO. IN I GET TO YOU SHE
WORKS IN THAT'S WHAT- HER
COLLEAGUES IN HER PEERS SAY AND
SHE LITERALLY WAS FILMING THE
WORKING IN FILM THE ENTIRE OF
IT LAST NIGHT. JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU- AND WE REALLY REALLY
ARE SO HAPPY THAT YOU'RE HERE.
AND THEN WE NEED TO SEE A LIST
WHITE AND LET'S COME ON DOWN-
SHE'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
OCEAN SCIENCE TRUST ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
PAGE PAGE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES IN WILL
GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE FROM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING IN
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON PAGE BEAR BE WITH THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THIS UPDATE ON BEHALF
OF THAT AND SHE DESCRIBED TASK
FORCE. FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF
SB THIRTEEN TEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN OPC WORKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. TO ADVANCE THE
CTF COMMERCIAL FISHING
ELECTIONS FOR HALF OF THE
COURTS AS WELL AS TO APPOINT.
AND COMMERCIAL FISHING FLEETS.
ELECTIONS AND THE OTHER HALF OF
THE PORTS ARE UNDER WAY AND ARE
SLATED TO BE COMPLETED BY
SUMMER. TWENTY TWENTY. THE TO
HAVE MET IN OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AND FORTY TO REPORT
WAS SEVEN RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS OTHER
AGENCIES. IN DECEMBER. THE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED A
REQUEST FOR A DETAILED AUDIT OF
THE DENTIST CRAP ACCOUNT. AND
REQUESTED THAT THE STATE
PRIORITIZE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR. FROM THE DENTIST CRAP
ACCOUNT TO SUPPORT THE DISEASE
YEAH. WE HEARD FROM DIRECTOR
BOND AND THIS MORNING HIS
COMMITMENT ON BEHALF OF CDF W.
TO IMPLEMENT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THIRTY CITY
HAVE ALSO PROVIDED GUIDANCE TO
CITY OF W. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THE OFFICE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT. ON HELPING BIOTOXIN
MANAGEMENT ZONES TO CREATE MORE
PREDICTABILITY FOR SEASON
OPENERS IN THE FACE OF TO MY-
SAID. THE DISEASE YOU HAVE ALSO
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR CITY OF
WCT PH AND A WE HOP PURSUING
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT
EVISCERATION OPTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH APPROPRIATE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SEES. THAT
HE SAID HE THE CITY OF SUPPORTS
THE EFFORTS OF THE DENTURE
DESCRIBE FISHING YOU'RE WORKING
GROUP. AND THE TASK FORCE
REQUESTED TO CHANGE THE PRE
SOAK TIME IN THE AREA SOUTH OF
MENDOCINO SNOW CAPPED SO NO MY
COUNTY LINE TO BE CONSISTENT
STATEWIDE. AND THERE IS A
PARALLEL RECOMMENDATION TO
MODIFY THE SPORT PRE SOAK
THROUGH THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION PROCESS. LASTLY THE
TASK FORCE SUPPORTED THE TRI
STATE TO DESCRIBE COMMITTEES
SUGGESTION TO MODIFY THE
PRESEASON CRAB CALL STANDARDS.
IN MY ROLE WITH THE I'M UNABLE
TO TAKE A POSITION AND
LEGISLATOR HOWEVER I WANTED TO
MEN AND- THAT THE DECEMBER
TWENTY NINE THE REPORTING. MORE
INFOR AN INCLUDING THE CAST
BACK. ON EIGHT BEFORE SEVEN.
TWO FROM TWENTY NINE IN.
LOOKING AHEAD THE CITY OF
MEMBERS FROM OTHERS CAN.
IDENTIFY PRIOR IS IN THE SHORT
AND LONG TERM LAW TERM WHICH
INCLUDE BILL ON SOME OF THESE
ARE. SUCH AS TOXIN MANAGEMENT
ZONES IT IS SERRATION ORDERS
AND OTHERS LISTED IN THEIR WORK
PLAN. WE ANTICIPATE CONVENING
THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE IN
APRIL TO CONTINUE MOVING THESE
FORWARD ON THESE TOPICS. IN
CLOSING ON BEHALF OF THE DC TF
IN DC CHECK ADMIN TEAM. THANK
YOU SENATOR REQUIRE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE IN THE FULL
COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR POSITIVE
RECEIPT OF THE REPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AGAIN
TO PROVIDE THIS UPDATE ON
BEHALF OF THE D. C. T. H. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FOR BEING HERE
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE BECAUSE AT I
TOTALLY BUT YOU DO NAY. YOU'RE
VERY KIND SO THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH- IN IT MEANS A LOT
AND I THINK YOU BRING WITH US
I'M SORRY THAT WE GOT SUCH A
LATE START AS WELL TODAY. WE'RE
NOT GOING TURN OVER DAVID
GOLDENBERG THE EXECUTOR AFTER
THE CONFERENCE YOUR CHIN
COMMISSION SIR IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
TO SEE YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING
IN TODAY THE FLOOR IS YOURS
FIVE MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU
WOMEN A PROBLEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SHE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON. GERMAN MCGUIRE
AND- VICE CHAIR STONE. AND
MISTER WAS SLOW- I GIVE YOU THE
MISTER THIS TIME- BEFORE I GET
STARTED I WANTED TO JUST
ADDRESS MRS TO US. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONES- REQUEST THIS FOR
THE NEW SHOOTERS. I REALLY TRY
TO GET THEM TO COME LAST NIGHT
BUT- I WILL EXPLAIN WHY DO WE
HAVE A DEFICIT IN THE STATE AND
THEN WE DO HAVE- MANY DOWN
SOUTH BUT THEY HAD A LOT OF BAD
WEATHER. AND OUR DRIVERS ARE
NOT ALLOWED OR THEY COULDN'T-
GO OUT IN GOOD FAITH- TO GET
SOME MONEY BECAUSE OF BAD
WEATHER. I APPRECIATE THAT I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO THEM THERE BUT
I THINK THAT. THE AVAILABILITY
OR LACK OF AVAILABILITY FOR
WHATEVER REASON. WE ALWAYS NEED
TO BE MINDFUL OF WHAT WE HAVE
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE AND NOT TAKE
ANY OF IT FOR GRANTED THAT WAS
MY POINT BUT- YES UNDERSTOOD
I'VE BEEN WAITING OVER TIME TO.
REPLY TO. I AM I JUST WANNA
GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COMMISSION AS WE ARE A STATE
MARKETING PROGRAM UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE WE WERE
ESTABLISHED BY AN ACT OF THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE ARE ABOUT
THERE'S ABOUT FIFTY DIFFERENT
COMMODITY MARKING GROUPS THAT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE BUT WE
HAVE A CO OVERSIGHT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AS WELL. OUR STATE AGENCY AND-
FOLLOW THE OPEN. MEETING RULES
THAT THAT OTHER STATE AGENCIES
FOLLOW. EXCEPT THAT THIS IS A
VERY SMALL GROUP BUT THE
FISHERMEN OTHER DIVERS. HAVE TO
PAY THE MANDATORY SUSSMAN AND
EVERY FIVE YEARS WE COME UP FOR
A RENEWAL. WHETHER THE
INITIALLY WANTS TO ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE AND TO WORK ON THEIR
BEHALF SO WE CAN GET WE- WE DO
MARKETING PROMOTION. AND A
LITTLE BIT OF REGULATORY
AFFAIRS AND SO. I JUST LIKE TO
JUST GIVE A LITTLE PLUG AS TO
WHAT WE ARE- THE SEARCH
INDUSTRY IS NOW- STRANGER TO
HAVING. AND SOME BAD TIMES AND
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
SOME REALLY LONG BAD TIMES I
WILL. GET INTO A WITH MY
PRESENTATION. WE HAVE A FEW
LOOK AT THE OVERALL HISPID
LASTS AS A TEN YEARS OF OUR
FISHERY. I'M IT'S BEEN PRETTY
STEADY TO ABOUT TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHEN THE WAR MORE BLOOD. CAME
CAME AROUND AND STARTED TO KILL
OFF THE KELP AND IT WAS
ADDRESSED BY A NUMBER OF OTHER
SPEAKERS I WON'T GO INTO THAT.
BUT YOU CAN START SEEING THAT
AROUND TWO FIFTEEN. THAT THERE
WAS A STARTING TO SEE IT A
DOWNTURN. AND IN THAT I STARTED
TO REALLY- SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL MORE SO IN THE NORTH
AND THEN IN THE SOUTH AND SO WE
DID APPLY. FOR DISASTER
DECLARATION WE DID GET IT- LATE
LAST YEAR AND THEN WE DID OF
GET ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE ARE-
WE WERE PROOF THREE POINT THREE
MILLION. BUT I'D LIKE TO SHOW
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE THAT
PICTURE OF WHAT A NORMAL OCEAN
BOTTOM PLATE WITH BREADS WE
HOPE IS RED. GINS BUT ON THIS
BEEN ABOUT. PURPLE THEY'RE JUST
UP THANK YOU TO THE FLOOR. A
FOREIGN REASONS THE STARFISH-
HAS. DIED OFF BECAUSE THE WARM
WATER AND JUST ALLOW THE
PROPOSED TO EXPLODE. AND THEY
ARE ALL THE URGENCY JUST EMPTY
SHELVES THAT THERE'S NO ROLE IN
AND SAYS THERE'S NOTHING MUCH
TO PICK. BUT WHEN YOU COMBINE
AND ALSO THE DISASTROUS. BASED
ON VALUE OF HOW THAT YEAR A
COMPARISON PASSED A PREVIOUS
FIVE YEARS- THE KIND OF GETS
MASS BUT I WANTED TO SHOW YOU
THE POUNDAGE AND THAT GETS LOST
BECAUSE- AS- AS WE- PUNISH.
BEGINS A DECREASE VALUE PER
POUND STARTS TO INCREASE AND SO
IT KIND OF GETS MASS BUT- IF
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
POUNDAGE. YOU SEE- IN THE NORTH
DOWN TO FIFTY SIX ALMOST FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND POUNDS CMPARED
TO WHERE THEY WORK IN OVER
THREE MILLION. JUST VERY
DRAMATIC AND WE SEEN SOMEONE OF
A CHANGES IN THE SOUTH AS WELL.
SO IT IS VERY DRAMATIC AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF- DIVERS. THAT
HAVE- JUST LEFT THE FISHERY WE
HAVE ABOUT- THREE HUNDRED
DIVERSE WE'RE DOWN TO ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED SOON BUT TWO
SEVENTY RIGHT NOW. AND ABOUT
THE FIFTY TO SEVENTY THAT ARE
REALLY JUST ACTIVE AND IN
KEEPING WITH THE IN THE NORTH.
I UNDERSTAND ABOUT TWO OR THREE
DIVER THAT ARE REALLY.
ACTIVELY DIVING THESE DAYS IT'S
JUST NOT MUCH THERE. AS I
MENTIONED- WITH YOUR ASSISTANCE
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP- CENTER HE
HELPED US GET THE- THE GOVERNOR
DECLARATION- REQUEST TO THE
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE- BACK IN-
AND FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR. THE
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE APPROVED
THE DISASTER REQUEST IN OCTOBER
OF THIS YEAR AS YOU'D OF LAST
YEAR. AND WE JUST FOUND OUT A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO THE THREE
POINT THREE MILLION WAS-
ALLOCATED. SO BUT- THAT WAS
420-162-2017 TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO BEEN
DECIMATED AS YOU SAW IN THE
PREVIOUS SLIDE. AND WE'RE GONNA
BE ASKING YOUR HELP TO JUST
KIND OF PUSHED THINGS ALONG
WITH- WITH A REQUEST TO THE
GOVERNOR. OBVIOUSLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BECAUSE HANDS FULL
WITH OTHER DISASTERS THAT ARE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND WE FULLY
APPRECIATE OF THAT THAT THIS IS
GOING MANY. ON TOP OF THIS BOOK.
DO HAVE THE FISH IN THE THAT
THAT IS FREE AND HAPPY SO. FOR
QUITE A LONG TIME. AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED AND I WAS WITH A
FRIEND AT THE TIME JUST THAT
AND THEN- SPREAD SHEET THAT YOU
PROVIDED YES IN THE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN BOTH ON- TOTAL
TURN- POUNDS. AND DOLLAR VALUE.
JUST STAGGERING YES ARE YOU
SEEN THE DECREASE I A AGAIN
THANK YOU SO SPECIAL IN THE
NORTH JUST UNBELIEVABLE A
PEOPLE HAVING A VERY VERY HARD
TIME ONLY GOSH. YEAH SO TO HELP
WITH THIS THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER
OF PROJECTS THAT HAVE- LOOKED
AT A KELP RESTORATION BECAUSE
THE KELP DIED OFF AND SPOKE.
MORE SO IN IN YOUR DISTRICT
ALONG THE ON IN MINUTES IN
CANYON CINEMA COUNTY. I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK OF THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO ALLOCATING ABOUT
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS. WITH
THE- AN ABUNDANCE OF MONEY FROM
CALLS COME FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND ALSO THE
WATERMAN'S ALLIANCE THEY
THEY'RE PUTTING IN MONEY AS
WELL. SO A TO THE TOTAL OF
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND. WE ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THAT THAT THAT
EFFORTS GOING ON HOWEVER MORE
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE. I'M
HOPING THAT WITH THE ALLOCATION
OF THE THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS WE CAN. GIVE
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO. THE
FISHERMEN AND ALSO THE
COMMERCIAL BUYERS. BUT ALSO PUT
MONEY TOWARDS ON RESTORATION AS
WELL AND ENHANCE THESE
PROJECTS. ABOUT ONE MINUTE ONE
MINUTE LEFT ALMOST AT THE VERY
AND- AS FAR AS HELP- IN THE
FUTURE. THERE ARE TWO BILLS
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH OR AT
LEAST HAVE BEEN ENTERED- IS ONE
IS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN.
I UNDERSTAND THIS MIGHT BE A
SPOT BILL BUT JUST IN CASE THIS
IS TO TAKE- THE- THE DIVING
LICENSE PERMIT. AND MOVE IT OUT
OF THE STATE- EFFORTS. WHERE
YOU'RE CONTROLLING THE FUHRMAN
PERMIT FEES. AND MOVED OVER TO
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION.
THAT'S TRUE- WE WOULD LIKE TO
BECOME MALLS AND HAVE THE
DIALOGUE AND JUST. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN HELPING US
MAINTAIN THAT RELATIONSHIP UP
THAT WOULD BE CAN BE HEARD. NOT
SAY IT IS. TERRIBLY WRONG BUT
IT'S- I. PULL THAT OUT.
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN. A
LICENSES. AND THE AB THIRD THE
RATE CUT. PHILIP TENS AND I SAY
THAT IS AN OLD EFFORT. IN NOBLE
GOAL. BUT TO PROTECT 30% OF THE
CONS. BY A TWENTY THREE BUT THE
FISH INDUSTRY YOU KNOW ALREADY
SERVICE BY HAVING SEASONS WE
HAVE SIZE LIMITS AND AN H.
WHEELS OF THE MPAS OF INPUT AND
THAT'S ALSO COMPACTED ARE ARE
AT LEAST THE DIVERS- INTO
SMALLER SMALLER AREAS AND ASK
THE TAKE ON MORE OF A BURDEN
MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT WE WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR- HELP. AND
GUIDANCE AND MAKING SURE THAT
OUR- OUR WORDS ARE HEARD WE
LOOK FOR THE WORKING SIR THANK
YOU AND THEN I THINK I'M DONE
THIS IS WHAT WE REALLY STRIVE
FOR- AND THAT HOPEFULLY WILL
GET BACK TO THAT. IF YOU DON'T
WANNA TOUCH OF ABOUT THIRTY
SEVEN TO FIFTEEN SECONDS A
DIRECTOR BONTA MENTIONED THAT
THE- I'M IN A DISASTER I WAS
JUST A PLAGUE THEN I'D LIKE TO
GIVE A SHOUT TO KNOW OPPENHEIM
AND ROB ROSS WHO HAVE BEEN ON
THE PANEL WE WORK TOGETHER I
ALSO MANAGE THE- FORTY SEVEN
COUNCIL. IT'S BEEN A VERY ROUGH
ROAD- THIS LOTS OF DIVERGENT
ISSUE- CONSIDER IS IT WAS A
FISHERMAN COMMERCIAL BUYERS THE
PARTIAL- FISHING PASS DIVEST
OPERATORS ALSO IN AND- EVER
FISH GUIDES AND SO. CAN IN THEM
ALL TO FIGURE OUT- AND WHAT
THEY'RE WILLING TO. DEVELOP WAS
OF STRUGGLE. WE WILL PASS. OF
THE OTHER APARTMENT IN OVER. A
ONE TO GIVE AT THAT TO THE
OTHER PARTNERS FOR HELPING US.
PUSH THROUGH NO REAL FISHY TO
THINK SO MUCH MISTER BY SHARED
A LOOK AT THAT. AFTER AND IT'S
LIKE. I KNOW AT. THE TENNIS HEY
THE NEXT YEAR. HER HIGH. AREA
ALL RIGHT EIGHT THINK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE NOT GOING TO THE
FLOOR. TO I WAS HELLO WELL IS A-
THE CAL. IN COMMITTEE ON SCENE.
IN STILL HAD TO THE FLOORS. YET
ONE MINUTE YOU'RE FIVE ON THE
ONE MINUTE. WELCOME THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE ASSEMBLY MISS
DAWN AND TOM WAS SLOW. IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- A KNOWLEDGE
OF LAST NIGHT IT ENCOURAGING.
WHEN SOMETIMES YOU DON'T SEE
THE RESULT OF YOUR WORK IN THIS
FIELD WHEN YOU'RE PROTECTING
RESOURCES. I DON'T KNOW I SEE
THE RESULT. WELL. THIS I CAN'T
TELL YOU. I'M FILLING IN HERE
FOR TWO DURING MOREAU TO. WHO
HAD SOME ISSUE. AS A BUSY YEAR
FOR THE CAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FONDLY KNOWN AS THE SHE A SHE-
OUR MEETINGS THIS YEAR FOCUSED
ON CENTRAL VALLEY HATCHERY
MANAGEMENT. THE FISHERIES
RESTORATION GRANT PROGRAM PEER
REVIEW COMMITTEE THE
DEPARTMENT'S AD HOC RESTORATION
LEADERS COMMITTEE AND ONGOING
GRANT PROGRAM REFORM AND
OVERSIGHT. ALSO THE JOINT STATE
FEDERAL COASTAL MONITORING
PROGRAM OR CMP. AND SITES
RESERVOIR ITS IMPLICATIONS FOR
THE TRINITY RIVER DIVISION AND
THE NEED FOR SCIENCE BASED
MINIMUM BYPASS FLOWS IN THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER. AMONG
UPCOMING ISSUES ARE STOCKS IN
THE OCEAN OUR OCEANS SEVEN
FISHERIES ARE NOT IN A RECOVERY
TRAJECTORY. THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER SEVEN ABUNDANCE APPEARS
BETTER THAN OTHER RIVERS THE
KLAMATH IS STILL SUFFERING
GREATLY FROM C. SHASTA
INFECTION OF JUVENILE FISH
BELIEVED TO BE THE CAUSE OF
THIS YEAR'S POOR ABUNDANCE. WE
HAVE GOOD REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT DAM REMOVAL CURRENTLY
EXPECTED IN TWO YEARS WILL
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. OUR
PRELIMINARY EEL RIVER
MONITORING INDICATES ABOUT HALF
AS MANY FISH AS LAST YEAR WHICH
WERE ALREADY VERY LOW COMPARED
TO RECENT YEARS. AS A RESULT
COASTAL COMMUNITIES IN THE
NORTH WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE ECONOMIC DISTRESS
AND FISHERIES REMAINS SEVERELY
CURTAILED. IN THESE DOWN YEARS
WE LOOK TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAINTAIN AND BUILD ON FUNDING
TO INVEST IN WATERSHED IN
FISHERIES RESTORATION. AND WE
ALSO LOOK TO STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO REMAIN FLEXIBLE IN
MANAGEMENT HATCHERY OPERATIONS
AND TO SPEED UP THE PACE OF
RESTORATION PROGRAMS. FOR
EXAMPLE HATCHERY RELEASE
STRATEGIES AND RELEASE
LOCATIONS ARE CRITICAL. TO
BOOST HATCHERY FISH SURVIVAL
AND WE ENCOURAGE AGENCY
MANAGERS TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMERCIAL SPORT AND TROUBLE
SALMON REPRESENTATIVES TO
CONSIDER OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
ALSO WE NEED TO REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS TO REBUILD OUR FALL RUN
SALMON STOCKS IN AREAS IMPACTED
BY DROUGHT AND POUR WATER
MANAGEMENT. THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT SITES RESERVOIR. THE
DRAFT E. I. S. E. R. E. I. R.
HAS NUMEROUS DEFICIENCIES AND
THE SIZE PROJECT AT THIRTY HAS
RESISTED REQUEST TO
RECIRCULATE. THE DRAFT THE I.
S. P. I. R. FIRST THE MODELING
CALLED FOR MINIMUM BYPASS FLOWS
AS LOW AS THREE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY CFS AT RED BLUFF
WHEN. DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE HAS RECOMMENDED NO
LESS THAN THIRTEEN THOUSAND CFS.
OF THOSE LOW. FLOWS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO SEVEN RUNS.
SECONDLY THE MODELING SHOWS
IMPACTS TO THE TRINITY RIVER
THROUGH A SHIFT IN TIMING OF
DIVERSIONS THAT INCREASES
TEMPERATURES DURING CRITICAL
SPAWNING PERIODS IN THE FALL.
THIRD TO SEE A SEAT NOT SUPPORT
FAST TRACKING OF SITES AND
OTHER NEW RESERVOIRS AS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
DRAFT WATER RESILIENCE
PORTFOLIO. ADDITIONALLY THIS HE
IS HE DOES NOT SUPPORT
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AS A
REPLACEMENT FOR REGULATORY
REGULATORY FLOW REQUIREMENTS
FOR VARIOUS RIVERS THIS
APPROACH HAS FAILED IN THE PAST
IN OTHER CASES. THE NINETY FOUR
BAY DELTA ACCORD THE TWO
THOUSAND CAL FED RECORD OF
DECISION THE CALIPHATE
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER ACCOUNT AND
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN V. S. A.
FOR ORVILLE RELICENSING ARE
EXAMPLES. AND THE SALMON AND
STEELHEAD RUNS CONTINUE TO
DECLINE. REGARDING CENTRAL
VALLEY WATER OPERATIONS THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO
REVISIT PERMITS ISSUED TO THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF RECLAMATION.
THAT ALLOW IT TO DE WATER UP
240% OF THE FALL RAN REDS IN
THE UPPER SACRAMENTO AND
OVERHEAT THE RIVER TO LEVELS
LETHAL TO INCUBATING SALMON
EGGS AFTER THE WINTER RUN
TEMPERATURE CONTROL SEASON
EXPIRES. AND ENCOURAGED TO
RECALL OF REQUIRE THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION TO FIX THE
TEMPERATURE CONTROL DEVICE ON
FOLSOM DAM. FOR NEW A THE
OFFICIAL WALLET POSITIONS WE
WOULD ADVOCATE FOR PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT ECHNICAL STUDIES
PRIORITIZATION OF GRANT
PROJECTS PERMITTING AND
ESPECIALLY SUPPORT FOR
MONITORING THESE ALL SUPPORT
THEY INVESTMENT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT OF IN RESTORATION.
AND SHOWING THAT IT WORKS ONE
MINUTE. THE CSE APPLAUDS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS ON
CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS DIRECTOR
BOTTOMS BONHAM'S STE BETTER
STRONGER FASTER PROGRAM. NOW WE
WANT TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT
FOR FUNDING THE KING FISHER
FLAT HATCHERY BRUCE DOT PROGRAM
ENCOURAGE MORE FUNDING OF THAT
TYPE OF. CALIFORNIA NEEDS A
ROBUST RECOVERY WITH A
HARVESTABLE SURPLUS OF OUR
VITAL SALMON STOCKS THE SUPPORT
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE
STILL FIGHTING AN UPSTREAM
BATTLE TO EVEN REVERSE THE
DECLINE. WE THANK THE JOINT
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
COMMITTEE IN THESE TOUGH TIMES
FOR SALMON FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HELLO THANK YOU SO MUCHAND
AGAIN WELL DESERVE LAST NIGHT
PRETTY EXCITING SO VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOU WORK AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU
PROVIDER HEARING US YEAH WHEN I
TURN IT OVER TO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE OCEAN SCIENCE
TRUSTS- MISS WHITE MEN AND AT
THIS IS A REALLY NICE FOR SURE
THAT YOU IN AND OUT AS WELL.
LOOKS GREAT. THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR TELLING
THE HEARING BY AN HOUR BECAUSE
IT MEANT I GOT YOU THAT TWENTY
YEAR ANNIVERSARY REPORTS. THERE
REALLY IT'S REALLY THIS IS A
WONDERFUL REPORT BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY JUST REITERATE MY NAME IS
LIZ WHITE MEN AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE- CALIFORNIA
OCEAN SCIENCE TRUST. AND UNIQUE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
ESTABLISHED BY CALIFORNIA
STATUTE. QUICK REMINDER ABOUT
US MY ANNUAL REMINDER TO YOU-
WE BELIEVE THAT SCIENCE CAN
ACCELERATE PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
STATE VERSION OF A HEALTHY
COAST IN THE OCEAN AND- AND
HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE. AND WE
TAKE PRIDE IN AS A NON PROFIT
NIMBLE RESPONSE TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SCIENCE TO
HAVE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON THE
POLICY DOT. ORG AS A SMALL T.
IN OUR ABILITY TO POT NOT THE
DOOR ON AND- INTO THE BEST
EXPERTISE AVAILABLE AT. PLANTS
DEVISED TO THE PROTECTION
COUNCIL. OF FOCUS ON. RETURN ON
STATE AND SCIENCE INVESTMENTS
IN JUST TO. APPOINT BY
ASSEMBLYMAN SOONER. WAS THAT
MEANS I'M- VICE RECOMMEND. THAT
CA MAKE. APPROACHES THE MAKE
THE BEST. IF XIN USE OF I AM.
STATE RESOURCES. SO ABSOLUTE ON
ON ON PER STATE AS WHERE TO
DRAW IN FEDERAL FEDERAL FULLER.
AND PRY. MONEY SUPPORT OF STATE
PARTIES. SO I'VE TO PRY UPDATE
FOR YOU TODAY I AM VERY QUICKLY
FIRST WE ARE REQUIRED BY A
FUNDING LEGISLATION TO REPORT
ANNUALLY TO YOU AND TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT OUR- BI
ANNUAL REPORTS- CATCH UP MOVED.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH TIME TO HIGHLIGHT
TO ANY ONE THING FOM THAT
REPORTS I WANTED TO MENTION
THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION. WITH SCIENTIFIC
PEER REVIEWS OF THE FISHERY
MANAGEMENT PLANS ALL COMPONENTS
WITHIN AND DO OUR PART TO
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE FOR TREES.
IT'S A LOW OUT BY MANY I'M-
PLAYED IT COOL AND BIGGER ROLE
IN. ABOUT BUT THE FEW YEARS
WE'RE PROUD OF OUR SMALL PIECE-
TO DEVELOP A PEER REVIEW
PROCESS- IN WHICH THE SCIENCE
AND THE OUTCOME. BENEFITTED
FROM THE INPUT OF STAKEHOLDER
PERSPECTIVES SOMETHING THAT IF
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE WORLD
OF CLASSIC PEER REVIEW IN THE
SCIENCE. COMMUNITY IS JUST A
WORLD APART FROM THE CLASSIC
EXPECTATIONS. AND I THINK THE
PRINCIPLES OF- SORT OF
INCLUSION OF A DIVERSE SET OF
EXPERTISE AND- IT THAT PROCESS.
FULL TO OTHER TOPICS THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT HERE TODAY. AND MY
SECOND UPDATE TO IS TO ANNOUNCE
THAT- I WOULD MY NOTES SAY THIS
MORNING BUT IT WAS THAT SHE
THIS AFTERNOON- WE RELEASED OUR
TWENTY YEAR ANNIVERSARY
REPORTS- I HAVE COPIES HERE AND
IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. IN IT WE REFLECT ON
THE SUCCESSES AND IMPACT OF THE
LAST TWO DECADES BUT I WANTED
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY O
THANK ALL MANY POT KNOWS FROM
THE STATE'S INCLUDING THE OCEAN
PROTECTION. AND SO I COULD GIVE
ME A NONPROFIT SON PRIVATE
INDUSTRY- ALSO THIS IS A REALLY
ONLY A RESULT OF THE STRENGTH
OF OUR PARTNERSHIPS. I HOPE
THIS WILL CAN ANCHOR ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
STRENGTHEN NOT SCIENCE SUPPORT
DIRECTLY OF THE LEGISLATURE-
MOVING FROM WHAT HAS BEEN IN
THE PAST- AS IS USEFUL FOR AD
pSERVING AS A SCIENCE RESOURCE
IN A MORE SUSTAINED FASHION. WE
HAD INTENDED TO FOSTER THIS
DIALOGUE AND LEARN MORE ABOUT
YOUR SCIENCE NEEDS AND THE
VALUE OF A SCIENCE RESOURCE TO
YOU- AT A BRIEFING NEXT WEEK
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO HOST OF
THAT BUT I. UNFORTUNATELY
POSTPONED AT EVENTS LIKE SO THE
OTHERS WOULD BE. BURNED UNTIL
LATE THE OR FALL. MY TEAM KEEPS
TELLING ME THAT WE TURNED
TWENTY ALL YEAR SIR WE LOOK
FORWARD TO RE ENGAGING WITH
YOU- IN THAT CONVERSATION. AND
THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH IN DEBT
WE- POSTED. IN REPORT ON TO. I
JOIN COMMITTEES WEBSITE AS WELL
SO VERY. FOR THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE TO THE
VICE CHAIR TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE VICE CHAIR.
I'M UP WITH US ABOUT JUST
HEALTH OF THE OCEAN- WHETHER
IT'S THE ISSUE OF URCHINS-
ABALONE. KELP WE TAKE A LOOK
AT- THE WARM WATER BLOB AND HOW
THAT IS IMPACTED- THE CRAB
FLEET. IT'S AN UNPRECEDENTED
TIME THAT WE LIVE ANY COMMENTS
ON THAT- IN AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
I WILL COMMENT ON URCHIN SO I
I'VE- THE CRAB FISHERMEN ARE
SEEING A FEW STARFISH COMING
BACK AND THEY ARE THE MAIN
PREDATOR ON THE PURPLE URCHINS
THAT ARE. EATING A LOT OF THE
HELP THAT'S GREAT- THE PURPLE
URCHINS CAN LIVE FOR TEN YEARS
WITHOUT EATING AND THEY HAVE
TEETH THAT CAN SHE THREW ROCKS
AND ABALONE SHELLS. THEY'RE
VERY PROLIFIC AND- THEY NEED
THAT TOP PREDATOR TO KEEP FROM
HAVING NO OF CASCADE YEAH NO
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. PLEASE
I'LL TAKE A STAB AT IT AND THAT
IS WHAT I'M HEARING FROM THE
FISHERMEN OR THAT IS CHANGING
IN OCEAN CONDITIONS I MEAN I
TALKED TO MY SALMON- FISHMAN.
SOMETIMES THEY THEY SAY THAT
THE ANSWER OR UPDATE THE UP TO
WELLINGS OF WHICH WE HEARD OUR
OKAY. SOME ASSEMBLY IT'S BODY
THE WARMING TRENDS ARE STILL
THERE. BUT FOR THE URGENT
DIVERS THE OCEAN ACIDIFICATION
IS SOMETHING TAT HASN'T BEEN
MENTIONED BUT THAT IS A VERY
BIG CONCERN SOFTENING OF THE
SHELLS. MAYBE THAT IS. LEADING
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES OF THE
LONGER LASTING ON DEPRESSION
THAT WE'RE WE'RE FINDING WHERE-
WITH RECOVERY IS TAKING LONGER
SO. THERE'S LOTS OF LOTS OF
ISSUES GOING ON AND PROBABLY
TOO MANY TO REPORT BACK HERE.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO BE MINDFUL
THAT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
DC TF BUT I THOUGHT I MIGHT
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AT PC'S FEBRUARY
TWENTY SIXTH MEETING. THAT
COUNCIL APPROVED ITS STRATEGIC
PLAN. FOR TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN THE FOUR
MAIN GOALS WITHIN THAT PLAN
ARE. CLIMB IT BIO DIVERSE CITY
EQUITY IN THE BLUE ECONOMY SO
THE COUNCIL'S REALLY USING NOT
TO GUIDE ITS COAST IN OCEAN
PROTECTION MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. PLEASE AND I GUESS
I'LL I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
OCEAN HEALTH CONVERSATIONS FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE AND I'LL
I'LL SEE YOU AND RAISE YOU TO
AND TO SORT OF A NEW WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT OCEAN HEALTH I
THINK THE CONVERSATION IS
INCREASINGLY TURNING TO. TO ONE
OF OCEAN RESILIENCE AN
ADAPTATION THAT DRAWS IN THOSE
THE SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND HUMAN
DIMENSIONS AS WELL. AND I
THINK- THAT THAT'S UP TO ME-
PRODUCTIVE VENUE FOR. ADVANCING
ON WHAT IS AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS
SAID A CHANGING OCEAN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WHAT IS IT THANK
YOU TO OUR PANEL THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME THANK YOU FOR
DRIVE IN IN TODAY AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOUR HERE
AND WE APOLOGIZE. ABOUT
STARTING THE TODAY SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH IF I
MAY IT'S POSSIBLE THE OCEAN HAS
A LIMIT TO HOW MUCH CARBON
DIOXIDE. SORT YOU RIGHT NO.
THANK YOU. VERY VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT WELL THAT'S THE PROBLEM
THOUGH IS THAT I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT IS IT'S JUST CAN WE
SURVIVE IF IT ABSORBS BEYOND A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF CARBON
DIOXIDE THE ORIGINAL FUNCTION
BUT CAN WE FUNCTION WITH IT.
YES ALL RIGHT SO WHAT WE LIKE
TO DO NOW IS OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ANY INDIVIDUAL
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD AT THIS TIME YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES YOU CAN JUST GIVE
US YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
ONE TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT
HE'S THE CIEF CONSULTANT FOR
THE FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
COMMITTEE I THINK MANY GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE HIS NAME IS
TOM JONES THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
HARD. TOM REALLY IS. THE SOLID
HE IS THE ROCK OF THIS. JOINT
COMMITTEE AND WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE. OF YOUR WORK.
EACH AND EVERY YEAR THIS WOULD
NOT HAPPEN WITHOUT YOU. BOTTOM
LINE. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER WAS SLOW AS WELL WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL. LET'S OPEN IT UP
FOR. A PUBLIC COMMENTS WE
WELCOME YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. DAVID
HELLO ALL. COMMERCIAL SALMON
CRAB AND- ROCKFISH FISHERMEN.
AND I'LL START OUT WITH MY ASK
WHICH WOULD BE WOULD YOU ASK
THE OPC TO PROVIDE A STUDY OF
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT OF
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY TO
FISHERIES. AND A PROPOSAL TO
MITIGATE. AND THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO SAY WAS. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE A COMPLEMENT OF THE
WELL INTO WHAT ISSUE. NOT
CURRENTLY ADDRESS WHICH IS THE
DEMONIC ACID LEVEL IN WALES.
AND THE EFFECT THAT HAS ON
ENTITLEMENTS. IN THE FIFTY
YEARS I'VE BEEN FISHING ONE OF
FISH AROUND WHALES THEY KNOW
THEIR BUSINESS. AND I'VE BEEN
WORD MULTIPLE TIMES THEY WOULD
TAKE MY GEAR OFTEN THEY DON'T
AND ALL IT IS A VERY THIN STEEL
WIRE WITH THE BALL WAY OUT THE
BOTTOM AND THEY JUST GO RIGHT
BY AND THEY DON'T TOUCH. SO IT
SEEMS LIKE TO ME. ANOTHER
COMPONENT INVOLVED IN THIS.
INTEREST THANK YOU NO THANK YOU
NFL BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
HANGING WITH US FOR SO LONG.
THANK YOU HATE GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS MARK SMITH
ACTUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S TODAY THEY WERE
MENTIONED EARLIER BY JOHN
MCMANUS- THE ORGANIZATION DID
PUT OUT A VIDEO RECENTLY TALKED
ABOUT. HATCHERY MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO PICK A FIGHT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT BUT WE
DEFINITELY HAVE SOME
DISAGREEMENTS ON THE WAY THAT
WE ARE HANDLING OUR HATCHERIES
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH SOME
OF THESE HATCHERY FISH. LIKE
THIS VIDEO TO BETTER I ALONG
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND WE'D
LIKE YOUR COMMITTEE HONESTLY TO
BE INVOLVED IN THAT- UPDATE
ISN'T IT. I REQUEST ABOUT IT
BUT WE- GIVE THAT THERE ARE
PRACTICES WE COULD HAVE. ON
ENHANCE OUR FISHERIES- AND THAT
WOULD NOT COST US A LOT OF
MONEY BECAUSE THAT'S ALWAYS THE
LIMITING FACTOR WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE THINGS ARE PARTNERS A
PC FFA AND- G. SSA AND THE
OTHER RECREATIONAL SPORT
FISHING GROUPS OF THINK WOULD.
SOLVE THE AGREE WITH US. THAT
BRINGS ME TO MY REQUEST. JUST
WANT TO ADVISE YOU THAT WE
EXPECT TO SEND A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE ASKING YOU TO HOLD A
HEARING PERHAPS THIS YEAR OR AT
THE BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR ON.
THE STATE OF OUR RECREATIOAL
FISHERY- THIS IS A GREAT
HEARING TODAY- WE HAVE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SPORTFISHING-
THAT TAKES PLACE IN THE OCEAN
AND SOME OF IT IN LONDON HOW
DECISIONS MANAGEMENT DECISIONS
THAT ARE MADE. ARE OFTEN MADE
IN CONCERT WITH- BOTH
ENVIRONMENTS PRICKLY FOR
ANADROMOUS SPECIES BUT- WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE A HEARING FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ON INLAND
RECREATIONAL SPORT FISHING-
THAT'S- BASS STRIPED BASS BLACK
BASS IN THE DELTA. SAM IN OUR
INLAND RIVERS IT'S OUR KOKANEE
PROGRAMS IT'S OUR TROUT
PROGRAMS. IT'S ALL OF THOSE
THINGS- AND YOU KNOW IN THAT
WE'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT. PREPS
REASONS WHY THE NUMBER OF
ANNUAL ANGLING LICENSES THAT IS
SOLD HAVE GONE DOWN BY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE. WE'D LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT RECREATIONAL.
OPPORTUNITY WOULD LIKE TALK
ABOUT HOW HATCHERIES CAN MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS SO. I THINK THE
COMMUNITY. THE RECREATIONAL
GROUPS WILL SEND THAT LETTER
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
DIALOGUE WITH YOU ON THAT
THANKS AGAIN FOR POSTING
TODAY'S FORM. IF YOU SOME
INTEREST IT'S GOOD TO SEE LAW
NIGHT WITH A FOR THAT LETTER
WILL BE ON. THE LOOKOUT FOR SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
IT'S GOOD TO SEE SIR. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANKS FOR HANGING
WITH US HELLO AGAIN- I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE TIME
YOU'VE TALKED TO- TALK WITH ME
LAST NIGHT MY NAME IS. KIM
ZELKO I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMERCIAL
FISHERMEN OF SANTA BARBARA- OUR
PORT ASSOCIATION AND I'M ALSO A
MARINE SCIENTIST AFFILIATED
WITH UCSB. THE OWNER OF A
COMMUNITIES OF FISHER PROGRAM
GET. AND I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU
AN UPDATE ON OUR LOBSTER
FISHERY OURS CALIFORNIA SPINY
LOBSTER FISHERY HAS HAD A VERY
TOUGH YEAR- WE HAVE NORMALLY A-
THE- DOCKSIDE PRICE OF TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS A POUND- TO THE
FISHERMEN. IT FELL TO ABOUT
TWELVE DOLLARS A POUND TO THE
CHINESE RETALIATES TERRY-
TERRACE IN THE FALL WHEN THE-
SEASON OPENED AND THEN. IN
GETTING READY FOR CHINESE NEW
YEAR OF THE PRICE FELL THE
AGAIN TO ABOUT EIGHT DOLLARS
WHEN TRYING TO CLOSE THE MARKET
DUE TO CORONA VIRUS- SO IT
EFFECTIVELY ENDED OUR SEASON.
OF IN THIS FOLLOWS ON CLOSURES
THAT HAPPENED AS LAST SEASON
FROM DEMO OKAY ACID AS WELL SO
WE'VE HAD A TOUGH TIME AND I
WANT TO BRING THAT TO YOUR
ATTENTION. OR SOUTHERN
FISHERIES DOWN OFF OFTEN GET
NOTICED- UP HERE. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE LEARNED FROM
THE URCHIN FISHING IS THAT
GETTING A DOMESTIC MARKET GOING
CAN BE VERY HELPFUL WITH THESE
HUGE GLOBAL FLUCTUATIONS IN
MARKETS. ARE LOBSTER MARKET- IS
ENTIRELY AN EXPORT MARKET AND
WE REALLY NEED NEW TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS TO. MARK FOR
LAPSED. THAT WOULD. BEING ABLE
TO TAKE ALL THE LOBSTER OR DO
OTHER PROCESSING IT WOULD
CREATE PRODUCTS LIKE FOR MY- A
COMMUNITY SUPPORTED FISSURED
LOVE TO MAKE LOBSTER RAVIOLI
LOBSTER STOCK IN THAT IS
COMPLETELY. NOT ALLOWED AN
OFFICIATING CODE EVEN THE- IN
LOBSTER. ZOOMER AS- A
MEASURABLE PRODUCTS- AND SO I'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE FISHING
GAME. ON CHANGING THIS THIS
YEAR- AND I HOPE THAT WOULD
HAVE YOUR SUPPORT- ANOTHER
THING THAT COULD REALLY HELP IS
TO ADD TO SB. ONE OF ELEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT- THAT PROVIDES FOR
EVISCERATION OF DUNGENESS CRAB
IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS WHEN TO
MOW GRASS IS A PROBLEM- ADD TO
THAT LOBSTER AND- ROCK CRAB A
ROCK CRABS SUFFERS THE SAME
FATE AS DUNGEON S. UNDER DEMOC
ACID EVENTS. AND YET THERE'S NO
MENTION OF ROCK CRAB OR LOBSTER
IN SP. ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT SO I
HOPE WE CAN REMEDY THAT AND
THAT'LL PUT US ON A PATHWAY TO-
HOPING WHETHER DOMESTIC MARKETS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME.
OUT YESTERDAY EVENING. HAPPY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ON ROCK
CRAP- THE DISSERTATION ON THE
LOBSTER SIDE AND- ON THE OTHER
ISSUE HAD MENTIONED SO IF YOU
WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH LOVE TO
TALK WITH YOU- IN HAPPY SIT
DOWN ANY TIME. GREAT THINGS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING A
TOWARD TENSION APPRECIATE YOU
HANGING TODAY. WHO ELSE WOULD
LIKE YOU TO MAKE COMMENT WE
WELCOME YEAH- TO COME ON BOARD
FIRST LAST NAME. ALL RIGHT HERE
IN SEE NUMBER GOING TO BE ABLE
TO- CLOSE THE HEARING BUT
BEFORE WE DO WE TAKE THEIR TURN
OVER THE VICE CHAIR. FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS MISTER VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR DEDICAION TO THIS. I
JOINT COMMITTEE IN FOR ALL OF
YOUR WORK SIR LOVE WORKING WITH
YOUR FLOOR SHORES. I THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOU'RE WILLING
TO MOVE AT THESE ARE ALWAYS
VERY INTERESTING. HEARINGS I
CERTAINLY LEARNED A LOT AND-
BUT UNDERSTANDING KIND OF
COMMON THREADS AS WE GO TO YEAR
TO YEAR. BUT ALWAYS THE- THE
NEW. TAKE ON WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GO FORWARD I JUST APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY. BEING HERE BEING
WILLING TO. COME SACRAMENTO.
PARTICIPATED HEARING AND BEING.
OPEN AND STRAIGHTFORWARD AS YOU
ALWAYS ARE WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT WE GET SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE-
PARTICIPANTS FOR BEARING WITH
US AND SITTING THROUGH. A LONG
HEARING. AND I JUST HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO. A GOOD JOB OR A
BETTER JOB OF TAKING WHAT WE
LEARNED. PUTTING IT IN A POLICY
WORKING WITH THE STATE
AGENCIES. AND WORKING ON THE
STRENGTH OF THE FISHERIES.
INDUSTRY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITH VICE CHAIR VERY GRATEFUL I
WOULD LIKE TO GET A- LOOK AT
SOME OF OUR FOLLOW UP FROM TWO
DAYS SO- WERE GOING TO BE
SETTING UP A MEETING. WITH THE
DIRECTOR FROM DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES IN SECRETARY
CROWFOOT. ON THERMAL LIDO
ANOTHER MILITA PROJECT WE'VE
ALREADY. RECEIVED A
CORRESPONDENCE FROM SECRETARY'S
OFFICE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SETTING UP THE MEETING. WITH US
HERE SO- WE'RE MOVING ON THAT
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT. WE
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP BUT WITH A
FOCUS ON ALL OFFSHORE WIND- AND
CONTINUED OUR CONVERSATION ON A
POTENTIAL BUDGET REQUEST. HAD
WAITED DO A STATEWIDE-
ENVIRONMENTAL IN SCOPING.
SURVEY FOR ALL PORTS. THAT CAN
BE ONE OF OUR FOLLOW UPS WE
LOOK FORTY HEARING- MORE ON AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN IT WILL
DEFINITELY GO BACK AND TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT- AND- IF THAT IS
ACTUALLY SPOT BILL AND WHAT WE
NEED. TO DO IF IT'S NOT OPEN.
UP THESE- LET US KNOW- MISTER
SMITH IS GOING TO GET US SOME
INFORMATION ON HIS REQUEST FOR
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING. ON
THE RECORD DON'T. PUSH IT ST.
IN THE FALL WITH THE GOOD FOLKS
FROM BARBARA I WITH LOTS IS
WELL AS CRAP TO ISSUES A LOT
ONE IS ON CRAP. WAS ANYTHING I
MAY IT MISSED ON OUR FOLLOW UPS
MISTER WESLEY. YEAH FOLLOWING
UP ON THE DISASTER REQUEST FOR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THAT SIR
WHAT IT SPEND PLAN WORKING WITH
MORE. PM IF WE GET THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. MEETING FOR
SHELLFISH NO THAT'S ARE IN THE
WORKS OF BUT YEAH YEAH
ABSOLUTELY YEP. STIR AND WEAK.
RIGHT ISSUES HERE CAPTION ALL
RIGHT HELLO THROUGH THE NOTES
TO MAKE SURE THAT'S WHAT
WONDERFUL AGAIN THANK YOU ALL
FOR TAKING THE TIME THANK YOU
FOR THE STAMINA TODAY FOR HANG
IN WITH US- IN AGAIN I'LL SAY
IT ONE LAST TIME AND SUB PAUL
YES- I'M SO SORRY WE STARTED
LATE TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND WE LOOK FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS TO COME. THIS MEANS THE
CHURCH.
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE.